Scholastic Audio presents Wings of Fire
Book 4.
The Dark Secret.
By 2AT Sutherland.
Read by Shannon McManus.
The Dragonette Prophecy.
When the war has lasted 20 years, the
dragonettes will come, when the land is
soaked in blood and tears, the
dragonettes will come.
Find the sea wing egg of deepest blue
wings of night shall come to you.
The largest egg in mountain high will
give to you the wings of sky.
For wings of earth, search through the
mud, for an egg the color of dragon
blood.
And hidden alone from the rival queens.
The sand wing egg awaits unseen.
Of 3 queens who blister and blaze and
burn.
Two shall die, and one shall learn, If
she bows to a fate that is stronger and
higher, Shall have the power of wings of
fire.
Five eggs to hatch on brightest night
five dragons born to end the fight.
Darkness will rise to bring the light.
The dragonettes are coming.
Prologue.
The ice dragons came out of nowhere.
It should have been a quiet night.
They shouldn't have seen anyone but Sky
Wings and other mud wings on their patrol
along the mountainous border between
their kingdoms.
There hadn't been a battle near their
village since the one where they lost
Crane, 16 days ago.
Reed still couldn't think about that
battle without feeling a huge pit open
inside his chest.
Sometimes he wanted to close his eyes and
fall into that pit and never come out.
But he couldn't.
He had 4 other brothers and sisters who
depended on him.
He was their leader.
Their big wings.
Even though he knew now that he wasn't
supposed to be.
It should have been their brother, Clay
whose egg was stolen before they all
hatched.
Did you hear that?
Umber whispered.
Darting up to fly beside him.
The smallest dragon in their mud wing
troop of siblings, Umber was also the
most observant.
Reid knew by now that it was always worth
listening to him.
What?
Reed whispered back, tilting his head and
straining his ears.
His wings caught the air currents as they
both soared higher, and he studied the
dark, jagged shapes of the claws of the
clouds mountains.
He couldn't see any movement or hear any
wing beats.
Still, he twisted around to check on his
brothers and sisters, calling them closer
with a flick of his tail.
In a moment, Pheasant, Sora, and Marsh
were flying in a close formation behind
him.
I thought I heard hissing, Umber said
somewhere close by.
Reed glanced down uneasily at the shadowy
trees that covered the mountain slope
below them.
Anything could be hiding in there.
But the only sound he heard was the
sandwing general up ahead, calling it top
volume, as if stealth patrol were only a
funny name for what they were doing.
Move it, Mudwings. bellowed the sand
dragon.
His squadron of 7 sandwings, all fiercely
loyal to Queen Byrne, hovered behind him
grunting.
I want to wrap up this patrol and get
some sleep tonight.
It was probably nothing, Umber said to
read.
And that was when the 9 ice dragons
suddenly shot out of the forest and
attacked the sand wings.
It was so fast, so calculated, and swift
and sudden, that 2 sand wings were sent
spiraling toward the ground with shredded
wings and blood pouring from their
throats before Reed could even process
that this was a real attack.
Marsh shrieked with terror and grabbed
Reed, nearly tumbling the big wings out
of the sky.
Marsh had never really recovered from
their 1st battle, where he'd seen their
sister crane die in front of him.
I need to do something about that.
Reed thought, but not right now.
Marsh, keep it together, he shouted
pulling his wing free.
Come on, quick, we have to help.
He saw the hesitation on all their faces
and caught himself wondering, again, what
Clay would have done in this situation
and whether the others would have been
happier and safer following him, and also
wondering whether they were wondering
that too.
But no one said what they must be
thinking.
It's a suicide mission.
What help can we be?
I don't want to lose another sibling.
Instead, they formed up behind him and
dove toward the writhing dragons.
Reed hated fighting ice wings.
Their serrated claws seemed 10 times
sharper than normal claws, and their whip
thin tails left stinging marks across the
snout and wings.
Worst of all, they could just breathe on
you and kill you.
He shot a burst of fire at the biggest
ice wing, who was grappling with the sand
wing general.
Her teeth snapped shut and she hissed at
him, but she was too busy with the
sandwing to come after Reed.
He spun in the air, lashing out at
silvery white scales as another ice wing
attacked his flank.
They clutched each other with fierce
talons for a moment, the wind buffeting
their wings.
Finally, Reed managed to cough out
another bolt of flames, and the ice wing
jerked away, narrowly avoiding a singed
nose.
Reed spotted an ice wing diving toward
umber, and leads to knock his brother
aside, catching the brunt of the white
dragon's momentum against his chest.
As he staggered back, he saw another ice
wing wrap her dangerous claws around
Sora's neck, and he roared with fury.
Pheasant was there in an instant, throwing
the ice wing off Sora, but the ice dragon
came back at them with her mouth open to
shoot her frost breath.
I can't lose anyone else.
Reed thought.
It'll kill me.
He smashed into the ice wing's side and
sliced his claws across her throat while
she was twisting to breathe on him.
Her eyes went wide, and she made an
agonized, gargling noise as blood bubbled
from the wounds.
When he let go of her, the ice wing
soldier fell toward the dark forest, her
wings twitching feebly, like a dying
grasshopper.
Retreat!
A voice suddenly howled.
Reed's heart jumped hopefully, thinking
the ice wings were giving up, but then he
realized it was the sand wing general.
Retreat!
The sand dragon yelled again.
Reed thought they might defeat the ice
wing so they kept fighting, but it wasn't
worth the risk.
Every moment was another opportunity for
an ice wing to kill one of his brothers
or sisters.
Retreating meant keeping them alive.
Retreat, he echoed the general, grabbing
umber and pulling him back.
Fall back.
Pheasant, you too.
He scanned the struggling shapes in the
moonlight, and picked out his troop, all
still alive, for now.
His sister sank her teeth into her
opponent's forearm, and he released her
with a shriek of pain.
In a flash, she was at Reed's side, and
they soared up into the sky with Marsh
Sora, and Umber right beside them.
Reed saw the sand wings take off toward
the mountains.
Most of the ice wings shot after them.
Only 2 turned to pursue him and his
siblings.
This way, he cried, diving for the
forest.
If ice wings could hide in there, so
could his dragons, he wasn't obligated to
follow the sand wings.
They'd probably make a run for the Sky
Palace anyway, and he didn't want to lead
the ice wings back to his village.
Pine branches whipped against his face as
he hit the trees.
His brothers and sisters had practiced a
formation like this.
Zipping through an overgrown forest while
staying together, he had to trust that
they'd remember and be close behind him.
He heard the sound of thrashing wings
farther back, and risked a glance over
his shoulder.
Even in the shadows, he recognized the
shape of how his brothers and sisters
flew.
They were all there.
It must be the ice wings who'd gotten
caught in the upper branches.
Reed took a chance and landed.
The others dropped to the ground with him
and they all immediately flattened
themselves with wings outstretched
becoming puddles of shadow on the dark
forest floor.
Silence fell.
No one breathed.
The branches creaked overhead, and small
night animals skittered through the
bushes around them.
Reed felt a squirrel dart over his foot
but he didn't move a muscle.
After a long while, they heard a far away
whistle, and the sound of wings in the
distance, as if the ice wings had
reassembled to fly away.
Reed still didn't move.
He waited for almost an hour until he
couldn't hold his breath any longer, until
any and all dragon noises had faded long
ago.
Then, very carefully and quietly, he
inhaled, he heard the others do the
same.
Is anyone hurt?
Reed asked softly.
That was awful, Marsh whispered.
I thought we were all going to die.
I'm fine, Pheasant said.
Nothing that won't heal soon.
I'm all right, too.
Sora said hoarsely.
Umber, Reed said, when the smallest
dragonette didn't respond.
I hate this war, Umber burst out.
I don't understand what we're even
fighting for.
Who cares who the sand wing queen is?
I've never met Bern and I don't want to.
Why am I fighting an ice wing over a
throne that has nothing to do with either
of us?
Because our queen says we have to.
Pheasant said, with a little more sarcasm
than Reed thought was safe, even if there
was no one to overhear.
Queen Moorhead must have a good reason
for aligning with Burne in the Sky Wings
Reed said.
We shouldn't doubt her.
Besides, the war will be over soon.
Sora said unexpectedly.
She hardly ever spoke, and she'd spoken
even less since Crane's death.
Reed turned and saw her eyes reflecting
the glow of the moonlight.
Clay is going to end it.
There was something about the way she
said Clay's name that made Reed want to
sink into a mud puddle and stay there for
a month.
She sounded as if she believed in him so
much.
A dragon they'd barely met.
They followed Reed, and they loved him.
He knew that.
But surely they must wonder what could
have been.
And whether Crane might still be alive, if
Clay were their big wings all along.
That's true, Umber said, lifting his
head.
Clay and his friends, they're going to
save us soon.
How soon?
Marsh asked.
I thought the prophecy said 20 years.
Doesn't that mean 2 more years before
they end the war?
Actually, Pheasant said.
Some dragons think it depends on when you
start counting.
If you count from the 1st battle, then
it's only been 18 years.
But if you go back to the death of Queen
Oasis, which is really when this whole
thing started, then it's been almost 20.
She caught the tilt of Reed's head and
shrugged.
I've been reading about the prophecy
since we realized clay is in it.
There was a pause, as they all had their
own thoughts about clay.
The war, and the prophecy.
If you're all unhappy, Reed said
tentatively, we could, I mean, we could
try to find the talons of peace.
Pheasant let out a shocked hiss.
I may not like this war, but that doesn't
mean we should leave our tribe and our
home.
We are mud wings.
We belong in our village.
Unless you think we should leave.
Marsh said, leaning against Reed's side.
I'll do whatever you decide.
We all will.
Umber said.
Reed knew they would, but should they?
He had no idea what to do.
Betray his tribe or keep risking his
siblings' lives.
You don't have to decide tonight, Pheasant
said, more gently.
We just had a narrow escape.
Let's go home and sleep.
Will all feel better in the morning.
Reed nodded, and they gathered themselves
stretching their cramped wings as best
they could under the trees.
Showers of pine needles slid across their
scales, smelling of winter fires.
What were those ice wings doing here
anyway?
Marsh asked, stamping his feet.
I have no idea, Reed said.
It seemed as though they were lying in
wait for us, but it's not like we're an
important patrol.
Perhaps they were here for something else
and we were unlucky enough to attract
their attention.
Maybe they were here for the scavenger
den, Umber said.
What scavenger den?
Reed glanced at him?
Surprised?
Can't you smell it?
Umber asked.
We flew over part of it too.
It's pretty well hidden in the forest.
How do you notice something like that in
the middle of a frantic escape?
Pheasant demanded.
Umber shrugged.
Why would the ice wings care about a
scavenger den?
Sora asked softly.
They all thought for a moment, then
looked at Reed.
I don't know.
He said helplessly.
It felt like he was saying that all the
time these days.
Well, Pheasant said, spreading her
wings.
It doesn't matter.
What matters is we survived another
battle, thanks to Reed.
I wonder if they really feel that way, he
thought.
I certainly don't.
I hope we survived the next one, Marsh
said gloomily.
I hope we don't have to.
Umber said.
I hope Clay fulfills the prophecy and
ends the war and saves the world really
soon. before we have to do any more
fighting.
Don't you think?
Maybe he will.
Maybe.
Pheasant said.
I hope so.
I do too, Reed said.
He looked up at the stars.
Before the war takes anyone else I care
about. before our village is destroyed
before I have to choose between loyalty
to my tribe and the safety of my brothers
and sisters.
Before we have to kill anyone else.
I hope so too.
Part one, the secret plan.
Where is she?
Starflight suspected that he might be
dead, except that everything hurts so
much, darkness pressed against his eyes
whenever he tried to open them.
His nose and throat ached in a fierce, raw
way as if they'd been scraped out with a
crocodile tail.
Is she all right?
He couldn't remember what he'd dreamed
and what was real?
Perhaps he was still under the mountain.
Perhaps his friends had never tried to
escape their guardians.
Maybe this was one long nightmare that
had started with a threat of Maru Seer's
visit.
But Starflight was sure he could remember
the large night wing taking him aside.
There was a lecture about how Nightwings
have a reputation to uphold, and
Nightwings are natural leaders, and you
must make the others respect you, fear
you, and follow you, or you'll be the
greatest disappointment our tribe has
ever produced.
Starflight couldn't have conjured that
from his own brain.
That was all real.
He crawled onto his side and felt jagged
rocks press into his scales.
Was the Skywing Palace reel?
The dragonettes captured before even
tasting sunlight?
The prison on the tower of rock, the
baking hot arena sands that smelled of
blood and terror.
Queen Scarlet's delight at capturing him
a real night wing out in the world, and
her plans to make him fight, and her
excitement about the prospect of watching
him die.
No, that had to be real, because
Starflight remembered being rescued by
the night wings.
He remembered watching his friends turn
into small dots below him, blue and brown
and bright, and he knew it was real
because it felt so much like this felt, as
if he were a scroll ripped in half down
the middle, so none of the words made any
sense anymore.
Will I ever see her again?
I hope she's not here.
I hope she's safe somewhere.
I think there's something wrong with
him.
Was that a voice?
He tried to listen, but his dreams
dragged him back down.
There had been another stern lecture for
Morrow Seer.
It was essential for Starflight to be the
leader of the Dragonettes.
Everything depended on him.
And a new order.
He must convince the others to choose
blister as the next sandwing queen.
Maybe, they killed him by accident.
That'd be all right.
Maybe I'll get to be in the prophecy
instead.
I don't think that's how it works, fierce
teeth.
And then there was the kingdom of the
sea.
No one would listen to him.
He couldn't lead anyone.
His friend practically laughed at him
when he tried to support blister.
Another prison.
Another escape where Starflight did just
about nothing to help, and then the
rainforest, and the strange, unnatural
tunnels, one to the kingdom of sand, and
one, apparently, to the secret home of
the night wings.
That, Starflight remembered.
He remembered staring up at it.
The dark hole in the tree that led to a
home he'd never seen.
I bet he'd wake up if I bit him.
I bet Morrow seer would throw you in the
volcano if he found toothmarks on his
prophecy pet.
I bet my mum would have him for lunch if
he tried.
He was definitely hearing voices.
Unfamiliar voices very close by.
The memory of the rainforest was
blurring.
Starflight tried to fix his mind on it.
On those last moments, guarding the
tunnel so the night wings wouldn't come
through and attack the rain wings.
What had happened?
Well, he'd better wake up and be
interesting soon, or Mo see it will take
him away again before we get to ask him
anything.
Ooh, I have an idea.
Claus scrabbled on rock, and then there
was quiet.
Starflights eyelids felt too heavy to
open, as if extra scales were piled on
top of them.
He let the darkness drift up over him
again.
Right, guarding the hole with clay.
Morning sunbeams flickering through the
green leaves, octopus blue flowers
turning their heads up to the light.
Sunny was back in the village, with
tsunami, watching glory try to become
queen of the rain wings, of all things.
Sonny had brought them food the night
before, her golden scales brushing
against his dark wings as she passed him
strange little purple fruits.
I love you, he would never say.
Don't hate me because of what the other
night wings have done.
Don't think I'm like my tribe.
Don't listen to Glory's description of my
kingdom, the smoke and the fire, and the
smell and the death, and the trapped
tortured rain wings, and the cruel black
dragons.
Don't look at me like I'm one of them.
Like I could ever do what they've done.
Please.
And then she'd glanced up at him and
smiled, and in Sonny's eyes, he could see
himself as Starflight, just find the way
he was.
Her friend.
Which made everything better and worse
all at the same time.
Careful.
Oh, I'm not going back for more of you
spill it, idiot.
Get your great honking wings out of my
way then, fathead.
The voices again.
Starflight caught at the memories, trying
to remember the last thing that had
happened before everything went dark.
He'd been staring at the hole, wondering
what the other night wings were really
like, wondering if they were all as scary
as morrow seer.
Wondering if he went through and talked
to them, whether they would listen.
What if he could stop the night wings and
rain wings from fighting?
What if his tribe understood him and
believed in him?
What if they thought it was better to be
smart than brave?
What if they didn't care that he had no
special night wing powers?
What would Sonny think of me then?
She'd probably think, who are you?
And what have you done with Starflight?
Because there was no way he'd ever be
brave enough to go through that tunnel on
his own.
And then Clay had yelped, did you see
that?
I think it was a boar.
I'll be right back.
And poor Ever Hungry Clay had charged off
into the trees, leaving Starflight to
watch the hole alone.
In a heartbeat, Dark Wings had boiled out
of the hole.
Dark claws had circled his snout.
A dark voice had hissed in his ear.
Silence.
If you want your friend to live.
Another dark voice, better saved than
sorry.
Although he had made a sound, and he'd
known it would hurt right before the blow
struck his head, and pain blazed through
him, and that was the last thing he
splash.
Starflight jolted up with a yell, his
eyes popped open, freezing salt water
cascaded over his snout, and snaked down
his neck, seeping into his scales.
The muddled, heavy feeling vanished in an
instant.
It worked, cheered one of the unfamiliar
voices.
Trat, said another.
I really thought he was dead.
Starflight shook his head, and the pain
ricocheted around inside.
He rubbed at a snout, trying to clear the
ocean water from his stinging eyes. 6 or
7 or maybe 8 dark blurry shapes
surrounded him.
Beyond them, glowing red light pulsed in
lines along the walls.
The freezing water had cleared his nose
for a moment, but heavy smoky air was
already pressing back in.
Who are you?
Starflight gasped or tried to?
Huh.
I thought he might attack us, said a 3rd
voice.
That's what I would do.
He doesn't look very dangerous, said
another voice skeptically.
They should have picked someone bigger
don't you think?
Bigger, and scarier, and fiercer.
Like me. said the voice, who had hoped
Starflight was dead.
You all have tiny rain wing brains.
Said yet another voice.
Starfly was losing count.
He was still inside his egg when they
took him.
They didn't know if he'd be big or scary
or even if he'd be male or female.
Otherwise, of course, they would have
picked a girl, obviously.
Like me.
Hello?
Starflight coughed.
One of the shapes came close enough for
him to make out the features. of a
disgruntled looking dragonette a year or
2 older than himself.
She poked at his mouth and peered at his
teeth, jabbed at his chest so he coughed
again, inspected his claws, and sighed
huffily.
Weak, she declared.
I'd have sent him back too.
You're just saying that because you're
hoping they'll pick you instead, said
another dragonette, pushing forward.
He padded Starflight's head in an almost
friendly way.
But prophecies don't work like that.
We'll see, she muttered.
That's fierce teeth, said the friendlier
dragonette to Starflight.
Don't mind her.
Older sisters always think they can do
whatever you're doing better than you
can.
I know.
I've got one too.
I'm mighty Claus, by the way.
Older sister?
Starfly echoed, blinking at fierce
teeth.
Yes.
This is the touching family reunion
part.
She said.
Say mother, different fathers, we
assume.
How do you feel?
She eyed him from horns to tail.
Ill, very ill.
Dying, perhaps?
What part of brightest night are you
having trouble with?
Said another dragonette behind fierce
teeth.
Haven't you been listening in class?
Events have to march the prophecies.
Hi, strange dragon, I'm mind reader, but
don't worry.
I promise I'll stay out of your head.
The older dragonette's in the room
laughed uproariously, as if this was the
most hilarious joke in Pyrea history.
The 3 dragonettes who looked younger than
Starfly rolled their eyes, like they were
used to hearing jokes that made no sense
from that group.
Starflight rubbed his wet scales
confused.
Now that his site was clearing, he could
see that he was in a long, narrow cave
lined with indentations in the rock at
regular intervals, all the right size for
dragonette beds.
He was curled on one of these, not far
from a large archway that seemed to be
the only exit from the room.
Next to him on the floor was a large
hollow stone, which was apparently what
the dragonettes had used to collect the
seawater they'd just poured all over
him.
It didn't look like a prison.
It looked like a dormitory.
Hot coals smoldered in alcoves in the
walls, lending a red glow to the room.
A skylight at each end of a cave allowed
a bit of dim gray light to filter in.
There were at least 50 sleeping spots
that Starflight could see, but only about
11 of them looked slept in.
Several had rough blankets heaped on them
in messy piles, while others were
scattered with objects that looked like
seashells and twisted bits of rock.
A few of the blanket covered beds had a
scroll lying next to them, which made
Starflights claws itch with longing.
But most of the beds were completely
bare.
Places for dragonettes, but no
dragonettes to fill them.
Starflight remembered something Maro Seer
had said offhandedly, shortly after
rescuing Starflight from the Sky Wings.
He said, We can't afford to lose any
night wings.
Even peculiar little ones.
Maybe there is something wrong with my
tribe.
Starflight thought.
Maybe they're losing Dragonette somehow.
Or not having enough of them in the 1st
place.
Everything smelled like sulfur and
decaying animals.
As fierce teeth leaned over and jabbed
his stomach again.
Starflight realized that a lot of the
decaying smell came from the
dragonettes.
They all had horrendously bad breath.
Moro Seaer's breath had never been
wonderful either, but this was much
worse.
It took all of Starflight's willpower not
to recoil when they spoke to him.
They were all so shockingly thin.
Every one of them with narrow chests
bloodshot eyes, and hacking coughs.
Even the dragonettes who survive are in
pretty bad shape.
Starflight thought.
He stretched gingerly, eyeing the door.
It didn't seem to be barricaded in any
way.
As far as Starflight could tell, he could
walk right out into the caves beyond.
There's probably a guard, he thought, or
lots of guards, or maybe something really
creepy, like Queen Coral's electric
eels.
Or a lava river, like the one that keeps
the rain wings trapped in their prison
caves.
A shiver of fear ran down his spine.
Why am I here?
He blurted.
The little crowd of dragonettes exchanged
glances.
Because you failed, fierce teeth offered
I assume.
We don't know that. mighty Claus
interjected, a couple of the big dragons
dropped you here a few hours ago, and
you've been muttering and thrashing
around ever since.
Yeah, lots of worrying about Sonny, who's
Sonny?
One of the other dragonets demanded.
Starfight considered throwing himself
into the volcano.
Another dragonette, he mumbled.
I hope she's safe.
I want to hear about the mainland.
Mind reader said eagerly.
Tell us everything.
We've heard there are trees taller than
dragons, and that in some places, the sky
is blue.
True?
False?
What's the coolest thing you've seen?
What's the best thing you've eaten?
You've never been to the mainland?
Starflight said.
Dragonettes aren't allowed to leave the
island until we're 10 years old, Mighty
Claus said.
Apparently we can't be trusted to keep
all the night wing secrets until then.
Almost in unison, all the dragonettes
snorted impatiently.
You're the only exception.
Fierce teeth said, in a voice dripping
with scorn.
Him and the other one, Mind Reader said.
I heard my mom say there was another.
I don't know any night wing secrets
Starflight said.
Oh, said mighty Claus.
I guess that's one way to make sure you
keep them.
The scrabble of claws in the hall outside
heralded the appearance. of a dragonette
smaller than the others, perhaps 3 years
old.
She raced into the room and gasped, he's
coming.
Immediately the dragonettes scattered to
their sleeping spots.
Half of them dove into their blankets and
pretended to be asleep.
A few of them grabbed their scrolls and
looked studious.
Others fussed busily with the objects
around their beds.
Fierce teeth sat down on her bed, folded
her wings, and glared at the doorway.
Starflight wished he was unconscious
again, as he heard heavy footsteps
tramping toward the room, he glanced up
at the skylight, wondering if he could
fit through it, but knowing perfectly
well he was too terrified to try.
With a scraping, hissing sound, Maro Seer
slithered into the room.
He frowned at fierce teeth, then looked
coldly down his long nose at Starflight.
Up, he snarled.
The queen of the night wings wants to see
you.
Starflights experience with Dragon Queens
thus far, had not been exactly
wonderful.
Me?
He stammered.
Now?
You mean right now?
Shouldn't I?
I mean, I'm not really prepared to, or I
I don't really look to see a queen.
I mean, maybe stop blithering and follow
me.
Morosira swept out of the cave with a
growl.
Go, go, go.
Mighty Claus hissed, flapping his wings
as Starflight hesitated.
Starflights claws caught on small holes
on the rocky floor, and he stumbled as he
chased after the giant night wing.
Volcanic rock, he thought, peering at the
walls around him.
I wonder when it last erupted.
From the rumbling under his talons, and
the heat rising through the floor, it
didn't seem like the most dormant
volcano.
Moro Seer led the way up a winding tunnel
without looking back.
My friends, Starflight started to say
Sonny and the others, are they?
The large black dragon didn't turn
around.
Starflight kept walking for a few minutes
then took a deep breath and tried again.
When can I go back?
His only answer was a snort of disgust.
Starflight swallowed his questions, and
nervously tucked his wings in.
The walls felt like they were getting
closer.
He didn't see any guards, or rivers of
lava.
He didn't see any other night wings at
all.
But as they moved along the tunnel
Starfight heard something up ahead, a
hissing, murmuring sound that grew louder
as they approached.
Dragon voices, jumbled and arguing.
Dread prickled through every scale on
Starflight's body.
If he hadn't been more terrified of what
Maro Seer would do to him, he would have
turned and bolted back down the tunnel.
Finally, Morrow Seer and Starflight
stepped through an archway into a cave
full of dragons.
The walls were packed with dragon wings
with night wings hanging from crags and
rocks and the ceiling like bats.
One by one, dark scaled dragon heads
turned toward them.
They gathered night wings fell silent.
A last voice cried, We should attack
now.
We should have attacked yesterday before
cutting off abruptly as the speaker
noticed Starflight.
Starflight wondered again if he was
dreaming, because this was his biggest
nightmare come to life, a room full of
angry night wings, all of them glaring at
him.
Watch it.
Marcio growled, a Starflight stumbled
into him, and then Starflight saw what
lay ahead of their talons.
A few steps into the cave, the rocky path
abruptly fell away on either side, leaving
only a thin strip of stone to stand on.
Below him, was a bubbling lake of glowing
orange lava.
He could feel the heat crackling along
his scales.
Moro Seer stepped back to the safety of
the doorway and prodded Starflight
forward, so the dragonette was left alone
on the spur of rock surrounded by lava.
Lava, and night wings.
And they're all reading my mind.
He thought, with another jolt of terror.
They can see all my thoughts.
They know I'm terrified and weak and
useless, and that I don't think blister
should be the next sand wing queen, and
that I think this is a horrible place to
live, and stop thinking about all the
things I don't want them to see in my
head.
With a massive effort, Starflight focused
on the details of the room around him.
Think about what you see.
Don't think about anything else.
First, there weren't actually 100s of
dragons staring at him.
He did a quick estimate, hiding his other
thoughts inside mountains of numbers.
Maybe 40.
About 40 black dragons filled the cave
most of them as large as Marosir, which
meant they must be quite old.
They were all as thin as the dragonettes
in the dormitory, and many of them had
worn patches on their scales, sores on
their snouts and wings and traces of
blood around their nostrils.
These dragons looked like the tribal
opposite of the colorful, healthy, well
fed rain wings.
There was a clear spot on the cave walls
right across from him.
It looked like a circle had been carved
into the rock as wide across as
Starflight's wingspan, and then jabbed
full of small holes, none of them bigger
than a dragon's eye.
The other dragons kept glancing at this
circle, as if waiting for it to do
something.
On a ledge beside the circle, perched a
dragon with a scar rippling down her
chest.
Her wings drooped in an odd way as if
they were weighted down with rocks, and
she wore a cluster of diamonds around her
neck.
Another chain of smaller teardrop
diamonds was wound around the horns on
her head.
But that can't be the queen?
Starflight thought.
She didn't have authority in her bones.
She didn't radiate power all the way
through her wingtips, like the other
queens he'd met.
It took him only a moment of puzzling
this out before he realized that there
must be a dragon behind the screen
staring through those holes at him.
A chill sliced through his scales.
Nobody could see her, but her presence
filled the cave like heavy smoke.
The queen of the night wings.
The scrolls always referred to her as
mysterious and unknown, but Starflight
hadn't imagined that she would keep
herself hidden even from her own tribe.
Why?
Because it's extra terrifying, he
answered himself.
This is him, barked one of the dragons.
Yes, Maro Sio growled.
We snatched Jim from the rain forest this
morning.
Wings rustled uneasily all around the
cave.
Has he told us anything?
asked another dragon.
What do they know?
What are they planning?
How soon will they attack?
growled another.
And how did that rain wing escape?
Another one shouted, as several dragons
began to speak at once.
We've heard reports that there was a mud
wing with her, a mud wing.
How did he get here?
Why didn't we kill them before they got
away?
They're talking about glory and clay.
Starflight thought with a shudder.
That's the rain wing I warned you about
Morrisier snarled.
The one that Talons of Peace got to
replace the Sky Wing, they lost.
He spat into the lava.
This is exactly why I told them to kill
her.
A rain wing, of all things.
Said the dragon with the diamonds.
What an unfortunate mistake.
We had her. said a dragon with twisted
horns.
Here, in our talons, and nobody killed
her.
Who knows what she saw?
cried another dragon.
If she warns the rain wings what we're
planning, she can't possibly know that.
Marasir said.
She knows about the tunnel between our
kingdoms.
Challenged a dragon from the far wall.
And that little one escaped with her.
She'll have told her everything she saw
in the fortress.
What if they figure it out?
A clamor of voices filled the cave.
Figure what out?
Starflight looked down at his talons and
wished they weren't shaking so much.
He was half afraid that he'd tremble
himself off balance and into the lava, but
that wasn't even in the top 20 things he
was worrying about right now.
What are they planning?
He glanced up at the screen where the
queen was hidden.
She hadn't spoken at all yet, but he
could feel her watching.
From the way his skin prickled, he
thought she hadn't taken her eyes off him
since he'd entered the cave.
All at once, the dragon with the diamonds
leaned toward the screen, tilting her
head.
A hush fell instantly around the room.
Nothing moved, except the bloop bloop of
bubbles in the lava.
Every night wing present seemed to be
holding his or her breath.
Starfly didn't hear anything.
No queen's voice issuing regally from her
hiding spot, but the diamond dragon
nodded and straightened up again.
Queen Battle winners as to shut up and
ask him.
To his horror, she pointed at
Starflight.
That's why he is here.
Make him tell us what they know and what
they're going to do next.
The listening dragons all swiveled their
heads toward him.
Falling into the lava suddenly sounded
like a pretty great option.
Um, Starflight stammered several times.
I, I, um, speak.
Or I kill you right now.
Morrisio growled behind him.
Starflight pressed his front talons
together and took a deep breath.
Her name is Glory, he blurted.
The dragons all hissed.
This was not something they cared about.
She, she said you have rain wing
prisoners.
Please tell me she's wrong.
Tell me it's all a mistake.
But no one corrected him.
Should he tell them glory's plan, that
she was trying to become queen of the
rain wings, so she could build an army to
come rescue their lost dragons, that they
shouldn't underestimate her?
Would he be betraying his friends if he
said all that to the night wings?
Or would he be betraying his tribe if he
didn't?
The close smoky air of the cave pressed
down around Starflight?
What if I can fix everything?
This is the chance you wanted.
You ask Lori to let you talk to the night
wings.
You wanted to give them a chance to
explain themselves.
You want to define a peaceful solution, so
you wouldn't have to pick sides in a
war.
But now that he was here, facing their
dark eyes, He couldn't find any of the
brilliant words he'd meant to use.
Suddenly, one of the nearest dragons
snapped, just tell us that they're
planning an attack.
Yes, Starflight blurted.
I mean, I think so.
This met with such an uproar that
Starflight had to sit down and cover his
head with his wings.
He'd said the worst possible thing.
He'd made everything worse for glory and
the rain wings, and he couldn't even
bring himself to speak up and try that
famous diplomacy he'd always thought was
such a good idea.
They wouldn't listen to me anyway.
He told himself, but he didn't know if
that was true.
He wasn't brave enough to find out.
It doesn't matter.
Rasped a hoarse, wet voice.
Rain wings are no match for us.
A horribly disfigured dragon pushed past
Morrow's ear, slithered into the cave, and
glowered at the other dragons.
His snout was twisted and deformed by a
terrible scar that had closed one nostril
melted several scales, and left nasty
oozing bubbles along his jawline.
The dragon with the diamonds frowned.
Vengeance.
You are not invited to this council.
Yeah, I noticed, he hissed.
And yet I know more than any dragon about
rain wings and what they can do.
He gestured to his face.
And I can tell you that this was a
fluke.
Brain wings are too stupid and cowardly
to be dangerous.
Most of you know I got this when I
grabbed their queen.
Well, turns out, just one of their queens
stupid tribe.
And she had no idea what she was doing, or
I'd be dead.
She didn't even mean to spray me.
They never do.
Vengeance shook his head, breathing
loudly through his mouth.
They have Pyre's most powerful weapon, and
they're too pathetic to use it.
Maybe they were, before this glory came
along, said one of the other dragons.
From what Morosia says about her.
She is not as weak as the rest of them.
You have no idea, Starflight thought.
And it's your fault they found out about
us.
The Diamond Dragon said.
You're the one who brought her here.
Even though Death Bringer warned us the
dragonettes were in the forest, and that
we should stay away until they were gone
death bring her.
Vengeance smirked.
Oh, yeah.
How is your pet greatness?
I've heard a very interesting story about
him.
He turned and beckoned with his tail.
Starflight recognized the Nightwing
assassin who was dragged into the cave by
4 guards.
It was starting to get crowded on the
ledge by the door.
Vengeance seized Deathbringer's ear and
virtually threw him onto the stone
outcropping with Starflight.
They knocked into each other and flung
out their wings for balance.
Deathbringer wasn't much bigger than
Starflight after all.
He'd looked larger when he was attacking
Queen Blaze and threatening glory.
But here, in the same lava predicament as
Starflight, with everyone looking just as
displeased with him, he seemed a lot less
intimidating.
Ah, he said to Starflight in a friendly
way.
You're here too.
His eyes looked as if he wanted to ask
something, but didn't dare.
This dragon, vengeance bellowed, pointing
a death bringer.
This pet assassin of princess greatness
was actually conspiring with the enemy.
He is the one who brought the mud wing
here, and he helped them both to escape.
Princess, Starfight thought.
So, the Diamond Dragon, greatness, speaks
for her mother for some reason.
Hang on, Deathbringer said, hopping
neatly over Starflight's head, so the
dragonette was between him and
vengeance.
He looked around at the other dragons and
spread his wings with an innocent air.
Conspiring with the enemy.
Do you have any proof?
Yeah.
I have witnesses, vengeance hissed.
One of the gods she attacked on the way
out, saw you helping them.
And the gods you distracted from the
tunnel.
So the mud wing could come through.
They can tell us all about that.
A terrible silence followed.
Starflight wondered whether they were all
searching Deathbringers' mind to find out
what was true.
He kept his own mind carefully blank, just
in case.
Death bringer. said greatness, twisting
her diamond necklace in her front claws.
That kind of betrayal.
The punishment is death.
The Nightwing assassin spread his wings
and bowed deeply toward the queen.
I swear, I have only ever done what I
thought would be best for my tribe.
Oh, yeah.
Vengeance coughed wetly.
So why?
Or all the dragonettes still alive then?
Deathbringer glanced under his wing and
met Starflight's eyes.
There was a question in them, and this
time Starflight guessed what it was.
Are they?
All still alive.
Starflight nodded as imperceptibly as he
could, and a look of relief flitted
across Deathbringer's face, then was
gone.
My mission is not complete.
It's true.
Deathbringer said.
I need to return to the rainforest
and...
And betray us some more, vengeance
suggested.
I bet you do.
Starflight noticed greatness leaning
toward the screen again, but most of the
dragons were staring at Deathbringer and
didn't notice this time.
I assure you, I'm a loyal night wing.
Deathbringer said, his voice rising.
Perhaps I think it's worth discussing.
Whether we really need to kill these
dragonettes, but you see, roared
vengeance.
He's...
Vengeance.
Greatness shouted, cutting him off.
She stood up on her ledge and spread her
wings, revealing the silver scales
glittering underneath like echoes of her
diamonds.
She puffed up her chest, and contorted
her face, as if she was trying to appear
menacing and regal, but it looked like a
performance.
Starflight still couldn't see a future
queen in her.
The queen has spoken, greatness said, into
the perilous silence, vengeance.
You endangered the whole tribe.
You disobeyed orders.
You brought a viper to us, disguised as a
simple garden snake.
Wait, vengeance cried.
What he did was worse.
I just grabbed a rain wing, same as
always.
How could I know?
She didn't look no different than the
others?
And in addition, said greatness, you are
irritating the queen.
She flicked her tail, just the tiniest
movement at the guards in the doorway.
No, shrieked vengeance.
His wings flapped open, but he'd barely
lifted off when the 4 guards grabbed him
with one swift heave, before Starflight
even had time to blink.
They hurled the scarred dragon into the
lake of lava.
Death bringer shot up and out of the way
as lava splashed all around them.
Starfly didn't move fast enough, and a
bright orange droplet splattered on his
foot.
Burning pain flared through him, and he
thought he might faint.
Then a shape surged out of the lava.
Vengeance, screaming and trying to escape
as he was boiled alive.
Death bringer's talons yanked Starflight
into the air just in time.
Lava sprayed in all directions as the
dying dragon flailed his wings.
Don't do this.
Save me.
Vengeance howled.
The guard stepped forward with
expressionless faces.
They were wearing a sort of armor
including helmets and thick plates over
their underbellies, and they were all
carrying wicked, pronged spears like the
one glory had brought back to the
rainforest.
It was these spears they used to shove
vengeance back under the lava, and to
hold him there, until the thrashing
stopped, and the dark shape of the
scarred dragon finally sank all the way
below the bright gold red surface, and
disappeared.
After a long moment, Starflight
remembered to breathe again.
He glanced at Death Bringer, hovering in
the air beside him.
There was an unusually somber look on the
assassin's face, as if he'd just seen a
glimpse of his possible future, and not
in a magical, prophetic vision sort of
way.
Thank you, majesty.
Death bringer said at last, bowing toward
the hidden queen.
Don't, death bringer.
Greatness said, her voice cracking.
She cleared her throat and looked away.
We're not done with you.
She had addressed the guards.
Take him to the dungeon.
We'll investigate the charges, and then
Her Majesty will decide what to do.
Deathbringer flew down to the guards, and
allowed them to push him out the door
only glancing back once to meet
Starflight's eyes, with a look Starflight
couldn't decode.
Maybe he expects me to have mind reading
abilities.
Maybe he's trying to send me a message.
If so, sorry, Deathbringer.
You picked the wrong dragon.
Greatness rubbed the ridges above our
eyes, looking tired.
All right.
We need a break.
If it's your turn to eat this week, go do
that now, and we'll reconvene tonight.
She glanced around the room, leaned
toward the screen again, and added, The
queen says to a turn at dusk with
possible defensive and offensive
strategies.
Morosia.
See if you can claw some more information
out of the dragonette before then.
Morosier dipped his head, flexing his
talons.
Starflight hoped uneasily that she meant
claw in a metaphorical way.
The night wings began to disperse.
Most of them threw holes in the ceiling.
Marosier jerked his head, and Starflight
reluctantly followed him back into the
tunnels.
The mention of eating had reminded him of
how hungry he was, although he couldn't
really worry about food when he wasn't
even sure if he was a prisoner or a spy
or just a failure.
And after what had happened to
vengeance.
Starflight was pretty nervous about what
the night wings might do with a failure.
Maru Sears wings billowed like
thunderclouds as he stormed ahead of
Starflight.
Soon Starflight realized that they
weren't going back to the dormitory.
Marosir had taken a turn somewhere, and
now Starflight could see dim gray light
up ahead.
They emerged onto a shelf of rock that
jutted from the side of the fortress.
Below them was a weird landscape of rocks
that looked like giant, lumpy gray black
dragon scales, with a fiery orange
glowing underneath, filling in the
cracks.
A lava field.
Starflight thought.
He remembered a little about volcanoes
from one of the scrolls he'd studied back
under the mountain.
What felt like a lifetime ago.
But there weren't any active volcanoes on
the mainland of Pyria, so he hadn't
memorized it like the other scrolls.
It had never occurred to him that the
Night Wings, who'd written most of the
scrolls might have firsthand knowledge of
volcanoes, might, in fact, be living on
one.
Starflight couldn't see any caves or a
lava river like the one glory had
described, so he guessed they were on the
other side of the volcano, but the air
was as smoky and gray as she'd said, and
as hard to breathe.
He still felt that raw, scraped feeling
all the way down his throat.
Far overhead in the ashy sky.
A pair of black dragons wheeled and
circled, around and around, like
vultures.
Starflight wondered if they could see the
mainland from up there.
How far was the island from the rest of
Pyria?
Did the night wings have a way to get
there?
Other than the secret animus made tunnels
to the rainforest?
So many questions.
His whole life, he'd been full of
questions about the night wings and their
secret home.
And now, perhaps, they could all be
answered.
He took a moment to think, I'm here.
This is my home.
This is my tribe.
This is what I was looking for.
But it didn't feel true.
This awful place was nothing like the
Nightwing utopia he'd always imagined.
He'd pictured a beautiful hidden place
full of art and music, and dragons who
loved to read, with spires reaching to
the clouds, and waterfalls, and sunlight
and a library around every corner.
Not this.
The smoke and stench, and hostility, and
gloomy surroundings.
And even a 1000000 answers, even all the
answers to all the questions he could
think of, wouldn't be able to take the
place of Sonny and the other
dragonettes.
Maro Seer stared across the lava field
and inhaled several times, his nostrils
flaring and his tongue slithering in and
out.
He did this for so long that Starflight
began to wonder if there was something
wrong with his nose.
Um, Starflight squeaked at last.
Maro Sier glared at him in the middle of
a giant sniff.
Just, um, Starflight said.
I just want you to know, I don't know
anything else, really, about the rain
wings attacking.
Almost immediately, his traitorous brain
started clamoring, except the glory might
be queen by now, and that rain wings are
normally pacifists, and he fixed his eyes
on the mountain behind them, and tried to
think of nothing but lava.
Maro seer snorted.
That doesn't surprise me, he said.
You know, just about the most useless spy
I've ever met.
He spread his wings and inhaled once
more.
Let's go.
His tail nearly knocked Starflight off
the ledge as he leaped into the sky.
Down there?
Starflight called, glancing at the molten
cracks in the rocks below them.
Is it safe?
He flapped to catch up tomorrow's year.
Of course it isn't.
Marosira snapped.
Several dragons have made the mistake of
trying to land down there, only to break
the crust and fall right through.
He nodded at a white shape sticking out
of the rocks.
Starflight peered at it until he realized
what it was, and then wished he hadn't.
His stomach twisted as he spotted a few
others.
Dragon skulls.
Their mouths open in an eternal scream.
I wouldn't suggest a closer look.
Marosier said dryly.
We're going over there.
He nodded to the far side of the lava
rocks, where Starflight now saw a tangle
of gray ash covered trees.
So, Starflight cleared his throat.
When greatness said, if it's your turn to
eat this week, what did that mean?
Maro Seer hissed.
There's a rotating schedule.
All night wings are allowed to hunt or
gather for about 5 days out of every
month.
Naturally, I am exempt.
Naturally?
Starflight echoed.
Although he hadn't meant for it to sound
so much like a question.
Only 5 days a month?
No wonder they're all so thin.
They must be running out of food on this
island.
The older dragon frowned down at him.
My role in the tribe's future makes me
indispensable.
Oh, Starflight said, not daring to ask
any more questions.
As they got closer to the trees, it
turned out to be a bigger forest than
Starfly had expected, covering about a
quarter of the island, from the edge of
the lava to the ocean.
I see, he said with relief.
I wondered where you hunted.
Surely there couldn't be much prey on an
active volcano.
Here, when we have to, Marosier spat.
For instance, when we can't get to the
rainforest or the kingdom of sand.
His forked black tongue hissed in and
out.
Oh.
That must be another reason they're so
angry right now.
They've been using their rainforest to
find extra prey, he thought, like that
sloth Glory Clay and I found by the
river.
He'd had trouble getting the stench of
that dying sloth out of his nose.
For a moment, Starflight thought the
memory of it had brought this smell back
until he realized a similar smell of
decay was coming from the forest below
him.
The whole island was like this when we
got here, Morrisier said.
You mean covered with trees?
Starflight asked.
What happened?
The volcano?
Stupid question.
Of course it was the volcano.
He looked back at the mountain, which
must have sent a river of lava this way
that covered almost all the trees, turning
the island into a mostly barren
rockscape.
Marasir didn't answer him.
They circled overhead once, and
Starflight spotted a few other night
wings prowling through the trees.
Morosier glowered at them, then flicked
his tail at Starflight.
Quickly, he snapped, before one of them
finds my prey.
Your Starflight started curiously, but
Mario Sierra had already tucked his wings
and was arrowing down to a patch of
stunted trees not far from the beach.
The older dragon landed with a thud that
sent gray dust billowing around his
talons, and immediately dropped his nose
to the ground.
With a horrible snorting noise, he
charged across the clearing, taking deep
breaths, and flicking his tongue rapidly
in and out.
Starflight had never seen hunting like
this.
Duna taught them what he could in the
caves under the mountain, and sometimes
it had involved scent trails.
Starfight was always decent at those, but
usually it also involved being quiet
waiting to spot your target, and then
attacking swiftly before they even knew
you were there.
But from the noise Moroser was making
Starfly thought every animal on the
island must know he was coming.
He followed the large black dragon
thinking about Dune and his hunting
lessons.
Their sand wing guardian hadn't been
particularly kind to the dragonettes
although he'd never been as cruel as
Kestrel, but he'd always noticed how hard
Starflight studied, and sometimes he gave
him special tutorials on scrolls that
Starflight found confusing.
Their other guardian, webs, had often
made an effort to bring back more scrolls
for Starflight on his trips outside.
They'd both been more cautious with him
than the other dragonettes, perhaps wary
that his nightwing mind reading or
prophecy skills might suddenly manifest.
Something I'm still waiting for, he
thought, hunching his wings.
Morosier made a guttural, triumphant
noise and swiped a leafless bush out of
his way.
Underneath it was something half dead.
More than half dead, Starflight thought
almost all the way dead.
It looked like a pile of gray and white
feathers, as big as a dragon's head.
When the giant night wing hooked one claw
in it to drag it out, it let out an awful
pathetic squawk.
What is it?
Starfly asked, trying to remember a bird
like this from his scrolls.
His curiosity made him forget about being
too afraid to talk.
It's bigger than any seagull I've seen.
A giant albatross.
Morrisier said, flipping it over.
I was sure it would be dead by now.
With a shrug.
He sliced one claw across the bird's
throat.
Starflight covered his snout with one of
his wings.
The toxic smell of the dead bird was
almost overwhelming.
He wanted to run to the ocean, and bury
his head in the salt water to make it go
away.
As Maro Sierra prodded it a few more
times, Starflight spotted a bite on the
bird's neck, like the one on the dead
sloth in the rainforest, it looked
infected and disgusting, crawling with
insects.
Are you sure that's safe to eat?
He asked.
I'm the one who killed it, Marosio
growled.
I'm certainly going to eat it.
But won't it make you sick?
Marosier gave him a dark look.
Night wings don't get sick.
Don't tell me you have a weak stomach.
In addition to everything else wrong with
you.
No, I don't think so.
Starflight said, hoping he wasn't about
to throw up and prove himself wrong.
But look, there's probably horrible
bacteria all through that wound.
Of course, there is, Marasier said.
How do you think it died?
My bite infected it.
That's...
He paused, frowning at Starflight.
Isn't this how you hunt too?
Starflight glanced down at the horrible
smelling bird.
He had a feeling he shouldn't admit that
so far, Clay had done most of the hunting
since they left the mountain, but he also
didn't want to admit that he didn't
understand this at all.
Use your brain, he told himself.
You can figure this out.
You bite your prey, he said slowly, and
then you wait for it to die.
And then you find it, and eat it.
Once it's already dead and rotting.
But it doesn't make you sick.
He squinted at Maru Seer's teeth.
There's something in your mouth that
kills them, even if the bite itself
wasn't fatal.
Is it venom?
Marusir shook his head.
Some night wings think so.
But none of our scientists have been able
to find any when they examine our tribe's
corpses, nor have we had any success
replicating rain wing venom shooting.
He scowled at the bird, and abruptly
ripped off one of its wings.
You may have this, he said ungenerously
tossing it at Starflight.
Starflight jumped back to avoid catching
it, and the wing splattered to the ground
in front of him.
Several wrigley things crawled out of it
and he closed his eyes quickly.
Um, he said.
No, thank you.
Morosea already had his teeth buried in
the underbelly of the albatross.
He tore off a mouthful and chewed for a
moment, staring narrowly at Starflight.
What do you think you're going to eat?
He barked.
This is the Nightwing Way.
I'll catch something else, Starflight
said.
He glanced around.
A turtle or a lizard or something.
I'm starting to see why you're so
useless.
Marasier hissed.
No one's ever taught you to be a night
wing.
We assumed you'd be born superior like
the rest of us, but perhaps you're
defective.
Well, you don't have time for delicate
sensibilities, and a lengthy turtle
hunt.
Eat the wing or starve.
Star of Light was too intrigued by this
strange biological phenomenon to register
that he'd just been called defective as
well as useless.
Listen, it might not make you sick, but I
think it would make me sick, Starflight
said.
He wished he could write all this down.
Were there any scrolls about nightwing
bites and what they did to their prey?
Maybe he could study the tribe and write
the 1st one.
I'm not used to eating infected carrion.
Scientifically, I would assume it's
something you have to adjust to over time
as your dragonettes will have done
growing up with a diet like this, but I
won't have the correct antibodies to keep
me safe.
It's not worth the risk.
The enormous black dragon had paused mid
bite, and was staring at Starflight with
his mouth open.
Well, he said after a long moment, that
answers that question.
What question?
Starfight asked.
Maro Seer picked at his teeth with one
claw and lashed his tail.
Now I know who your father is.
The wind off the ocean seized the tree
branches and rattled them fiercely.
Starflight dug his talons into the
ground.
It wasn't that he'd forgotten to wonder
who his parents were.
It was more that he was terrified to hear
the answer.
A father like Maroser, or vengeance, or a
mother like greatness, or fierce teeth.
Perhaps it would be better never to find
out, rather than have his dreams meet the
inevitably awful reality.
But suddenly, the idea that a real dragon
somewhere on this island, was connected
to him, and might care about him was
almost too much to bear.
It's what Sonny and I always talked about
finding our parents.
My father?
He whispered.
Didn't you know who he was before?
There were a few possibilities.
Maro seer said grimly, but only one other
dragon I know talks like you.
He talks like me.
Well, this is guaranteed to make him even
more insufferable.
Maro Sierr muttered, shredding the other
albatross wing and stuffing scraps of
meat in his mouth.
He's been claiming it was his egg for the
last 6 years.
Can I meet him?
Starflight asked.
Oh, there's no getting out of that.
Morris here's tail twitched.
I'm surprised he didn't track you down
the moment you were dragged in.
Must be in the middle of another big
experiment.
Nose in his scrolls, probably hasn't even
noticed that we're about to go to war.
He wants to meet me.
He'll be looking for me.
What about my mother?
Starflight asked.
Could I meet her?
No, Marasir said, plucking a feather off
his tongue.
Dead. died a few years ago.
Oh.
Starfly didn't understand the wave of
sadness that seemed to punch him in the
chest.
He had known her.
She'd agreed to give up her egg for the
prophecy, so she couldn't have been very
attached to him.
She was probably as bad as Coral or
Clay's mother.
Still, how did she die?
Starflight tried not to look at the mess
Maro Seer was making of the albatross.
Dune and Kestrel had always insisted on
strict table manners and cleanliness
since they were all trapped under the
mountain together, in just a few caves
with nowhere to escape to if someone ate
their prey in a loud, annoying way.
She got herself involved in a battle.
Tried to help a sea wing had been
attacked by two sky wings.
Marosea grunted.
Idiot.
So obviously, you didn't get that brain
from her.
He narrowed his eyes at Starflight. and
waved one of the bird bones at him.
Enough.
I have questions for you.
I really don't know anything, Starflight
said in a hurry.
How dangerous is that rain wing?
Marasier asked, ignoring him.
Our studies indicate that most rain wings
care only about themselves and prefer
everything to be easy.
Accurate.
Starflight nodded.
He really desperately didn't want to
betray glory in any way, but he couldn't
think of a way to avoid Morris Seer's
questions or lied to him when Morris Seer
was sure to read the truth in his mind.
To his surprise, Moros Sears shoulders
relaxed.
That's what I thought.
He said.
So perhaps they won't do anything.
Perhaps they'll roll over and go back to
sleep.
Starflight realized that Marosier had
misunderstood him.
He'd only meant that laziness was true of
most rain wings, but the Night Wing had
heard that it was true of glory as well.
Maybe, he said non-committally.
He tried not to think about how glory
would never let this go, how she would
fight tooth and claw to rescue the rain
wing prisoners.
It had been strange seeing her like that
as if she'd borrowed tsunami's ferocity
for a day.
For years, Glory had acted as though she
didn't care about anything.
But apparently, imprisoning and torturing
members of her tribe was one way to get
her attention.
He remembered what a council had said.
What plan was the council talking about?
He asked.
What is it we don't want the rain wings
to know?
He stumbled over the words, trying to say
we, as if he could be part of this
tribe.
But he wanted Marosier to feel as if
Starflight was on his side, that he could
be trusted.
It was a trick he'd seen Sonny use a few
times when glory and tsunami were
fighting.
Why are we mad at tsunami today?
Now, what has glory done to us?
And it often worked.
Not this time, though.
The less you know, the better, Morrisier
snapped.
You'll get less trouble that way.
That wasn't generally Starflight's
philosophy.
He'd say knowing more was always better
than knowing less.
Moro Seer ripped the last chunk of flesh
off the bird and spat out several more
feathers.
If you're determined to starve, he
muttered, and devour the wing, he'd
thrown to Starflight in a few bites.
Very well, he grumbled.
Let's go see mastermind.
He flung the remains of the bird into the
bushes and jumped into the sky.
Then I'll take you to the alternate. he
said over his shoulder.
The what?
Starflight asked.
But Maro Seer was winging away quickly
and didn't look back.
Starflight followed him, still thinking
about the way Nightwings hunted.
It explained a few things, including the
bad breath on all the dragonettes in the
dormitory.
Oddly, Deathbringer didn't seem to have
the same smell.
Starflight wondered if the assassin spent
more time on the continent than other
night wings and had learned to prefer
live prey over carrion, like most
dragons.
Ahead of them, the Nightwing Fortress
loomed. black against the gray sky.
It was massive, built in layers that
wrapped halfway around the mountain, but
it also looked somehow precarious, as if
one rock shelf could shift underneath it
and the whole thing might suddenly slide
all the way into the ocean.
In fact, Starflight squinted.
It was hard to see at first.
Black on black in the dark, smoky air, but
as they got closer, he was sure.
Part of the fortress had been swallowed
by lava, clearly some time ago, a whole
corner of the building, at least as big
as Queen Scarlet's Gladiator Arena, was
covered by a hardened mass of black rock
bubbles.
It looked like a giant dragon had reached
out of the mountain and slammed its
talons down over the walls.
Starflight glanced up uneasily, had the
plume of steam rising from the top of the
volcano.
Orange gold fire glowed from inside, and
he knew that streams of molten lava ran
down at least one face of the mountain
toward the caves where the rain wings
were trapped, if Glory's description was
right.
Surely another eruption could come any
time, endangering the rest of the
fortress.
That thought made him even more nervous
about following Morrisier back inside, but
he didn't have much choice.
The large night wing ducked into a mouth
like opening on the highest level of the
fortress.
The tunnels here were lit with hanging
chandeliers of torches, as well as the
niches of coals Starflight had seen
before.
The stone under his talons felt smoother
and more polished, as if it was
frequently swept or mopped, unlike the
lower tunnels.
Starflight thought of the gold dragon
prints in the sky palace.
The emerald studded throne in the kingdom
of the sea, and the colorful flowers that
wound all around the rain wing village.
There was nothing like that here.
Nothing to break out the monotony of the
stone walls, nothing to showcase the
wealth and power of the night wings.
Then again, I guess no one ever comes
here, he thought.
Instead of trying to impress other
dragons with opulence, they do it with
mystery.
He could see how that would make sense.
But it would have been nice to see
something besides fire and rock in all
directions.
As they turned a corner, Starflight
paused and looked back.
He thought he'd heard, but maybe he was
imagining things.
But, It had sounded like claws, tip
tapping on the stone behind them.
He stared along the dark tunnel, and
suddenly had a shivery feeling of hope.
Maybe it's glory, he thought.
Maybe she's here, and camouflaged.
Maybe she's come to rescue me.
He couldn't imagine how she would have
gotten past the Nightwing guards who must
be posted around the hole.
In fact, if he were in charge, he just
took a night wing in the tunnel at all
times, just to be sure no one could
invisibly squeeze by.
But maybe the night wings weren't that
smart.
There it was again.
Tap, tap, tap.
Definitely talent.
Although whoever it was wasn't doing a
terrific job of being stealthy.
Glory is much better at sneaking than
that.
Maybe clay?
It was awful how much his chest hurt with
hope.
If only it were clay.
If only that big brown head would poke
around the band, see him, and grin.
Starflight promised the universe that he
would never, ever make fun of clay again
if only the mud wing would suddenly be
here, rescuing him.
Keep up.
Morrisio growled from up ahead.
Starflight realized that he was really
being an idiot.
If someone were trying to sneak up behind
them to rescue him.
It wouldn't much help if Starflight stood
there staring at them.
He started to turn to follow Morris ear
but just then, a head did poke around the
last corner.
It wasn't clay, or glory, or tsunami, or
sunny.
It was just a Nightwing Dragonette.
She stared right at him for a startled
moment, and then he shrugged and turned
away.
But at the same time, she yelped, oh my
gosh, it's you. and bolted up to him
grabbing his front talons.
I had a vision about you.
She declared grandly.
He froze in the act of trying to pull his
talons away.
Have you had any visions about me?
You did?
Starflight said, blinking.
She appeared to be his own age.
So if she was having visions, that meant
Dragonette did develop their powers
before they were full grown, which meant
Starflight should have something by now.
But he didn't.
Whenever he tried to read minds or see
the future, it was like staring into the
night sky, empty and cold and
meaningless.
He hadn't admitted that tomorrow, see her
yet.
Speaking of whom?
The floor now trembled ominously, as the
older night wing came thundering back
along the tunnel to them, his eyes nearly
popped out of his skull when he saw the
new dragonette.
Fate, speaker.
He roared so loud, the Starflight thought
the volcano might erupt right then.
I told you to stay in your cave with the
others.
I know, I heard you, she said cheerfully
but I got bored, and I wanted to explore
and I saw you flying by, so I thought I'd
come too.
I can't believe I'm in the Nightwing
Fortress at last.
I have had lots of prophetic dreams about
it, you know.
She said conspiratorially to Starflight.
She still had his front talons pressed
between hers.
Although, in those, it was actually
bigger and lighter, and smelled way less
terrible, plus it had a lot more treasure
and seriously less grouchy dragons.
She thought for a moment.
Hmm.
Maybe they were just regular dreams.
Fate speaker.
Maro Seer hissed.
What did I say about keeping your visions
to yourself?
You said, shut up about your visions.
I'm not remotely interested.
Fate speaker answered, but that doesn't
mean this dragon isn't interested.
Aren't you interested?
she said to Starflight.
He was, but he did not think it would be
wise to admit that in front of Marosier
who had smoke rising from his nostrils.
Starfly tried to study the dragonette
without obviously staring.
Fate speaker's black scales shimmered
with underscales of deep blue and
purple.
Like Starflight's wings.
Hers were scattered with silver scales on
the underside, so they looked like part
of the night sky, but unlike his, face
speaker had several extra silver scales
one at the outside corner of each eye, a
band circling one ankle, and a few lone
ones sparkling along her tail like starry
freckles.
Anyway, I just know you're terribly
important, she said to him, releasing his
talons and that we have a great destiny
together.
We do?
He thought, hopefully.
Perhaps he was going to survive the
Nightwing Fortress after all.
Am I actually useful in this great
destiny?
Are my friends there?
Am I with Sonny?
He wished to get asked her questions
without Morrow's seer breathing furiously
over their heads.
Go back to the others.
Maro seer ordered.
Oh, can't I come with you?
Fate speaker asked.
She gave Marosia a pleading look.
I foresee that I'll be really helpful
with whatever you're about to do.
Also, that I'll find it totally
interesting.
I don't think that counts as foreseeing
Starflight said.
It sounds more like guessing.
Mario CR growled deep in his throat.
Very well.
Keep your mouth shut, and don't get in
the way.
As if I would, fate speaker said happily
immediately tripping Starflight with her
tail.
Maro Seer stomped away, muttering, Fate
speaker gave Starflight an enormous smile
that reminded him of Sonny.
He wondered if Sonny missed him, and
whether she felt anything like the ache
that filled his chest whenever he thought
of her.
Oh my, sad face.
Fate speaker said, nudging Starflight's
wing as they walked.
Cheer up.
What's your name?
That wasn't in your vision?
Starflight tilted his head curiously.
He'd always wondered how much detail the
visions had.
The prophecy Morrow Seer had delivered
years ago was remarkably cryptic, but
perhaps there was more information in the
seer's head that he hadn't shared.
Um, Fate speaker wobbled her head back
and forth, squinting thoughtfully at
him.
Oh, of course.
Big toes.
What?
Starflight glanced down at his talons, a
little offended.
No, no, it's Starflight.
Oh, she said.
Are you sure?
Quite sure.
She shrugged.
Well, I was close.
Hi, Starflight, I'm fate speaker.
You're probably wondering why you've
never seen me before.
Starflight paused midstep and frowned at
her.
Am I?
It's because I didn't grow up here.
She carried on blithely, without noticing
his reaction.
Moro Seeor's growl echoed down the
corridor, and they both started walking
faster.
I only got to the island yesterday.
I know this is going to sound crazy, but
I was raised by the talons of peace.
Starflight, walked straight into a
chandelier.
He staggered back, his head spinning.
Oh, ouch, fate speaker said.
She patted his shoulder gingerly.
That looked painful.
Anyway, so it turns out I'm part of that
big dragonette prophecy everyone is so
excited about.
Can you believe it?
No, Starflight thought.
I'm the wings of night, she said
proudly.
Morris here says it's up to me to stop
the war.
For some reason, he seems kind of grumpy
about that.
Starflight felt all his hope, flicker, and
go out.
He'd been praying quietly that maybe this
was another night wing intervention to
point him in the right direction.
He'd hoped, perhaps, he'd be given
another lecture, and then sent back to
his friends.
But apparently, fierce teeth was right.
He was here because he'd failed.
And fate speaker was his replacement.
It made sense.
Fate speaker had powers, and Starflight
did not.
He'd failed to follow Morris here's
orders more than once.
He was a useless night wing and a useless
dragonette of destiny.
Wow.
Fate speaker said, finally noticing his
expression.
You look like someone just ate your only
walrus.
Are you all right?
I, Starfight began.
I just thought...
They came around a bend in the tunnel, and
nearly stepped on Morrow Seer's tail.
He gave them a glare that shut Starflight
up in a hurry.
Fate speaker, however, was undaunted.
Labs.
She read off the door in front of them.
Ooh, what does that mean?
It means don't touch anything?
Moro seer said grimly.
We are here, so Starflight can meet his
father.
If we're very unlucky, he'll have time to
give us a tour of all the experiments
he's working on, he hissed.
Let's get this over with.
The door swung open to reveal a huge
room.
More brightly lit and cleanly kept than
any other part of the fortress that
Starflight had seen.
They were standing on a balcony.
There was a level above them, and a level
below them, and a crisscrossing network
of strange pipes stretching across the
space in front of them.
No, no, cried a voice.
A whip thin black dragon shot down from
the top level and hovered in front of
them.
He wore an odd helmet over his whole head
with only a few small holes poked in it
for him to see out, rather like the
queen's council screen Starfly thought.
I must not be interrupted.
This experiment is at a critical juncture
and greatness says I might be shut down
at any moment.
Everyone, please leave.
He flapped his wings and front talons at
them.
Mastermind, Maro Seer said coolly.
It seems you are right all along.
The dragonette from Bar Sights Egg is
apparently your son, and he's here now, so
I've brought him to meet you.
Starfight tensed, expecting the other
dragon to shrug and chew them away.
But instead, Mastermind reached up and
removed his helmet, revealing a snout
pockmarked with little scars and curious
bloodshot eyes.
My son?
he said.
And Starflight felt a happy shiver at the
tone of wonder in his voice.
Mastermind landed on the balcony beside
them, set his helmet on the floor, and
took Starflight's shoulders in his
talons.
Three moons, he said.
What a handsome dragonette.
It does look like me.
I knew he would.
As I suspected.
This jaw line is genetically dominant.
He gestured to the same spot on himself
and on Starflight.
Ah, and yes, see the way the star scales
on our wings spray outward like a splash
of water.
Whereas Morrow sears, for instance, curl
inward, more like a snail shell.
He flared one of his wings, and then
reached for Maro's ears, but the larger
night wing batted him away with a snarl.
Whole theories at this point, of course.
Mastermind said, and Starflight found
himself smiling back at his father's
toothy grin.
A larger data set would naturally be
essential for proving anything, but one
is much better than none.
Entirely wonderful, in fact, especially
compared to most of the rest of the tribe
including yourself, right, Mauricio?
No dragonettes.
As yet.
Maro Sear's face indicated he did not
intend to dignify that with a response.
But I have a son.
Mastermind said proudly, I, of all
dragons.
Let's see strong wings laugh now.
Just wait until everyone sees my handsome
offspring.
He clapped Starflight's shoulder again.
So strong and healthy.
You can be the assistant I've been
looking for.
What are you interested in, son?
Son.
Starflight's needs felt as if they might
not hold them up very well for much
longer.
Um, everything, he stammered.
Scrolls.
I like scrolls.
Fantastic, mastermind said.
I've lots of scrolls.
How about desellenization?
Know anything about it?
Starflight perked up?
A little.
Taking the salt out of seawater to make
it potable, right?
Potable?
Fate speaker interjected?
She was watching them with wide, startled
eyes, and Starlight remembered that she
didn't know yet that he'd been raised
away from the island too.
Drinkable, Starfight explained.
Is that what those pipes are for?
Very good. said mastermind, waving his
talons excitedly.
We have only one freshwater source on the
island, and it's become rather
contaminated with ash over the last few
years.
So I invented this magnificent
contraption to provide safe water for the
entire tribe.
He talked on and on, pointing to the
various pipes and explaining the science
behind the process.
Starflight listened with a fascination.
He'd never met a dragon who seemed so
full of information, like a walking
library of scrolls.
Come, come.
Mastermind said eagerly, gathering his
helmet and leaping off the balcony.
I'll show you what else I'm working on.
Starflight glanced at Mario Cia for
permission, and the large Nightwing
rolled his eyes and sat down with a
yawn.
Fate speaker didn't wait to be invited.
She flew behind them as mastermind led
the way down to the bottom level.
Here is where I do all my volcanology, he
said, striding between tables laden with
cauldrons of lava and steaming holes dug
right into the ground.
Well, I'm testing full materials that can
withstand eruptions and working on scale
models of barriers and outlining possible
implementation systems.
No wonder I need an assistant, right?
This place is pretty cool, fate speaker
said, glancing around at the volcano
experiments.
It's amazing, Starflight said.
He peered down at the smoke issuing from
a deep hole.
He wanted to study each section of the
lab in careful detail.
There was a strange contraption in the
corner that looked as if it was designed
to fit entirely around a dragon and then
be filled with something.
Water maybe?
He couldn't even imagine.
He already had a 1000000 questions, and a
couple of ideas about lava that might be
worth testing, if his dad didn't mind
some suggestions.
Mastermind flicked his tail at a corner
of the lab where tiny versions of the
mountain had been constructed, with
little fortresses stuck on the side.
Several of them were already smoldering
ruins.
Not going well, as you can see.
He laughed a little, almost nervously.
Queen Battle Winner isn't pleased about
that.
Of course.
She has her own ideas about where I
should be focusing my attention.
Come, come.
He lifted off toward the top level.
Starflight took one more look around
wondering what could be more interesting
or important than protecting the tribe
from the volcano.
I wonder if he's done any research on
Nightwings infecting the prey they bite.
Maybe I could help him study it.
He shook himself, blinking.
Sounds like I'm planning to stay.
He glanced at fate speaker, then quickly
away at one of the smoking jars of lava.
I might not have any choice about that.
But they have to let me see Sonny again.
If I'm trapped here forever, without her
without even a chance to say goodbye?
Come on.
Fate speaker interrupted his thoughts
tugging him into the air.
They hurried after mastermind, and
discovered that the 3rd level was another
balcony, with several doors ranged around
it, each one marked with 3 or 4 different
symbols.
Starflight's father stopped in front of
one door and rubbed his front talons
together.
About a year ago, we discovered a truly
truly astonishing natural phenomenon.
You won't know about this.
The talons of peace have no idea.
None of the other tribes do.
Our understanding of this biological
anomaly. is as yet so new and incomplete
that we haven't even put it in any
scrolls.
Certainly not the ones we distribute on
the mainland, but also not even the ones
that are for night wing eyes only.
I'm preparing a treatise on the subject
but there's still so much to learn that I
have no idea when I'll think it's ready
for publication.
You see, he said, leaning toward them, it
turns out one tribe of dragons has
evolved in unusual defense mechanism.
They can shoot venom from their fangs.
Deadly toxic venom that essentially melts
any animal or plant matter, it comes in
contact with, and you'll never believe
which tribe.
He didn't wait for them to guess.
Rain wings.
Rain wings?
Fate speaker echoed in a surprised
voice.
Starflight's heart was sinking.
He suddenly had a feeling he really did
not want to see what was behind these
doors.
Let's see.
We'll start here, Mastermind said.
He opened one of the doors to reveal a
long, narrow stone room.
A set of silver shackles with very short
chains was bolted to the floor near the
entrance, and all along the length of the
room, black marks scarred the floor and
walls, with indecipherable notes
scribbled beside each one in chalk.
Starflight stared at the shackles, feeling
ill.
Mastermind hopped down the room, avoiding
the black patches, although they all
seemed to be hardened and harmless, like
old lava.
This was one of our 1st questions
naturally.
When we 1st learned that rain wings could
shoot venom.
How far?
Was it a short range weapon or a long
range weapon?
Would we be able to approach and
incapacitate them if we developed
projectiles that could be fired from a
safe distance?
He stopped at the far end of the room and
indicated a mark on the floor.
This is as far as I've seen any one
dragon shoot.
An older male rain wing.
So my hypothesis is that it's a skill
that gets stronger as they age.
He rubbed the horns on his head, frowning
in thought.
I wonder if they have any elderly dragons
we could bring over and test.
Bring over.
Starflight thought bitterly, as if their
invited guests instead of abducted
prisoners.
Fate speaker was eyeing the shackles
nervously too, she looked as if she
didn't know quite how to ask about them.
The next obvious question is, what
materials aren't affected by the venom?
Anything we could use as armor or
shield?
Mastermind went on, hopping back up the
room toward them.
Come, come.
He ushered them out and over to the next
door.
We had to devise ways to study the
dragons without placing ourselves in
danger naturally.
Very few rain wings have ever
deliberately tried to shoot their venom
at us, but it goes very badly when they
do.
It's quite horrifying, really.
He opened the door and swept his talent
toward the tables inside.
Items of different shapes, sizes, and
materials were arranged in related
groups.
One table contained a gathering of sad
little plants and pots, drooping yellow
flowers dripping with black.
Another was all rocks, and a 3rd.
Starflight looked away quickly when you
realized that the trays all contained
remains of living things, sloths, lizards
fish.
It hadn't survived the experimental
process.
Ew.
Fate speaker cried.
We've tested it on everything.
Mastermind said proudly.
Turns out it doesn't affect metal, so, he
banged on his helmet, which gave out a
muffled clang in response.
But to anything alive, plant or animal, it
just destroys.
If it gets in your eyes or your
bloodstream, you're dead within minutes.
If it only hits your scales, you'll wish
you were.
We have a couple of recent victims.
I'll be getting to study as soon as
they're released from the healers.
He rubbed his talons together again.
If you're lucky, I'll let you take a peek
he said to Starflight, a once in a
lifetime opportunity to see what rain
wing venom can do.
I know what he can do.
Starflight choked out.
I've seen it kill 2 dragons.
Possibly 3 if Queen Scarlet is dead.
He thought of Fjord.
The 1st Dragon Glory's venom had killed
the Ice Wing, who had been about to kill
Clay in the arena.
Some of the poison had landed on the open
wounds on Fjord's neck.
That must have been why it killed him so
quickly.
And crocodile.
The mudwing who had betrayed the talons
of peace, and led the enemy right to the
summer palace.
When glory killed her so they could
escape.
Her venom had gone right into the
dragon's eyes.
But Queen Scarlet.
He shifted uneasily.
If he remembered right, Gloria's spray of
venom had landed on the side of the
queen's face.
So she really might still be alive, alive
and looking like vengeance, which didn't
bode well for the dragonettes.
Mastermind stared at him avidly.
Two dragons killed them.
Are you sure?
How incredibly careless.
We haven't picked up any rain wings with
that little control yet.
It wasn't careless.
It was on purpose, Starflight said
annoyed on Glory's behalf.
Fate speaker sucked in an astonished
breath.
Well, I never.
Are you sure?
His father's wings flared.
He looked equal parts alarmed and
enthralled.
That changes things entirely.
A variable I hadn't considered.
You'll have to tell me all about it.
What prompted the attack, what it looked
like, how long it took the victims to die
whether there was any time to fight
back.
Starfight realized, too late, that he
shouldn't have said anything.
If this information got back to the
council, they'd know how dangerous glory
was.
He had to hope that mastermind was too
wrapped up in his experiments to tell
anyone.
My, my, my.
Mastermind headed toward the next door.
Well, knowing the venom only worked on
certain substances, led us to the next
project, constructing armor that could
withstand a rain wing attack, if
necessary.
But it isn't necessary.
Fate speaker chimed in.
Rain wings don't attack other dragons.
Everyone knows that.
She looked at Starflight.
Well, they're not supposed to.
Even a rain wing will defend herself
sometimes.
Starflight said.
Hmm, not often, in my experience, said
Mastermind.
But why don't you stand back, just in
case.
He waved them a few steps away.
Settled his helmet over his head again
and flung open the door.
Inside, a dragon was pinned to the wall.
Starflight was lucky his stomach was
empty.
It heaved perilously, and he had to cover
his eyes and take a few deep breaths
before he could speak again.
The rain wing was the sad gray color of
the chains that had bound Starflight in
the Sky Kingdom.
The 1st time he'd been separated from
Sonny.
She drooped against the wall, her wings
outstretched and secured in place.
When he was able to look again, he saw
that what he thought were pins were
actually clamps, holding her where she
was, but not going straight through her
wings as he'd 1st thought.
Not that anything about this is all
right.
What are you doing to her?
Fate speaker cried.
She bolted into the room and lifted their
rain wings, snout gently in her talons.
The trapped dragon barely responded.
This one is done for the day.
Mastermind said.
We were testing to see whether they run
out of venom at some point, if they shoot
it for long enough.
But she fainted before we could get any
really useful data.
She needs water, fate speaker said
glancing around the room, then looking
straight at Starflight.
He hesitated, remembering Fjord and
Crocodile again.
If this dragon did suddenly spray venom
at them, he wouldn't blame her.
But he didn't want to be in the way when
it happened.
Starflight, fate speaker said, and the
tone of her voice reminded him again so
much of Sonny that he couldn't say no to
her.
I'll get some.
He flew to one of the pipes on the
desalinization machine where he'd seen a
faucet earlier, found an empty cauldron
that smelled clean, and filled it up.
Fate speaker had one of the prisoner's
wings unclamped by the time Starflight
got back.
Mastermind stood in the doorway, watching
through the holes in his helmet, but
neither interfering nor helping.
It was hard to know what he was thinking
with his face completely hidden.
Starflight brushed past him and set the
cauldron down, then unclamped the
dragon's other wing.
She slumped forward so suddenly that both
fate speaker and Starflight were nearly
knocked over, but they managed to catch
her and lean her wings over their
shoulders.
Fate speaker held a cauldronap, and the
rain wing revived enough to drink a
little.
What's your name?
Starflight Aster.
She coughed and looked sideways at him.
No, Nightwing, has ever asked my name
before, she whispered hoarsely.
It's orchid.
Oh, Starflight gasped, then closed his
mouth quickly and glanced at the door.
Mastermind was leaning into the hallway
yelling, strong wings, strong wings, you
blockhead, get up here.
Mangrove is looking for you.
Starflight whispered hurriedly.
He hasn't given up.
He'll be here to rescue you soon.
Fate speakers stared at him, as if he'd
just peeled off his scales and revealed a
hippo underneath, but Orchid lifted her
head, her eyes flooding with hope.
A shimmering rose pink spread over her
starting on her chest, and drifting out
to her wingtips.
Soon, she said softly.
Then I can hang on until he comes.
I hope it'll be soon.
Starflight thought.
I hope he doesn't die on his way here.
I hope glory survives too.
I hope my friends are planning to rescue
me as well.
Fate speakers expression was 10 kinds of
confused.
She tilted her head as if she was
listening, and Starflight realized, with
a jolt of panic, that he'd been having
several unguarded thoughts since they'd
started this part of the tour.
He'd forgotten.
How could I forget?
To worry about having his mind read.
But his father hadn't reacted to any of
his thoughts.
Mastermind looked as pleased as ever.
Not a mind reader then, perhaps.
Maybe those kinds of powers aren't
genetically dominant in us.
Maybe it is enough just to be smart like
him.
He'd always thought all Night Wings could
read minds, and all Night Wings could see
the future.
That's what it sounded like in the
scrolls he'd read.
But Glory thought maybe it was only some
of them, and perhaps she was right.
Maybe I'm not completely defective.
Three moons.
Mastermind barked from the doorway.
How did you turn her that pink color?
I've never seen any of them look like
that before.
That's because it's the color of
happiness, and there's no happiness on
this twisted island.
Starflight met fate speaker's eyes.
I think she's just grateful for the water
fate speaker said, blinking at him.
He didn't have to read minds to guess she
was thinking, we'll be talking about this
later.
Fascinating.
Mastermind came over and prodded the
scales on Orchid's neck with one claw.
She closed her eyes.
Her color didn't change.
Utterly fascinating.
A burly night wing slouched grumpily in
from the balcony.
Half a lizard hung from one corner of his
mouth, and his shoulders were almost too
wide for his wings to fit through the
door.
What?
he mumbled, chewing.
This one can go back, said Mastermind.
Oh, and strong wings, guess what?
This is my son.
He waved gleefully at Starflight.
Starflight wished he could go back half
an hour in time to when he'd been just as
happy about those words as mastermind
was.
Strongwings gave Starflight a dubious
look.
Huh, he said.
All right.
So when do I get a helmet like that?
He nodded at the thing on Mastermind's
head.
This is just a prototype, Mastermind
said.
He turned to Starflight.
As you can imagine, the hardest part of
creating venom resistant armor is coming
up with a solution that protects the eyes
but still allows one to see.
I'd love to hear your thoughts, because I
must admit I'm stymied.
This is a thoroughly imperfect solution.
He tapped on the helmet with his talons.
Peripheral vision is negligible at best
and of course, venom could still splash
through the holes if one were unlucky.
He shook his head.
There must be a more ingenious approach.
Whatever.
Strong wings grunt.
Where's her band?
Mastermind waved to the corner, and the
muscular Nightwing picked up a heap of
metal in one of the spears.
He brought it over and fitted a kind of
muzzle around Orchid's mouth, twisting
the lock into place, with a practiced
flick of the spear tips.
Then he shooed Starflight and fate
speaker aside, snapped a chain around the
rain wings neck, and gave it a yank.
Without protesting, or could follow him
out of the room.
But why are you doing this?
Starflight blurted.
Why study their venom at all?
Mastermind pulled off the helmet and gave
him a confused look.
It's science.
We're expanding dragon knowledge.
There's got to be more to it than that.
Starflight said.
Why is this so important?
Why do you need venom resistant armor?
The rain wings would never have bothered
you if you left them alone.
His father shrugged.
The queen has her reasons.
I have mine.
I don't get involved in her plans.
For me.
Scientific discovery is reason enough.
Starflight looked at the clams on the
wall, then down at the floor, too
sickened to ask any more questions.
Well, I wish I had time to show you more
Mastermind said.
Setting his helmet up on a shelf.
But my daily scheduled meeting with a
queen is upon me.
Do you get to see her?
Starflight asked.
No, no, said Mastermind. 3 moons, no.
No one sees the queen.
Not for the last 9 years or so.
She's very private.
Really?
Starflight thought.
I wish I had some more progress to report
Mastermind mused, but telling her about
you will certainly be a triumph.
Come back tomorrow, and we can get to
know each other better, yes?
He wrapped his wings around Starflight
and hugged him, not waiting for an
answer.
It was fantastic to meet you, son.
I am so very proud.
He ushered them out the door and locked
it, then slid away toward a tunnel at the
far end of the balcony.
Starflight glanced along the row of doors
imagining tortured rain wings behind each
one.
Wow, Fate speaker said.
So, turns out we might be horrible.
I did not foresee that at all.
Starflight sat down, his shoulders
slumping.
I believed everything I read.
About Nightwings being so noble and
brilliant and perfect.
This, I can't understand this.
So, where have you been?
She asked curiously.
You're not like them.
And who's mangrove?
I was raised by the talons of peace too
he said. hoping he could avoid the
mangrove question by distracting her.
Actually, I'm the one in the prophecy, or
I was.
I guess I'm expendable, since they're
replacing me with you.
What?
She took a step back. fluttering her
wings.
Wait, I never saw you.
I lived right in the talons of peace
camp.
We were kept hidden, Starfly explained.
Under a mountain.
No one was supposed to find us.
There you are.
Maro seer landed beside them with a
thump.
If you're quite finished with your little
chat.
There are other pressing matters we could
attend to.
I'm not finished, face speaker said
whirling toward him.
He's all special and chosen too?
How can we both be in the prophecy?
Only one of you will be, said Maru Seer
but that's why you're both here, so that
we can decide which one.
So there's still a chance, Starflight
thought.
Don't you know?
Didn't you deliver that prophecy?
Fate speaker asked, wrinkling her nose?
Prophecies can be complicated.
Maro seer said coldly.
Ooh, fate speaker said.
Good comeback.
I should write that down and use it on
Viper.
The real problem.
Moro Cyr went on, is that neither of you
are suitable candidates whatsoever, but
we have no other dragonettes of the right
age we could use.
So it must be one of you.
He growled.
We apparently made a grave error, allowing
you to be raised outside the tribe, where
we thought you'd be safe from, well, just
in case.
It has always been our assumption that
night wing superiority is something every
night wing is hatched with.
He looked down his nose at the 2
dragonettes.
Evidently, we were wrong.
But why aren't I suitable?
Starflight asked.
He hated the plaintive tone in his voice
but he couldn't seem to quash it.
What have I done?
You have no leadership qualities.
Morrisier said.
You make night wings look like cowards
and followers, and you antagonized our
ally.
Blister?
Starflight said, uncomfortably
remembering his interaction with her in
the kingdom of the sea.
He'd tried to find reasons to support her
as the next sand wing queen.
Really, he tried, but she was too
manipulative and too untrustworthy.
And he didn't like the way she'd looked
at Sunny, as if the little dragonette
would make an excellent snack.
You, have placed our whole plan in
jeopardy, Marasier said.
What plan?
Starfly cried.
How am I supposed to make anything happen
when I don't even know what you really
want?
To his surprise.
Mario Seer actually paused and thought
about that.
No.
He rumbled finally.
Dragonettes can't be trusted with
secrets.
Perhaps if you are the one chosen.
We can reveal more.
But all you should really need to know is
how to follow orders.
He scowled.
Now come.
Morosera swept away, lashing his tail.
Starflight and fate speaker exchanged
glances.
Have your visions given you any hints?
Starflight asked about whatever their
secret plan is, I mean?
She scratched her neck, the anklet of
silver scales glittering as she moved.
Let me think.
She closed her eyes for a moment, then
open them again.
Oh, absolutely.
It involves us, but both of us, and we're
going to be heroes, and the whole tribe
will help us stop the war, and maybe
they'll even make us king and queen.
Startled, he blinked at her.
King and queen.
But he couldn't.
She wasn't.
Well, she wasn't sunny.
And he'd been in love with one dragon his
whole life.
Move now, or I will kill you both
prophecy or no prophecy.
Morosier bellowed from the tunnel.
The dragonette scrambled up and hurried
after him, tripping over each other.
Fate speaker bounded into the lead, and
Starflight was left trailing behind, his
mind a whirl of confusion.
He didn't want to think about a possible
future as fate speaker's king, so he
focused on his father's experiments
instead.
Why are they torturing the rain wings?
I can figure this out.
Think, Starflight.
Think.
His 1st guess was that the Nightwings
wanted to use Rainwing Venom themselves.
As vengeance had said, it was one of the
most powerful weapons in Pyria.
If they could somehow replicate the Venom
or adapt it for their own purposes, that
plus their telepathy and precognition
would make the night wings unstoppable.
Maybe their secret plan involved joining
the war.
Once they had this new kind of weapon for
themselves.
Starflight already knew they'd chosen a
side, blisters, although why her?
and why they were thinking of fighting
the war now, 18 years into it, he
couldn't figure out.
Perhaps Blister had promised them
something.
The way Blaze was giving up territory to
the ice wings in exchange for their
help.
Territory.
Starflight stopped in the middle of their
rocky tunnel, as understanding flooded
over him.
That's what they need.
More than anything, the Nightwings need a
new home.
The volcano was extremely dangerous.
Maybe it had been dormant when the tribe
moved here, but it certainly wasn't
anymore.
The night wings were living under its
threat every day, and the island was a
horrible place to live.
They must be running out of prey, with
hardly any fresh water to drink, no view
of the sky through the thick cloud cover
and nowhere to go except through the
tunnel to the rainforest.
The rainforest, which was the opposite of
here, the perfect place to live.
That's their plan.
Starflight clutched his head.
Why hadn't he figured it out sooner?
The Night Wings weren't trying to
reproduce the venom.
Masterminds experiments were all about
how to defend against it, because the
night wings were planning to invade the
rainforest and steal it from the rain
wings, but they were afraid of the rain
wings fighting back.
Even the famously peaceful tribe would
surely have to defend their home.
So the night wings were figuring out how
to protect themselves from rain wing
venom, in preparation for the day when
they stormed into the rainforest and took
it over for themselves.
Is that what blister has promised them?
The tunnel from the rainforest to the
kingdom of sand.
That's for a sandwing army.
Once she is queen, so they can comb
through and help the night wings fight
their rain wings, if need be.
The rain wings were an awful danger.
This wasn't a matter of a few dragons
disappearing here or there.
Glory was right, and Queen Magnificent
was wrong.
They have to fight back, or soon they'll
all be dead.
And I'm the only one who knows.
But he was just Starflight, the weakest
most cowardly dragon ever chosen for a
prophecy.
How could he save the rain wings?
How could he stop his own tribe from
destroying them?
Fate speaker came charging back down the
tunnel?
I keep thinking he can't get any more
grumpy, and then he does, she said.
Come on, hurry up.
He says you have to meet the others in
case you're the dragonette in the
prophecy instead of me.
She waved her talons in front of his
face.
Wake up, dreamy face.
Starflight shook himself as hard as he
could.
Coming, he said.
Although he felt like he could barely
string words together.
Maybe I'm wrong.
But he knew he wasn't.
All the pieces fit together too well.
I figured out the Nightwing's secret plan
he thought.
But now, what do I do about it?
Part two.
The Queen's Secret.
Others.
What fate speaker had said didn't sink in
until Starflight was actually standing in
the cave a short flight from the fortress
facing 4 unfamiliar and unfriendly faces
red, green, brown, and white gold.
They have a sky wing, Starflight
Thought.
And a sand wing who looks like a real
sand wing.
He hadn't met many sand wings in his life
but this one's scowl and restless
hostility made her look like the opposite
of sunny.
The alternate dragonets of destiny.
Mario Cyr growled, scanning them with a
displeased expression.
Who is that?
Said the emerald green seawing, squinting
at Starflight.
Looks like her.
Is he going to be annoying like her?
He jerked his head at fade speaker.
This is Starflight.
Starflight, these are my friends, fate
speaker said, blithely ignoring him.
The Sky Wing snorted, and the sand wing
rolled her eyes.
Over there is Flame.
The sky wing, obviously.
The fat mud wing is ogre, the sand wing
with the sour expression is viper, and
the shrimpy sea wing is squid.
Did she get in trouble?
Squid asked Morrow Seer.
I told her she'd get in trouble if she
left a cave.
I hope you thumped her.
Where have you been?
Viper demanded at the same time?
Jabbing her poisonous tail toward
Morrisier.
We've been here for a whole day and a
half, and no one has checked on us or fed
us anything, but what appears to be
leftovers from a meal 3 months ago.
Most of which he threw up.
Flame said darkly, pointing at Okre.
It was awful, Ogre said.
Probably food poisoning.
You're lucky I'm still alive.
Quite lucky, agreed Flame, since I was
extremely tempted to kill him.
That's why it smells so bad in here, fate
speaker offered.
Can we move to a different cave, or ooh
into the fortress?
If there's a whole other set of
dragonettes, with all the elements that
are really in the prophecy, then nobody
needs us at all.
Starflight's head was spinning.
But if the talents of peace had these all
along, then why treat us the way they
did?
Why keep us around?
And why would the Nightwings send an
assassin after us?
Pieces started to fall into place in his
head.
They wanted us dead, so they could
replace us with these five.
It wouldn't do to have 2 sets of
dragonettes running around claiming
destiny.
Then he thought about the timing, and a
shudder ran through his scales.
We had a chance until we angered blister
until I angered her.
It was after that, when they decided to
kill us.
Because I failed to convince the others
to pick her as the Queen.
Maro Sierra was watching his face
intently, as if he might be listening to
the thoughts running through Starflight's
mind.
So Deathbringer was coming for all of us
Starflight said to him, His primary
target was the rain wing. said Maru
Seer.
Secondary, the sea wing.
The rest of you are still negotiable.
Starflight shook his head.
You can't kill glory and tsunami.
I won't do anything you say if that
happens.
His talons trembled, as if the volcano
were rumbling under his feet.
He half expected Morrow's there to slash
his throat right then.
We'll see.
Said Morrow Seer.
He didn't look very worried.
Your real problem is that my friends are
never going to let you replace me.
Fate speaker said tomorrow, seer.
We were raised together.
We're loyal to each other.
They'll fight back if you try to take me
out and put someone else in.
Replace her?
Viper said alertly.
We can do that.
Do it, said Flame.
I vote yes.
Me too, said Ogre.
He looks quiet.
Quiet would be great.
Can I be the one to shove her off the
cliff?
Squid asked.
Fate speaker gave them all an injured
look.
Very funny, guys.
Starflight got the distinct impression
that they weren't joking.
Poor fate speaker, he thought.
She really thinks they're her friends.
Do you have annoying visions all the time
too?
Squid asked Starflight.
Starflight shuffled his talons awkwardly
but Mario Seer cut him off before he had
to answer.
You may all be replaced, he said, as if
the word tasted disagreeable in his
mouth.
Except for you.
He nodded at flame.
The Skywing Dragonette puffed out his
chest.
Ha!
And don't you all forget it?
Viper hissed at him.
Then why'd you bring us here?
She asked Morrow Seer.
And when can we go back?
Squid asked.
Maro C.R. frowned at Squid.
Starflight could sense that he found the
sea wing unusually irritating.
He wondered if that meant the night wings
might change their minds about tsunami.
If they kept her alive.
They wouldn't have to deal with this
dragon as the alternative.
Then again, tsunami could be pretty
unusually irritating too.
Too bad it didn't work out more neatly
for Morrow's here.
Starflight thought, with a twinge of
satisfaction. 2 unsuitable night wings, 2
annoying sea wings, but 2 perfectly fine
mud wings and sand wings.
He thought Sunny was more than perfectly
fine, of course.
Who needed a poisonous tail when she was
funny, smart, and kinder than any other
dragon in the world.
If you want to be part of this, what I
need to see from all of you, Marcio
growled, is that you can take orders, work
together, and do as you're told.
Take orders and do as you're told are the
same thing.
Fate speaker said to him.
He glared at her.
That's how important it is.
His dark eyes scanned the dragonettes in
front of him.
So, your 1st test, you, he said to
Starflight.
All you have to do.
If you can, is stay alive.
What?
Starflight said.
The rest of you, said Marosir.
Kill him.
He flicked his tail at Starflight.
The dragonettes all stared at him for a
long, awful moment.
Can't we kill her instead?
Viper asked, pointing at fate speaker.
Ooh, yes, I volunteer, said Flame.
No.
Morosier nearly shouted.
What are you waiting for?
That was an order.
I said kill him.
He's serious.
Starflight realized, and then Viper
lunged at him.
Her poisonous tail arching forward like a
scorpion's.
On his other side, Ocher's claws slashed
at his wing, missing by hair.
And Flame made the fire is coming hissing
sound, Star Light remembered from his
terrible training sessions with Kestrel.
Maru Cyr was probably hoping to see
Starflight's fighting skills in action
but Starfly didn't care.
He knew better than to rely on those.
He also knew he couldn't do what he
normally did, which was freeze and hope
nobody noticed him.
Starflight ducked under Oker's wing
shoved squid into Viper, dodged around
fate speaker, and leaped out of the
cave.
Wind whistled through his wings as he
sailed down the cliff.
The shouts of the dragonettes echoed
behind him.
He knew they'd be right on his tail.
He had to find somewhere to hide.
Starflight shot down the cliffside and
banked toward the ocean.
His eyes scanned the ground below him
frantically.
The good news was, if he'd understood
them right, the dragonheads hadn't been
on the island very long, and probably
didn't know its geography at all.
The bad news was, neither did he.
Right now, he was on the other side of
the volcano from the forest.
Here, there were no trees.
Everything below him was dark rocks, or
rivers of glowing lava, nothing to hide
behind.
Ahead of him, there was a strip of black
sand beach that seemed to circle the
island.
He remembered Glory saying that the
tunnel to the rainforest was in a cave
above a black sand beach.
He wandered for a moment if he could find
it, but there wasn't time with the
dragonettes coming after him.
He couldn't outfly them for long either.
Flame, like most sky wings, had enormous
wings, which made them faster than
dragons from any other tribe.
He risked a glance over his shoulder and
saw the bright colors of 4 dragonettes
flash through the sky, much closer than
he would have liked.
Only four.
Fate speaker was nowhere to be seen.
Disobeying orders, or sneaking up on me
some other way.
He didn't have time to think about it
Starflight twisted into a dive and
swooped as close to the ground as he
dared.
His black scales would make him harder to
see against the rocks than if he were up
in the sky.
A blast of steam shot out of one of the
vents in the ground, and he flapped
hastily aside, barely avoiding the heat.
From this close, the rocks below looked
even more like black dragon scales, but
all melted and fused together.
Like mine will be, if Flame and Viper get
their claws on me.
The problem was, the dragonettes were so
close behind him that they'd see anything
he did.
They'd be able to follow him straight to
any hiding place.
It was too risky to try to lose them in
the water or the clouds, not with a sea
wing and a sky wing among them.
He beat his wings faster, trying to
think.
Use your brain, Starflight.
That's all you've got.
There was only one place to hide, the
fortress.
Maybe he'd find a room he could lock
himself into, or maybe his father would
help him.
He swooped into an arc, heading toward it
hoping the Dragonettes wouldn't cut him
off before he reached it.
Another blaze of heat brushed his tail
and he twisted to see where the steam had
come from this time.
To his horror, Flame was only a few wing
beats behind him, with fire curling out
of his nose.
The sight of the sky wing propelled
Starflight forward, the dragonette
beating his wings as hard as he could, but
his muscles already ached with exhaustion
and he knew he'd never make it to the
fortress before Flame caught up.
Then he spotted the caves that lined the
lava river below.
The rain wing prisons.
Glory had described hers in vivid
detail.
Suddenly, a blast of thick smoke shot out
of a vent in the ground below him.
This was a chance he couldn't miss.
He dropped behind the smoke, hoping it
looked as though he was still aiming for
the fortress, and then spiraled tightly
down and dove into the 1st cave he
found.
A nightwing guard was lying across the
entrance.
Starflight shot over her head and tumbled
onto the stone floor.
The guard sat up in a hurry, blinking, as
if she'd been asleep.
Farther into the cave, Starflight heard
scales shifting as the imprisoned rain
wing peeked out of the commotion.
Hey, said the guard.
What are you doing here?
She lashed your tail. looking very large
all of a sudden, despite the ribs visible
through her underscales.
Starflight staggered up to his feet again
trying to look calm and ordinary and like
he wasn't being chased.
I, I, I came to see the rain wing
Starflight stammered.
The prisoner.
The guard frowned suspiciously.
Why?
Um.
Starflight flipped through scrolls in his
head as fast as he could.
There were a few stories about
dragonettes and his favorite scroll, Tales
of the Night Wings.
This couldn't possibly work, but school
project?
He tried.
To his astonishment, the guard completely
relaxed.
Ah, she said.
Assignment for mastermind, right?
That weirdo is all about field studies
and live observation, drives my daughter
crazy.
All right, go ahead.
Just be careful.
Starflight bowed gratefully and fled
toward the back of the cave.
The rain wing prisoner was chained to the
floor and the wall, and a snout was
wrapped in an iron band, like the one
strong wings had put on orchid.
He watched Starflight with a resigned
mournful expression.
His scales were gray and dark blue.
Starflight wondered if extra chains had
been added to all the dragons after glory
and kinkaju escaped.
As far as he remembered, glory had been
muzzled, but not chained to the wall.
He was tempted to tell the sad rain wing
that he would be rescued soon too.
But it was dangerous enough that he'd
told Orchid.
He had no idea whether rain wings could
keep secrets, and if the night wings
found out that he'd been going around
saying reassuring things to their
prisoners.
Well, he couldn't imagine they'd like it
very much.
A commotion of wings sounded outside.
Starflight turned to the back of the cave
which overlooked a huge dark abyss.
Glory had said that all the prison caves
were connected by this chasm, which was
how Kinkachu got from one to the other.
The last thing Starflight wanted to do
was jump into that darkness.
Well, no.
The very last thing he wanted to do was
face Flame and Viper in talented talent
combat.
So, given those choices, leaping off a
cliff into the pitch black was the clear
winner.
He spread his wings and hopped off the
edge, flapping to lower himself down
slowly.
He kept thinking he was about to crash
into something sharp and pointy, but only
empty space yawned below him, as if it
were trying to suck him down.
Finally, several dragon lengths down from
the top, he felt a shallow ledge below
him and gently rested his talons on it
folding his wings in.
Even if someone peered into the chasm, his
black scales should keep him well hidden
in the shadows.
Voices started shouting up above.
Where is he?
That sounded like flame.
Who are you?
roared the night wing god.
Intruders?
A Sky Wing?
Hunter Mudwing.
They've come back for the rest of our
prisoners.
She started banging on some kind of metal
alarm gong that reverberated painfully
off the rocks around Starflight.
He covered his ears, but even over all
the noise, he could still hear flame
bellowing, no, we're supposed to be here
and ocher.
We're with Morrow seer.
We're trying to kill a nightwing
dragonette, Flame shouted.
Did you see where he went?
Wow.
That was the wrong thing to say.
Starflight thought.
They're here to kill our dragonettes!
shrieked the night wing guard.
An almighty crash followed, as if she'd
smashed the gong over Flame's head.
Starflight hoped she had.
Every time he thought of the Sky Wing's
smug face, he thought of how flame was
meant to take glory's place in the
prophecy.
Marusir has been trying to have glory
killed since the 1st moment he saw her, he
thought.
Because she's a rain wing, and he was
afraid she'd figure out the plan and warn
her tribe.
It's not that he thinks she's weak and
useless.
He's actually worried about what she
might do.
As he should be.
The crashing and shouting finally ended
with sounds of what appeared to be
several guards arriving and carting off
flame and ocher.
Starflight hoped Viper and Squid had met
a similar fate, maybe searching for him
in the fortress.
Just in case, he decided to stay hidden
for a while longer.
I could try to escape, he thought.
Now, while no one is watching me.
I could try to get back to the rainforest
to warn glory and the others.
I have an idea where the tunnel is, but
surely it's guarded.
And surely they'd stop me, and even more
Shirley.
Marsir would be furious, and most likely
he'd kill me himself.
He closed his eyes, picturing the island
or I could fly away across the ocean.
Just pick a direction and go.
He already knew he'd never be brave
enough to try that.
There was no way to know where the
nearest land was, or how to find the
mainland from here.
This island had not been on any of the
maps of Pyria he'd ever seen.
That was for sure.
Starflight wrapped his wings around his
talons. rested his head against the rock
wall behind him, and sighed.
Starflight?
A voice whispered above him.
He froze.
The shadows would hide him if he kept
still.
Starflight, it's me, fate speaker.
She called softly.
He realized her voice wasn't coming from
the cave he'd come through.
She must be in the cave next to it.
Also overlooking the abyss.
I'm pretty sure you're down there?
she said.
Because it's a crazy smart and crazy
brave thing to do, which sounds like
you.
Ha!
Starfly thought.
Crazy Brave is the opposite of me.
Crazy Brave is tsunami.
Crazy Brave would have been turning
around to fight all 4 dragonettes at once
which is what she would have done.
Sitting in a dark hole, waiting for
someone else to deal with my problem.
She's right about one thing.
That does sound like me.
Fate speaker sat quietly for a moment, but
he could still hear her breathing.
Of course, if you're not down there, I
sound totally insane right now, she
said.
There's a rain wing sitting next to me
who is giving me the weirdest looks.
Hey there.
What's happening?
Nothing weird, just talking to a pit.
Carry on looking miserable.
Don't mind me.
Ooh.
His ears went a little yellow.
She reported.
Does that mean amused or terribly
annoyed?
What do you think?
Amused.
Starflight thought.
If his very limited study of rain wing
scale shifting was any guide.
I wish I could let you go, sad dragon, she
said to the rain wing.
I'd need one of those long pointy sticks
though.
Starflight, come on.
Get up here so we can talk about how to
help all these sad dragons.
I checked a few of the other caves, and
there are at least 10 of them here.
Can you imagine?
14, according to Kingaju.
Oh, I promise I'm not going to kill you
she added, is that what you're worried
about?
My visions say we're going to do amazing
things together.
That's hardly going to happen if you're
dead, right?
I don't mind telling Morrow, seer, that
my prophecies are just as good as his
prophecies and my prophecies say you get
to live forever.
So there.
Starflight smiled into the dark.
He would love to be present for that
conversation.
All right, he said, I'm coming.
Together, they flew back to the cave
where Viper and Squid were huddled
sullenly against the wall, and Marosier
was pacing back and forth.
Oh, did you lose some dragonettes?
Fate speaker said to him, with mock
sympathy?
Morrisier glared at her.
It's not funny.
Squid hissed.
There were about a 1000 night wing guards
chasing me.
Viper rolled her eyes.
Try four, she said.
They nearly burned my tail.
One of their spears could have taken an
eye out.
And when I told them I was a dragonette
of destiny, they got even more mad.
I want to go home.
Squid folded his wings and sulked.
Plus, I haven't seen any sign of the
treasure I was promised.
We keep our treasures safe.
Marosia rumbled.
Instead of on an ostentatious display
like the other tribes.
He rubbed his forehead.
Perhaps I could have done a better job of
warning my tribe that you were here.
Perhaps you could have.
Viper snapped.
The council has been told.
But apparently the news hasn't spread.
It's going to take some explaining to get
flame and ochre out of the dungeon.
Maro Seer tapped his claws on the rocks
and tipped his head at Starflight.
A clever way to foil your tuckers. whether
you intended it or not.
It's not what I would have done, but it
worked.
Now can we kill fate speaker instead?
Viper asked.
Sometimes, you're just horrible, fate
speaker said to her.
Seems like you had an opportunity to kill
him and didn't take it.
Marasir said darkly.
Look, destiny is destiny.
Fate speaker said.
I don't know why you're so worried about
who's in the prophecy.
You delivered it.
Now you can sit back and watch it
happen.
Whether it's me or Starflight, who
cares?
The night wings, care, said Maro Seer.
The queen has decreed that I should
choose one of you and then kill the
other.
Fate speaker opened and closed her mouth
a few times.
Really?
She finally said, in a small voice.
Starflight felt sorry for her.
Starting with what glory had told him in
the rainforest, he'd had a few days to
adjust to how different night wings were
from his expectations.
Fate speaker was getting it all thrown at
her at once.
Not today, though. said Morrow Seer.
For now, I'm moving you all to the
fortress, so I can keep an eye on you.
He ended up dumping them in the same
dormitory where Starflight had 1st woken
up.
Then, to Starflight's relief, Marosier
stomped off to the evening council
meeting without him.
Are you sure you don't want to take me?
Fate speaker asked him.
Starflight guest, she was hoping to meet
other night wings, ones whom I'd give her
a better impression of the tribe than
Morrow Seer and mastermind.
Very sure.
Stay here.
Marcio growled at her, and try to speak
as little as possible.
She watched him leave.
Her wings drooping.
I was hoping to see the queen, she said
to Starflight.
You heard mastermind.
Nobody sees the queen.
He shook his head.
It looked to me like she does everything
through her daughter, greatness.
Which was something else Starflight
needed more time to think about.
He suspected there was more to that
story.
He wondered if he should try talking to
fate speaker about the night wings plan.
Maybe she'd be willing to help him stop
it.
He knew she felt sorry for the trapped
rain wing she'd seen, but no matter how
sympathetic she was, would she be willing
to betray her tribe?
There was no time to talk to her anyway.
As soon as Maro Seer was gone, Starflight
and Fate Speaker and Viper and Squid were
swarmed by the Nightwing dragonettes who
lived in the dormitory.
Hello, fate speaker chirped.
Hi, hi.
It's so nice to meet you all.
Oh.
So you're the other one, fierce teeth
said, sniffing her.
You don't look that great either.
Look at all the colors, mind readers said
poking squid's green wings, shiny.
Don't touch me, he whined.
Viper, make them stop.
The sand wing ignored him.
She brandished her tail until the
Nightwing Dragonettes got out of her way
then stormed to a sleeping spot at the
farthest end of the dormitory and curled
up on the stone.
Exhaustion was starting to overwhelm
Starflight.
He left fate speaker while she was
introducing herself to everyone. and lay
down in the same place where he'd woken
up a few hours before, He missed his
friends.
He wanted to be eating boar with clay
arguing with tsunami, telling glory about
all his strange new discoveries, and
warning her about the night wings.
But mostly, he missed Sonny.
He missed her warm scales leaning against
his.
Her green eyes watching him while he
talked.
He wanted to tell her about everything
that had happened today, about the
strange hunting habits of the night wings
the terrifying council chamber, the
mysterious behavior of the queen, and
what he'd figured out about their secret
plan.
He wanted to tell her all about his
father. and the alternate dragonettes, and
his eyes closed, and sleep came for him.
Starflight was dreaming, but it wasn't so
much a dream as a memory.
He was waiting by the cave entrance.
When Webbs rolled the boulder aside and
came in.
His wings unfurled, and he leaned forward
trying to see the guardian's claws.
Just one this time.
Web said, untangling a scroll from the
net full of fish he was carrying.
He tossed it to Starflight, who caught it
and turned it reverently between his
talons.
It was damp around the edges, and smelled
like fish, but he didn't care.
He carried it to the study cave, and
found Sonny curled in a small beam of
sunlight that came through the hole in
the roof.
His heart skipped a beat, as she opened
her green eyes and smiled at him.
A new scroll?
she said.
What's this one about?
He sat down next to her and unrolled it
carefully.
It's about us.
His eyes scanned the text quickly.
Oh, weird.
This must have been written recently.
It's all theories about where we are, and
who might be part of the prophecy and how
it might come true.
Sonny sat up and peered over his
shoulder.
Her warm golden scales pressing against
his.
Wow, I'd like to know all that myself.
It says there were 17 sea wing
dragonettes who hatched on the brightest
night, but only 6 of them were from blue
eggs, and maybe it's none of them because
perhaps there were other sea wing eggs
outside the kingdom of the sea, like
children of the talons of peace, it
says.
Or an egg that was stolen by the talons
Sonny pointed out.
Right.
It doesn't mention that possibility.
Starflight went quiet.
Reading a little further.
Does it say anything about the sand wing
egg?
She asked nervously.
The author seems confused about that.
Starflight rolled the scroll along
searching for references to sandwings.
He says, if a sandwing dragonette hatched
on its own in the desert somewhere, it
couldn't have survived, so it must be
someone's egg.
Maybe from the talons of peace again.
That would explain hidden away from the
rival queens.
I wish the guardians would tell us more
about where our eggs came from, Sonny
said with a sigh.
Maybe I should skip ahead to the part
about stopping the war.
Starflight said, rolling the scroll
through his talons.
Good idea.
We're taking suggestions, she joked.
Any war stopping tips are welcome over
here.
Starflight paused on the word Sky Wing.
It says something about how there aren't
any sky wings left who are hatched on the
brightest night.
What?
That's weird.
There must be some in the Sky Kingdom.
Maybe this author doesn't know what he's
talking about.
He kept reading, hoping to keep Sonny
close to him for as long as possible.
We don't need a sky wing anyway, she
said.
We've got glory.
Isn't it exciting that there are dragons
talking about us all over Pyria?
She added dreamily.
Right now, there are soldiers camped on
battlefields talking about how we're the
ones who'll save them from the endless
fighting.
They're dragonettes who want their
mothers and fathers to come home, and
they know we're the ones who'll make it
happen.
We are going to make so many dragons
happy Starflight.
She shifted her wings and shrugged, like
she was trying not to sound too
dramatic.
I mean, I don't know.
It's just nice to know for sure that
we're here for a reason, and we're going
to do something important.
Starflight liked the way Sonny thought
about the prophecy.
The idea of that many dragons relying on
him always made Starflight feel
overwhelmed and anxious.
But for Sunny, the prophecy was a promise
not an order.
Listening to our talk about it was
comforting.
Here, he said.
Possible ways for the Dragonettes to
fulfill the prophecy.
Um, all right.
The 1st theory is that all the
dragonettes are royal daughters, so
they'll all become queens of their tribes
and stop the war that way.
Sonny smothered a giggle.
I can totally see clay as a mudwing
princess.
He grinned back.
It doesn't make sense, though, without an
ice wing, and it means you'd have to be
the next sand wing queen.
No, thank you, Sonny said firmly.
I'm not tsunami.
I would never want to be Queen.
Starfly didn't like the idea either.
Although the part that bothered him was
the thought of Sonny being challenged by
vicious sandwings who wanted to be queen
in her place.
All right, let's find the next, he
started, when suddenly a commotion of
running claws sounded from the tunnel.
They both looked up, as Kestrel burst
into the room with Dune and Webbs right
behind her.
Give me that, Kestrel snarled, snatching
the scroll out of Starflight's talons, he
let out a cry of dismay as it tore
between their claws.
The Skywing peered at the scroll.
Then whipped around to glare at webs.
What were you thinking?
Handing them any piece of trash you find
on the beach?
The fish trader gave it to me.
Web sent offensively.
She knows I'm always looking for new
scrolls.
I didn't have time to read it, but I
didn't think it sounded that bad.
Where are the dragonettes of destiny?
Kestrel read off the title.
That doesn't sound dangerous to you
filling their heads with questions and
ideas.
Our heads are already full of questions
and ideas.
Sonny piped up.
We'll tell you what you need to know
about the prophecy.
Kestrel growled at Sonny and Starflight.
You don't need a pile of gossip and
rumors and speculation cluttering up your
tiny little minds.
Starflight's mind isn't at all tiny or
little.
Sonny objected.
She glanced at Starflight, and when he
didn't say anything, she whispered, hey
your line is, neither is Sonny's.
Starflight knew she was trying to make
him feel better, but he was too nervous
to speak.
Why were the guardians so mad?
Had he done something wrong?
This is not for you.
Kestrel snapped. waving the scroll.
She pointed it at Starflight.
You, battle training, now.
She turned and stomped out of the cave
with the other guardians close behind
her.
Sonny ran to the entrance way, then
turned back to Starflight with a
comically outraged look on her face.
Are you just going to let her do that?
she said.
She took your scroll?
That so unfair.
Starvlight thought so too.
But he definitely was not going to argue
with Kestrel.
It's all right, he said, looking down at
the gray rocks below his talons.
Hopefully webs will bring a new scroll
next week.
Oh, Starflight.
I know you're trying to hide it.
But you're so sad now, Sonny said.
She came and sat in front of him, reaching
to touch his tail with her own.
Listen, that scroll wasn't going to have
all the answers anyway.
You know that, right?
Nobody knows how the prophecy will
unfold.
We just have to always do what we think
is right, and fate will take us in the
right direction.
Maybe, he said.
But a map on how to get there would be
helpful.
You don't need a map, she said.
When you have excellent traveling
companions, like clay, and tsunami, and
glory, and of course, me.
She beamed at him.
That's true, he said, feeling again how
lucky he was.
Of all the caves and all of Pyria, of all
the eggs that could have been chosen
somehow his and hers had wound up here
and 2 dragons who never should have met
were together.
And that's how we'll always be, he
thought.
Starflight woke up to find a claw poking
his snout.
He mumbled.
Everything was still and dark in the
dormitory.
The coals smoldered and the wall niches
like the half closed eyes of slumbering
dragons.
The skylight looked out onto a night with
no stars.
The warmth from his dream faded
instantly.
Sonny was far away. and he had no idea
when he'd ever see her again.
I can't sleep, fate speaker whispered in
the dark.
Her wings rustled as she edged closer to
him and poked his shoulder again.
What are you doing?
Home, said Starflight. sleeping?
Let's go explore, she said.
I want to know more about our tribe, don't
you?
We can go look around the whole fortress
while they're asleep.
He rubbed his eyes and blanked at her.
When we get in trouble.
Why?
She said.
Nobody's told us not to.
We're night wings, aren't we?
Isn't this our fortress too?
Let's explore it before someone tells us
we can't.
There was a kind of logic to that.
Although Starflight wasn't sure Marosir
would agree with it, but really, she was
right.
Why should they get in trouble for acting
like they belonged here?
Besides, it was what tsunami would do.
And wasn't he always thinking he wanted
to be more like her?
He rolled off the bed onto the floor next
to fate speaker, and they padded softly
out into the tunnels.
She picked a direction, apparently at
random, and they started to walk the
empty halls.
The only sound was the tapping of their
own claws and the slithering of their
tails on the stone.
Don't be scared, Starfight told himself
and then told himself again, a few more
times.
You're not doing anything wrong.
There aren't any dangers lying in wait
for you.
You're not being treated like a
prisoner.
You're a night wing dragonette.
This is your tribe.
This is where you could have grown up.
He glanced to the bare walls, not so very
different from the cave where he had
grown up.
This is where you're supposed to be.
No, I'm supposed to be where Sonny is.
I'm supposed to be helping my friends
stop the war.
He stopped walking for a minute to take a
deep breath.
Then hurried after fate speaker.
All the torches had been extinguished, so
the only light came from the glowing red
coals on the walls.
Starflight couldn't even see any of the
moons when he looked out the windows.
The sky was too hidden by clouds and
smoke from the volcano.
He knew they wouldn't find much that
might be useful, unless he was brave
enough to open a door sometime, but he
was terrified of waking up any sleeping
night wings.
He kept imagining walking straight into
Maro Seer's room, and stepping on his
tail by accident, and the death or
dismemberment, or both that would no
doubt inevitably follow.
He was glad to see that fate speaker
wasn't going in the direction of his
father's lab.
Mastermind was surely sleeping like the
rest of the tribe, but Starfly didn't
want to risk encountering him, or get any
closer to the things he'd seen in there.
Every once in a while, as they walked
they heard a quiet snore from the rooms
they were passing.
But they saw no one awake, no guards
anywhere.
I guess they're used to not needing
guards, Starflight whispered.
Since no other tribe could find this
place.
They were always safe from attack.
He thought for a minute.
And even now that they might be attacked
they only need to post guards at the
tunnel.
I'm surprised everyone is asleep, though
fate speaker whispered back.
I always thought being a nightwing meant
you wanted to be awake all night.
I mean, that's true of me.
I can never wake up in the morning, but
once it's dark, I'm full of energy.
Does that happen to you?
I really thought that was a night wing
thing.
But maybe my friends are right, and I'm
just weird.
She kicked a rock sticking out of a crack
in the floor.
Or maybe it is a night wing thing, and
they're all muddled here because they
can't really see the night sky anymore.
Starflight said.
Maybe you're more of a night wing than
any of them.
She fluttered her wings, looking
skeptical.
As for me, I lived in a cave with no sky
most of my life.
So I was on whatever schedule our
guardians told us to be.
But once we were free.
Well, it's been a strange few weeks, so
it's hard to say.
But I do feel more alive when the stars
are out.
Does that make sense?
It does, she said.
Smiling at him.
She paused at an intersection, thinking
and then purposefully turned right.
Are we going somewhere?
He asked her.
Did you see the part of the fortress that
collapsed?
she asked.
I want to see what it looks like from
inside.
He stopped, his heart rattling
nervously.
Wait, he said.
It collapsed because it was covered in
lava.
That can't be safe to explore.
She flicked his nose with her tail.
Oh, stop worrying.
Mighty Claus told me it happened like 11
years ago.
It's just a bunch of rocks now, and he
said it's kind of neat looking.
I guess it covered the part of the
fortress where they used to keep their
treasure, so they had to blast tunnels
into it to get their treasure out.
Tunnels in lava rocks.
It'll be awesome.
Come on.
She bounded ahead and he followed.
More slowly, wishing he'd listened to his
original stay in bed instincts.
Fate speaker's sense of direction turned
out to be better than her sense about
dragons, and before long, they found
themselves in a part of the fortress
where the roof was partly gone.
What looked like thick black bubbles of
rock filled the hall ahead of them.
Chili air whistled through the gaps in
the walls, battling with the heat from
the volcano below their talons.
There, fate speaker whispered, darting up
to where the petrified lava met the
wall.
A tunnel just big enough for a dragon had
been chiseled and blasted and dug out of
the rocks.
Without any hesitation, she headed
inside.
What am I doing?
Starfight asked himself.
He really desperately wanted to melt into
the shadows and stay there waiting for
her.
But he also felt as though she couldn't
go in there alone.
And this time, there was no clay or
tsunami or glory to do the brave thing
for him.
He was the only dragon fate speaker had.
Taking a deep breath.
He forced himself to step into the small
tunnel.
Jagged rock pressed in from all sides
scraping his wings and the top of his
head.
The tunnel twisted quickly downward, so
they had to dig their claws in to avoid
sliding.
Fate speaker breathe a small plume of
fire.
But all that did was illuminate the thick
dark walls that encircled them.
The air was hot and stuffy, and
Starflight began to wonder if anyone had
ever died exploring these tunnels.
Suddenly, the tunnel turned directly down
and dumped them out into an empty space.
Fate speaker fell first, letting out a
shout of surprise.
So Starflight had a minute's warning and
was able to open his wings as soon as his
claws lost their grip on the floor.
Still, he tumbled several feet and landed
on top of her.
Oof, she said.
He scrambled away, and they both lit up
the air with their fire at the same
time.
The room was small, but intact.
The lava had crushed the upper floors, but
left this one preserved.
Starflight could see a small hallway
outside the door, with more rooms beyond
that.
He looked up uneasily, thinking about the
weight of everything above them.
Fate speaker was already hurrying to the
doorway as their fire faded into complete
darkness.
Mighty Claus said the old treasure room
is 3 doors down on the left.
Come on.
But isn't it empty?
Starflight asked.
Following her with his front talons
outstretched.
Are we just going to look at an empty
room?
A fascinating empty room, she insisted.
It used to be full of treasure.
Just imagine.
I've never even seen any treasure
before.
Oh, right, Starflight said.
The talons of peace wouldn't have any, I
guess, unless some dragons brought it
with them when they left their tribes.
If anyone did, they keep it hidden, she
said.
He felt her tail flick against his snout
accidentally, as they both felt their way
along the walls.
You didn't have treasure in your hiding
under the mountain place, did you?
No.
But I've been to the Sky Kingdom. and the
kingdom of the sea, Starflight said.
And I saw enough treasure there to know
that having lots of treasure doesn't make
you a good queen or a happy tribe.
I thought Queen Coral was a good queen
fate speaker said, sounding surprised.
Well, keep in mind, she wrote a lot of
the scrolls you've probably read about
her, Starflight said, but she's not
terrible.
She's better than Queen Scarlet, that's
for sure.
Or blister.
He shuddered, remembering the sandwing
dragon who'd been so disgusted with him.
I bet the sandwings would be happier if
they could find the treasure that
scavenger stole, though, fate speaker
said.
Maybe, Starflight said.
There were some really famous pieces of
treasure in there, including stuff that
was rumored to be animus touched.
Animus touched?
Fate speaker stopped and breathed fire
again.
They were standing under a tall archway
with 2 black metal doors, one of which
was propped open just enough for a
dragonette to slip through.
Animus Touched means an object that's
been magicked by an animus dragon
Starflight explained, and the helpful
teacher voice he sometimes used with his
friends.
So the object is left with some kind of
power, like a necklace that can make you
invisible, or a stone that can find
anyone you're looking for.
Or a statue that'll kill any heir to the
sea wing throne can get its claws on.
It's sort of an archaic term because
supposedly there aren't any animus
dragons anymore, but that's clearly not
true.
There's at least one among the sea wings
and there must have been one not long ago
among the night wings.
Really?
Fate speaker pushed lightly on the metal
door, and it groaned open another inch.
He realized he didn't know how much she
knew about the Nightwing Island.
Yes, there's a tunnel from here to the
rainforest, and one from the rainforest
to the kingdom of sand, which must have
been made by an animus dragon, he said.
I guess I can't be sure how long ago it
was, but none of the rain wings knew
about them.
Isn't that how you got here?
She shook her head.
We flew across the ocean.
It was so long and so boring.
I swear, I nearly fell asleep and ended
up in the sea a couple of times.
He perked up, full of geography questions
but she was already squeezing into the
room and making ooh noises.
He squashed himself through the door
behind her and saw, in the plume of fire
she sent out, a couple of wooden sticks
on the floor.
He picked one up and lit it so they could
look around more easily.
But when he lifted it up, the 1st things
they both saw were the shriveled corpses
of 2 dead dragons.
Starflight clapped his talons over fate
speaker's mouth, mid-shriek.
You'll bring the mountain down on top of
us, he whispered, and she snapped her
mouth shut.
He glanced down at the 2 midnight black
bodies.
Don't worry.
These 2 have been dead a long time, he
added.
Probably since the volcano erupted.
When he released her, she whispered, how
did they die?
Starflight lifted the torch again and
peered a little closer, although he
really didn't want to.
A spear lay beside one of the night wings
but it was an ordinary spear, not the
creepy, hooked and pronged kind all the
guards carried now.
Neither of them wore armor either.
Suffocation, I bet, he answered.
Or starvation, or heat, although dragons
can withstand a fair amount of heat.
My guess is they were guarding the
treasure when the eruption happened, and
they were trapped here.
Nobody could come find them until the
lava cooled enough to make the tunnel we
crawled through, and by then, it was too
late.
Fate speaker shook herself from horns to
tail.
How incredibly awful.
Starflight turned to look around the room
which, as he'd predicted, was otherwise
empty.
Bare shelves lined all the walls, reaching
up to the ceiling, and large urns stood
in the 2 back corners.
He could imagine that they had once been
filled to the brim with gold and jewels.
He caught himself thinking, a giant urn
full of gold and jewels would be kind of
cool to have.
Which was ridiculous.
Just his dragon instincts talking.
What would he do without much gold?
Unless it could get him back to his
friends or stop the war, it would be
useless to him.
Something went ping at the back of his
mind, but before he could figure it out
fate speaker said, maybe we should go.
I think so, Starflight said.
I don't know how much air is down here
but I don't want to find out by running
out of it.
Yikes, she said.
Her eyes widening.
That's all you had to say.
She turned and scooted out of the room
faster than he'd ever seen her move
before.
He took a step to follow her, and the
torchlight flashed on something small and
bright in one of the corpse's talons.
Starflight hesitated.
A piece of treasure that was left
behind?
Something they missed?
Because who would want to search a
corpse?
Well, not him.
Not particularly.
But he felt as if it was calling to him.
As if it had been waiting for him these
11 years, hiding from anyone else who
came along until the right dragon
arrived.
Now you sound like Sonny, with her faith
in fate, and destiny, and signs and
magic.
So, if taking the Lost Jewel was what
she'd want him to do, he braced himself
reached down and plucked it from the dead
guard's claws, rough dead scales scraped
against his, and he shuddered so badly, he
nearly dropped the gemstone, but instead
he gripped it harder and jumped back
knocking against the shelves behind him.
The claws were left clutching the air, as
if hanging on to the memory of treasure
would have to be enough.
Now Starflight felt fairly sick, but when
he held up the torch and glanced down, he
realized he'd done the right thing.
The blue star shaped sapphire glinted in
his talons with a tiny inner spark of its
own light.
He'd only ever read about these.
There were supposedly 3 of them in the
world, all lost, all created 100s of
years ago by a sandwing animus dragon, a
dream visitor.
He closed his claws around it.
With this, he could see his friends
again.
Starflight?
Fate speaker called.
Coming, he said.
He couldn't risk anyone finding the dream
visitor and taking it from him.
Not even fate speaker could know about
it.
He put it in his mouth, tucked down
between his teeth and his scales, and
pressed his tongue over it.
On the way back to the dormitory, Fate
speaker asked why he was so quiet, but he
just shook his head and mumbled that he
was tired.
She shrugged and headed off to her own
bed once they were back inside.
Starflight pulled out the rough blanket
he'd been given, and arranged it so he
could huddle underneath it.
The heavy brown fabric caught on his
horns and smelled like smoke, but it
would keep him hidden from any eyes that
might still be awake.
He cupped the dream visitor in his talons
and stared at it, trying to remember if
he'd read anything about how they
worked.
Perhaps I just think of the dragon whose
dreams I want to visit?
Surely Sonny would be asleep right now, in
the middle of the night.
If he remembered right, he should be able
to step into whatever she was already
dreaming about, and if she were in the
deepest level of dream sleep, she'd see
him, and they could talk to each other.
But if her sleep was shallow or uneasy.
He might be able to see in, but she
wouldn't know he was really there.
And if she were awake, it wouldn't work
at all, of course.
He closed his eyes and pictured Sonny, her
laugh that made everyone else laugh too.
Her flares of temper that vanished as
quickly as they came, her small claws, and
fierce protective face.
Her scales like rippled sunshine, the way
she looked like no other dragon on
Pyrea.
If she were here, she'd know exactly what
to say about his father, she'd tell him
what to tell the night wings about glory
and how to talk them out of herding rain
wings forever.
But no matter how hard he concentrated
his mind stayed firmly in the night wing
dormitory instead of finding her dreams.
Maybe she was awake.
Maybe she was in the rainforest somewhere
looking at the moons, and wondering if he
was looking at them too.
He tried glory next, then clay, then
tsunami.
Nothing happened.
He couldn't reach any of them.
Starflight squeezed the dream visitor
between his claws, grinding his teeth.
This had to work. unless it wasn't really
a dream visitor. it certainly looked like
one.
Try rain wing.
They're always asleep.
The 1st rain wing who came to mind was
Kinkaju, the little dragonette glory had
rescued from the night wings.
Starflight focused on her enormous dark
eyes and quick changing scales.
He pressed the dream visitor to his
forehead, praying that this would work.
And suddenly, he was perched on a branch
in the rainforest.
Starflight took a deep, relieved breath
but he still inhaled the smoke of the
dormitory.
He could see the rainforest, but he
couldn't smell it.
Unfortunately for him.
Kinkachu was curled on a giant leaf
beside him with her eyes closed.
There was a bandage of soft leaves and
moss wrapped around one of her wings, and
piles of red and yellow and purple fruits
all around her, like offerings to a
statue.
Her scales were a strangely pale shade of
blue in the moonlight, and she breathed
shallowly, as if, even in her sleep, she
knew a deeper breath would make something
hurt.
What happened to you?
Starflight wondered aloud, but she didn't
wake up.
He turned to find another dragon staring
right through him.
For a startled, terrifying moment
Starflight thought the dragon could see
him, but then he realized she was just
watching Kinkachu.
She was old, older than any of the
guardians or queens he'd met so far, and
she had that royal elegance about her
that he'd noticed greatness lacking.
Starflight turned back to kinkaju.
How could he get inside her dreams?
He looked down at the dream visitor and
remembered pressing it to his own
forehead.
Carefully, he leaned over and rested the
sapphire between Kinkaju's eyes.
The 1st time he tried, he nearly fell
right through her. since he wasn't really
there.
He couldn't touch her or anything around
her.
But when he tried a 2nd time, holding the
dream visitor where he thought it should
go.
He felt a therm of energy radiate from
Kinkachu through the jewel to him and
back again, and then he saw what she
saw.
In Kinkajoo's dream, she was standing in
bright sunlight, in a wide green bowl
laced with brightly colored flowers
surrounded by 1000s of rain wings, more
rain wings than there can possibly be on
the whole continent, all of them staring
at her with expressions of disdain, that
Starflight had never seen in real life on
any rain wing.
Glory was there in the center of the bowl
but this glory was impossibly big and
impossibly beautiful, and a crown of
orange hibiscus, gold chain, and rubies
sparkled atop her head.
That's how Kinkaju sees her, Starflight
thought.
This glory smiled more too, at least at
Kinkaju.
A crown, he thought suddenly.
Does that mean glory won?
Is she now queen of the rain wings?
Or is this a wishful dream?
Kingetu backed away from the stares of
the dragons until she reached the far
edge of the bowl?
Suddenly she turned and leaped off
spreading her wings, but instead of
soaring away through the trees, she fell
plummeting like a coconut toward the
ground below, her wings flapped
helplessly, and when she twisted to look
at them, giant holes appeared all over
her wings, spreading, as though acid was
eating them away.
Kinkaju screamed and clawed at the air.
Starflight watched helplessly from above
as the greenery swallowed her up.
It's just a dream.
He told himself, that his racing heart
didn't believe him.
Just a dream.
Nothing you could do.
She didn't even see you here.
He wouldn't be able to reach her in a
dream like this, where her emotions were
so strong.
It was really strange to be in someone
else's nightmare, so different from the
ones he had almost every night.
His own anxiety dreams usually involved
the night wing queen telling him that
dragonets who weren't telepathic were not
welcome in the tribe.
The dreamscape around him shuddered, and
then suddenly went dark.
She's waking up.
Starfly dug his talons into the tree
branch below him, even though he couldn't
see it now, and he also knew it wasn't
really there.
Or rather, he wasn't really there.
He wanted to hold on to the rainforest as
long as he could.
He didn't want to go back to the gloomy
nightwing dormitory.
Stay asleep, he thought desperately.
Please see me.
I need to send a message to my friends.
Now he could see faint outlines of shapes
in the darkness. as if it was very early
morning, and the sun was rising far
away.
In front of him.
Kinkaju was curled on the leaf again
still asleep, but twitching restlessly.
A silvery shaft of moonlight lit up the
expression of pain on her face.
She'd snapped out of the nightmare into a
shallow sleep with no dreams, where she
was half aware of everything around her
without being fully awake.
He could be here, but she wouldn't see
him.
Not now.
Another nightmare?
Said a quiet voice behind him.
Starflight whirled around, his heart
leaping into his throat.
Sonny.
The sand wing was just landing on the
branch beside the queenly rain wing.
Her golden wings folded in, and she
flipped her tail over her back talons the
way she always did.
A moment later, a glint of blue scales
appeared through the trees behind Sonny.
Tsunami, flapping down to land next to
her.
I think so, said the older rain wing.
I wasn't sure whether to wake her.
How is the queen?
Mad, said Sonny.
Super mad.
I keep telling her there's no way
Starflight went to the Night Wings on his
own, but she's convinced he's betrayed
us.
Shock rippled through Starflight's
wings.
It hadn't occurred to him that his
friends would think he'd left them on
purpose.
The queen.
Does she mean glory?
Glory thinks I betrayed them?
Then he remembered telling the night wing
council that the rain wings were planning
to attack, and his scales felt hot with
shame.
He may have been abducted, but he hadn't
done anything to help his friends since
he got here.
He hadn't tried to escape.
He hadn't even argued with Morrow seer, or
tried to stop the night wings.
Maybe he really didn't belong in the
prophecy.
Maybe fate speaker was the better dragon
to save the world.
Starflight?
Tsunami snorted.
Of all dragons, like he'd ever betray
us.
Can you actually imagine how it could
have happened?
First, making a decision.
Not exactly Starflight's forte, then
actually doing something instead of
sitting and waiting for it to happen to
him, and not just anything, jumping into
a dark hole with angry dragons on the
other side, Starflight?
Are you kidding me?
Starflight?
Oh my gosh, stop it, Sonny said.
You've been arguing with glory all day.
You don't have to convince me that
Starflight wouldn't do something like
this.
She hopped down to Kinkaju's side, nearly
passing right through Starflight.
He shivered and leaned toward her.
He could almost imagine he felt the
warmth of her scales as she went by.
You don't think he chose to go to the
night kingdom?
asked the dragon Starfly didn't know.
Sonny looked up at the 2 moons that were
visible through the canopy, then back
down at Kinkachu.
If he went, then I'm sure it was for a
good reason, but if he didn't choose to
go, then he needs our help, right
tsunami?
Isn't that the important thing?
Shouldn't we go get him right now before
something terrible happens to him?
She bent to examine the bandage on
Kinkachu's wing.
Yes, Starflight thought frantically.
Please hurry.
If it were up to me, the 4 of us would be
there now. tearing that place apart.
Tsunami growled, instead of wasting our
time here.
Combat training didn't go well. asked the
other dragon.
Tsunami lashed her tails so hard, she
nearly fell off the branch.
General, may I take a nap?
General, I need a papaya.
General, my claws are tired.
General, look, a butterfly.
Somebody is getting stabbed in the face
if you don't shut up.
Sunny smothered a giggle.
When does the queen want to attack?
The older dragon bared her teeth as
though she was ready to go right now.
Oh, look, Sonny interrupted, touching her
front talon lightly to Kinkaju's head.
She's waking up.
No.
Starflight saw Kinkaju's eyes flutter.
He reached out, holding the dream visitor
trying to send her back into dream sleep
but it was too late.
With a wrenching, sideways jolt.
The rainforest, and Kinkaju, and Tsunami
and Sunny, was ripped away.
And Starflight found himself lying on
cold stone once again.
The thick canvas lay heavy on his horns
and the dim red light of the coals pulsed
beyond it, making his eyes ache.
Sonny had been right there, inches from
him, so close.
And yet she might as well have been on
one of the moons.
He stared down at the dream visitor that
glowed faintly in his talons.
Seeing them had somehow been even worse
than not seeing them.
My friends think I betrayed them.
Or if they don't, they think it's because
I'm too much of a coward to do something
like that.
He closed his eyes, feeling lonelier than
he had ever felt in his life.
The blanket was ripped off Starflight's
head with such force that he tumbled onto
the floor.
His head spun for a moment, but his 1st
thought was that he was glad he'd hidden
the dream visitor well the night before.
Oh, Maro CR snarled.
His breath was fiercely awful this
morning.
At least Starflight assumed it was
morning, although the sky was barely
lighter than it had been the night
before.
Flame and ochre stood sullenly behind the
giant night wing, glaring at Starflight.
He hoped they had had to spend the night
in the dungeon.
Fate speaker came bounding over to join
them, followed more slowly by Viper and
Squid.
All around the dormitory, Nightwing
Dragonettes were poking their heads out
of their blankets, watching.
Fierce teeth looked openly envious.
Smoke rose from her snout, and her tail
twitched angrily.
Maro Seer didn't even look at the other
night wing dragonettes.
Let's go. he ordered.
His tail nearly knocked Starflight over
as he turned and swept out of the room.
Where are we going?
Fate speaker asked cheerfully.
She seemed to have recovered from the
news that either she or Starflight were
slated for death.
To see if it's worth spending any more
time on you.
Said Morris here.
Certain dragons think we should lock you
all up until we sort out our rain wing
problem.
But I think you need as much training as
possible starting as soon as possible.
So today, we'll have another test.
A test?
Starflight echoed, flapping his wings.
On what?
We haven't had time to study.
Shouldn't we review the material first?
Maro Seer looked over his shoulder at
Starflight.
Sometimes.
It is very hard not to bite you, he
growled.
Well, that's hardly fair, Starflight
thought, but he decided not to say
anything else.
Usually he was pretty good at tests.
Maybe this was finally his chance to earn
a place in the prophecy.
Especially if it's about history.
I read all the history scrolls several
times each.
He noticed that Flame was still glaring
at him with resentful orange eyes.
Carefully, Starflight maneuvered so that
fate speaker was walking between him and
the hostile Skywing Dragonette.
The 6 of them trailed after Maroseare all
the way to a roof of the fortress that
faced the small island forest.
Morosea spread his wings and narrowed his
eyes at the sky, which was dark gray, and
flickered with faraway lightning.
In the distance, the clouds seemed to be
pouring down into the ocean.
A storm out at sea.
Starflight thought.
He shuddered, remembering the storm that
had nearly flooded the cave in the
kingdom of the sea.
Clay had been chained to the wall, and
Glory and Sonny had been so determined
not to leave him.
If tsunami hadn't come for them, they
probably would have decided to drown
along with clay.
Starflight wasn't sure he'd have been
able to do that.
He'd been too scared to say anything
watching the water slowly rising toward
them.
Stay close to me.
Marosio growled.
He jabbed Starflight in the neck with one
claw.
Don't try anything.
And then he lifted into the sky without
any more explanation or instructions.
It took Starflight a moment to figure out
that they were leaving the island.
Back to the mainland?
He leaped into the air, his heart jumping
hopefully at the same time.
Wait, Squid called in a complaining whine
flapping after Morrow's here.
We haven't even had breakfast.
You're not going to make me fly on an
empty stomach, are you?
Because I will die.
I will literally die.
You won't, actually.
Not for a while, Starflight informed
him.
Most dragons can naturally survive for up
to a month without eating, if necessary
according to a natural history of
unnatural dragon abilities.
Listen to the scroll worm.
Flame said nastily.
Isn't he clever?
I will never, never.
Never go a whole month without eating
Okre said passionately.
Is one of the unnatural abilities being
really annoying, Viper asked, because
there should be a whole chapter on you
and fate speaker.
You don't even know me, Starflight
pointed out.
I was just trying to help.
I thought it was interesting, fate
speaker said. and probably useful.
If the Night Wings keep feeding us the
horrible stuff they've been bringing so
far.
Oh, I have a theory about that.
As they flew over the forest and out
across the ocean, Starflight told her
about how the night wings hunted, and his
ideas about the bacteria in their mouths
and how he and fate speaker probably
didn't have it, since they'd grown up
eating live or recently killed prey, and
hadn't developed the bacteria like the
night wing dragonettes on the island
would have.
Wow, said fate speaker, looking genuinely
fascinated.
Is this the test?
Viper asked.
Listen to you for as long as we can
without dying of boredom.
Nobody's talking to you, Viper, fate
speaker said.
Go be grumpy at squid and leave
Starflight alone.
Starflight glanced down at the waves
rushing below him.
The island was disappearing behind them
visible only as a red glow in the sky.
Ahead of them was nothing but sea as far
as the distant horizon.
He had no idea how Maro Zero was
navigating.
There were no landmarks, and the sky was
still hidden behind the clouds.
I should pay attention so I can fly this
way if I ever get a chance to escape.
Actually, what he should do was try to
escape once they reached the mainland.
Just fly away, hide, try to get back to
the rainforest.
He could not in a 1000000 years imagine
doing any of that by himself.
Maybe with tsunami and clay and glory and
sunny, but alone?
It sounded much safer to stay with the
night wings and hope someone came to
rescue him.
Rain began to fall.
Or rather, they reached the edge of the
storm, and Starflight realized that
Marosier planned to fly right through
it.
My wings are getting wet.
Squid griped.
Boo hoo, you poor sea wing.
Flame snapped.
Starflight wasn't about to say anything
aloud, but the rain made his wings
heavier, and it was much harder to fly.
He didn't have the strongest flying
muscles anyway.
Being raised in a cave meant not much
opportunity to practice.
He clenched his jaw and flew on.
If this was the test, he refused to
fail.
He would fly until his wings gave out, and
he would not let anyone see how much it
hurt.
Think of Sonny.
Think about being the dragon, you want
her to think you are.
The sea kept getting closer, which he
knew meant he was drooping.
The rain pelted down harder and harder
battering his scales, and making it
almost impossible to see ochre flying
just ahead of him.
Maroser was a dark blur in the clouds.
Starflight hoped they didn't lose him.
He hoped Maro Seer wasn't trying to lose
them because it wouldn't be hard in this
weather.
A bolt of lightning sizzled through the
sky, followed instantly by the loudest
thunderclap Starflight had ever heard.
His whole body shook with the
vibrations.
I hope we get there soon.
He blinked away raindrops, and realized
with a sickening lurch that the sky ahead
of him was empty.
Where are the other dragons?
For horrible moment, he was completely
lost.
Then fate speaker appeared at his side
and nudged his wing.
Down there. she shouted over the wind.
What looked like a small smudge on the
ocean turned out to be a tiny rocky
island.
Marosir and the others were perched there
already.
Starflight landed awkwardly next to Squid
who had his wings over his head and was
muttering angrily.
Halfway there, fate speaker grinned at
him.
Only halfway?
Starflight's resolution wavered, and he
stared down at his claws.
He was too exhausted even to ask all the
questions brimming inside him.
How had the night wings found their
island, if it was this far from the
mainland?
How often did they go to the mainland?
And did they usually use the tunnel to
the rainforest, or fly over the sea like
this?
He guessed most of them would choose the
tunnel if they could, rather than risk
this exhausting flight.
Marasier allowed them to rest for a short
while.
He didn't speak.
His dark eyes glowered at all of them, and
occasionally he glanced back in the
direction of the volcano.
All too soon, he gathered himself and
said, let's go.
And then they were all flying once
again.
Rain, thunder, aching wings, raindrops
filled Starflight's eyes, lightning
blazed too close to his tail.
Off to his left, squid was complaining
loudly, but no one could hear him over
the storm, or else no one had any energy
to respond.
Starflight was starting to think that
drowning wouldn't be such a bad way to go
after all, when he saw Mario Seer tilt
his wings and begin sailing downward.
Land had appeared in front of them quite
suddenly.
Starflight hadn't been able to see it
through the clouds and rain.
Now I saw a coast lined with jagged
cliffs, steep and rocky and plunging
straight into the sea.
Behind them jetted sharp peaks like
dragons' teeth, some of them tipped with
snow, extending in a relentless line
across the horizon.
The claws of the clouds mountains.
His heart sank.
He'd hoped they were near the southern
coast and the rainforest, but this had to
be Pyria's northern edge, where the sky
wings rolled, too close to Queen
Scarlet's palace, too far for him to fly
back to his friends.
It would take days, and he'd have to
travel alone through the Sky Kingdom and
the Mud Kingdom.
I'm sorry, Sonny.
I can't do it.
I can't find my way back to you.
His wings felt like glaciers, slow and
heavy, and dragging him down, as he
followed Marosir and the others to the
cliff top in the driving rain.
Bare rocks scraped beneath his claws when
he landed, and he bent forward, gasping
for breath.
Squid sprawled out flat on his back
groaning with pain, and Ogre immediately
began sniffing the rocks, as if he were
hoping to startle out some prey.
Flame was the only dragonette who wasn't
breathing heavily.
Starflight looked up and caught Maro Seer
studying the sea behind them again.
He had a weird flash of intuition that
made no sense.
Is someone following us?
he asked Maru Seer.
That's none of your concern.
Maro Seer answered.
He spread his wings and pointed down the
coast.
Through the storm, Starfly could barely
see the glow of firelight coming from a
cave in the cliffside.
What is it?
Fate speaker asked.
The most remote outpost of the Sky Wing
army, said Marisir.
Their assignment is to guard against
attacks from the north, in case Queen
Glacier ever decides to try this approach
to the palace.
There are no other dragons for miles.
This is your test.
They all stared at him, uncomprehending.
What is, Starflight finally asked, the
wind ripped his voice away.
You want us to kill them, Viper guessed.
She arched her poisonous tail and flexed
her claws.
All of them?
I don't want to, Squid whined.
What if someone bites me?
Shut up, or I'll bite you, Flame said.
He looked deeply rattled, as if he'd
never expected to be asked to kill
members of his own tribe.
Starflight wondered suddenly where all
their parents were, and whether these
dragonettes dreamed of home and family
the way his friends had.
No, you're not here to kill them, Marosier
snapped.
You're the dragonettes of the great
prophecy, remember.
Your test is to act like it.
He pointed to the outpost.
Go in there.
Tell the guards that you are the real
prophesied dragonettes, and convince them
to switch their alliance from burn to
blister.
In the shocked silence that followed, a
hurricane forest wind came howling up and
tried to throw them all off the cliff.
Starflight dug in his talons and made
himself as small as he could.
Just convince them?
Piper shouted at Maru's ear, raindrops
flying as she shook her head.
A bunch of strange sky wings?
So instead of killing them, we're going
to ask them to kill us.
I foresee that this is going to go really
really badly.
Fate speaker yelled over the wind.
Me too, cried Ogre.
Maybe I have special night wing powers
too.
They're going to kill me, Squid shouted.
Sea Wings and Sky Wings are enemies.
If you send me in there, I'm dead.
Morrisier's expression suggested that he
wouldn't be terribly devastated by that.
If you can't survive this, he rumbled.
And you're useless for the prophecy
anyway.
He pointed at fate's speaker.
You stay here.
Well, see how well that one does, this
time.
He flicked a claw at Starflight.
Starflight wanted to melt into the
rocks.
He wanted to leap off the cliff into the
sea.
He wondered how far he would get if he
bolted for the mountains right now.
With a journey to the rainforest to be
any worse, then walking into a sky wing
guardhouse and announcing himself as one
of the dragonettes Queen Scarlet had lost
not long ago.
Won't they just take us prisoner?
he asked Morrow Seer, and take us back to
the Sky Palace?
Oh, if you're convincing enough, Maris
here said, bearing his teeth.
Now go.
He shot a blast of fire at squid, who
barely leaped out of the way in time.
I don't want to, Squid complained again.
But Viper and Flame were already shoving
him forward.
Oker trailed after them, and Starflight
reluctantly brought up the rear.
He glanced back once, and saw fate
speaker huddled into her wings, a small
drenched shape beside the vast bulk of
Marosir.
He hoped his friends would welcome her as
the new night wing when he was gone.
I'm about to die.
He thought.
And I never got to tell Sonny I love
her.
I'm going to die without saving the
world.
Without stopping the war, without ever
doing one brave thing in my life.
As they approached the firelight
Starflight's dread grew heavier and
heavier.
Loud dragon voices spilled from the cave
along with a column of smoke that rose
from a hole in the stone wall.
What if someone's on watch?
Starflight whispered when they were a few
lengths away.
They all froze.
Starflight searched the darkness around
them with his eyes, trying to move as
little as possible.
Lightning flashed, and Starflight's heart
seized up.
Perched on a cliff top above them, was a
dragon with enormous wings staring out to
sea.
There, he whispered.
Surely he could see them.
Why hadn't he called out to warn the
other soldiers yet?
Starflight squinted at the shape, at the
rise and fall of its shoulders and the
curve of its neck, and it realized that
the guard was asleep.
Despite the rain pouring down on him
despite the booming thunder, despite his
whole job being to stay awake.
We're all right, he whispered to the
others.
They crept toward the cave, staying
closer to the shadows now, a wooden door
blocked the entrance.
Wait, Starflight whispered.
Flame paused with his front talons raised
to knock.
He frowned at Starflight.
Let's be smart about this, Starflight
said.
We don't have to charge right in.
Let's listen for a minute and see if we
hear anything that might be useful.
Fine by me.
Okre said with a shrug.
But it's wet out here.
Squid grumbled.
Flame and Viper exchanged glances.
And then, to Starflight's surprise, they
both nodded.
Perhaps fear made them more agreeable.
The 2 of them put their ears up to the
wooden door, so he crept along the wall
and crouched below the smoke hole.
He tried to arrange his wings in a way
that would shield him at least a little
bit from the rain.
There seemed to be several arguments
going on inside.
Starflight could only catch snatches of
one that seemed to be closest to the
fire.
Your queen, Ruby, says we can return to
the palace, you better believe I'm going
home. growled one dragon.
You'd be obeying the orders of a false
queen, snarled another.
Queen Scarlet is still alive, and she'll
have us all killed if we abandon our
posts.
Then where is she?
Challenged a 3rd voice.
What kind of queen leaves her kingdom in
chaos like this?
It's not chaos.
We have Ruby now, said the 1st voice, and
she says we can leave.
But Queen Byrne says we shouldn't, said
another dragon.
She's not our queen, snapped more than
one voice.
That's enough.
No one's going anywhere today.
Boomed someone authoritative sounding.
The hubbub of voice is stilled.
Not in this storm.
We'll discuss it again tomorrow.
After a moment, a murmur of grumbling and
muttering started, but nothing that
Starflight could pick out.
He crept back to Flame and Viper.
Useless.
Flame hissed.
Perhaps not, Starflight said.
Did you hear how some of them are
dissatisfied with burn?
We can press that, I think.
If she's trying to act like she's their
new queen.
I bet a whole lot of Skywings would be
willing to reconsider their alliance.
Fancy talk, said Viper, flicking our tail
at him.
Now let's see you actually do it.
She shoved squid away from the shadow of
her wings, where he was trying to
huddle.
Flame wrapped on the door before
Starflight could think of another way to
delay.
All the noise inside abruptly stopped.
Stamping feet approached the door, and it
was flung wide open.
Starflight found himself facing a room
full of sky wings.
Most of them were clumped in small groups
eating, or rolling prey bones in games of
luck.
Red, orange, and gold scales gleamed in
the firelight.
Savage looking spears, leaned casually
against the wall, and a map next to the
fireplace showed the continent of Pyrea
with an X where the outpost was located
and arrows showing possible attack routes
from the ice kingdom.
What in the?
said the guard who'd answered the door.
He trailed off, staring at them.
The whole room.
About 17 dragons, Starflight estimated
turned to stare as well.
Starflike could easily imagine how they
looked.
Five bedraggled dragonettes, soaking wet
and exhausted, in 5 different colors that
were normally not seen together.
One of the sky wings inhaled sharply.
It's them, he hissed.
It can't be, said another.
For some reason, Flame, Viper, and Oak
are all glanced at Starflight, but his
power of speech had abandoned him.
All he could think about was the cold
spire where he'd been imprisoned by Sky
Wing Guards, just like these, only a
short time before.
He wanted to cower behind the other's
wings the way Squid was doing.
Flame let out a small snort of fire, and
drew himself up as tall as he could get.
It is us, he said.
From the prophecy.
The dragonettes of destiny, said one
soldier, in an awe struck voice, wow.
Dragons actually call us that?
Viper said.
Lame.
I hereby forbid anyone to use that phrase
again.
Is that a roasted seagull?
Ocher asked?
Shoving his way forward and pointing at a
half eaten carcass on one of the tables?
Is anyone going to finish that?
Without waiting for an answer, he
snatched the bird and sank his teeth into
it.
Behind Starflight, Squid let out a small
whimper.
A few of the sky wings exchanged glances
looking a little more skeptical than they
had a moment ago, Starflight could feel
panic rising in his chest, he had to
speak up.
He had to be convincing, but his jaw felt
like it was welded shut.
Why are you here?
asked one of the soldiers.
After you escaped, why come back?
To hear of all places.
And what did you do to the sea wings?
asked another.
No attacks, no raids, no sign of them
since we destroyed their summer palace.
We know plenty of them must have survived
so where's the counterattack?
Do you have Queen Scarlet?
demanded a dragon leaning on the wall by
the fire.
What have you done with her?
Flame waved his front talons, as if none
of these questions were important.
We're here to tell you, you're supporting
the wrong sand wing.
He tilted his head arrogantly.
Burn isn't going to be queen, like the
prophecy says, she's going to die.
We've chosen blister.
The uproar was immediate.
Several dragons sprang to their feet
knocking over tables and scattering bones
and ashes everywhere.
How dare you?
somebody shouted.
We're not taking orders from some puny
dragonettes.
We'll never let the sea wings win.
One of the guards shoved flame in the
chest.
Traitor.
The red dragonette stumbled back, stepping
on Starfly's claws.
Blister killed my brother, roared another
soldier.
She will never be queen.
Her fate is to die beneath my talent.
We're the dragons from the prophecy.
Viper yelled over the din.
You have to listen to us.
No, you're not.
Said the same authoritative voice
Starflight had heard from outside.
An orange dragon with a long, scarred
neck stepped forward, peering intently at
the dragonettes.
Starflight had a feeling he'd seen the
sky wing before, probably in the queen's
palace.
The other Skywings quieted as the soldier
reached around Starflight, seized Squid's
ear, and dragged him into the middle of
the room.
Squid yelped with pain, flung his wings
over his head, and sat down, gibbering.
That is not the sea wing we captured
before. said the orange dragon
contemptuously.
You saw the marks she left on the guards
she fought with, and I do mean she.
Also, she was blue.
This sniveling creature is no dragonette
of destiny.
He looked around at the others, his eyes
gleaming with suspicion.
I say we kill him.
Perhaps we kill them all.
No, Starflight blurted.
I am the knight wing the queen held
prisoner.
I swear I am.
Remember, she had me fight scavengers.
And then the other night wings came and
took me.
He held his breath.
Please believe me.
The dragon breathed a plume of smell at
him, then narrowed his eyes at ocher, who
had moved on to gnawing on a large leg
bone he'd found on the floor.
I suppose that could be the mud wing, he
muttered.
And we never saw the sand wing or the sky
wing.
He studied Flame and Viper.
We assumed the queen was holding them
elsewhere in the palace in case they
could be fixed and allowed to rejoin us.
His gaze stopped on flame.
But perhaps, living with the talons of
peace will ruin any dragon, even from the
best of tribes.
He jabbed squid sharply with his tail, and
the small green dragon moaned unhappily.
If you are the night wing from the palace
he said to Starflight.
What happened to the sea wing who was
with you before?
She's...
Starflight felt hopelessly stupid.
Why hadn't Moros here guessed this might
happen?
Did he think this outpost was so remote
that no one from the palace would be
here?
But if he really wanted to replace
tsunami with squid, he had to know
someone would notice and object sooner or
later.
He knew he should act like Squid was the
real prophecy dragonette.
Especially if they all wanted to get out
of this cave alive, but he couldn't bring
himself to betray tsunami, who, if you
asked him, in all of Pireo was the dragon
most likely to fulfill a prophecy and
save the world.
He braced himself and looked the orange
dragon in the eye.
She's gathering an army.
This was true.
No need to mention that it was an army of
rain wings.
We're going to end this war.
He turned to the other sky wings in the
cave.
Soon you'll be able to go home to your
families.
Soon you will all be safe.
Soon there will be peace.
He caught a look of longing on some of
their faces.
Even the fierce, bad tempered, sky wing
tribe wanted a chance to live
peacefully.
He was sure of it.
Was that a prophecy?
One of the soldiers whispered to
another.
Starflight shook his head.
It was a promise, he said.
Viper let out a muffled, impatient
snort.
Starflight knew even his real friends got
fed up with a way he sounded like an epic
scroll sometimes, but he couldn't help
it.
When he thought about prophecies and
acting like a hero.
That's how he thought they should all
sound.
But what about blister?
asked the orange dragon.
Have you really chosen her?
Is she the next sandwing queen?
Several of the Skywings hissed, rattling
their wings.
Flame and viper and squid, and even ogre
were watching Starflight now.
He could guess that they were willing him
to say the right thing here, to convince
everyone that blister was the choice of
destiny, that she was going to win, and
nobody could do anything about it.
But he remembered blisters menacing
stillness, and the glint of evil in her
eyes.
He remembered the way she manipulated the
sea wing queen, and he remembered that
she'd killed Kestrel and tried to kill
Webbs, although there wasn't any good
reason why.
Oh.
He glanced at the alternate dragonettes.
If blister wanted to pick and choose her
dragonettes of destiny, she needed the
original guardians dead, so they couldn't
dispute her version of history.
His mind was racing.
She knew about glory when we met her.
She even said she had Nightwing friends.
She's conspiring with them.
Which meant she was almost certainly part
of the plan to assassinate glory and
tsunami too.
He coiled his tail.
He couldn't make her the next queen of
the sand wings.
If his voice had any power.
He couldn't let her use it.
No, he said, wincing as his voice
cracked.
He sounded like a one year old dragonette
pretending to be a queen.
We haven't chosen anyone yet.
So choose burn, said one of the
soldiers.
Several others nodded.
Burn is cruel, Starflight said.
You know she is.
She lives for war.
Even if she wins.
She won't stop killing and fighting.
She'll probably turn on all of you and
try to take your kingdom next.
There was no uproar this time, only
shocked silence.
They may not have wanted to admit it to
themselves, but what he'd said was true.
Burn was not a safe ally to have, and
she'd be a very dangerous queen of the
sand wings.
Yeah, Flame said half heartedly, what he
said.
So, was that a prophecy?
The same soldier whispered.
Let's take them back to the palace, said
the orange dragon decisively.
We'll turn them over to Queen Ruby and
let her decide.
If they know anything about Queen
Scarlet's whereabouts, she'll get it out
of them.
He lashed his tail.
No, Starflight thought, backing toward
the door.
Back to the Sky Wing Palace.
That would be even worse than staying
with the night wings.
Queen Scarlet had tried to make him fight
to the death in her arena.
He still had nightmares about scavengers
with sharp weapons climbing his neck
determined to stab out his eyes, or about
a horde of ice wings descending to
destroy him, even though Marosir had
taken him away before that happened in
reality.
But this wasn't a dream.
The sky wind claws reaching for him were
real, and his legs really were not moving
and he couldn't remember a single
training move that might help him fight
back, and he was about to be captured and
imprisoned once more.
And then, the door burst open, and the
night wings came blazing in.
That who was following us, Starflight
thought, with a jolt of shock, as 8 night
wings came to the door, breathing flames
in all directions.
He saw the tables and the map catch fire
and he saw flames engulf the orange
dragon, and then he felt talons seize his
tail, and he was dragged out the door
into the pounding rain outside.
Flame, viper, ochre, and squid were
tossed on top of him, howling.
By the time Starflight struggled free and
looked up, the door of the outpost was
ablaze.
Inside the cave, fire raged from wall to
wall.
Skywings were shrieking in agony.
A troop of black dragons blocked the way
out, killing any soldier who tried to
escape.
No, Starfight yelled.
I promised them, I promised them.
He flung himself at the back of the
nearest night wing, but the dragon
shrugged him off easily.
You can't kill them.
Starflight hadn't wanted to be taken
prisoner, but these soldiers were just
ordinary dragons, following their queen
and doing their jobs.
They wanted peace as much as he did.
They didn't deserve to die like this.
Morris here.
Starflight cried.
Stop them.
You are peculiar.
Morris here said from the shadows right
beside him.
Starflight jumped.
They're only a handful of sky wings.
Why would you care?
Can't you spare them?
Starflight said desperately.
Please, let them live.
It's much too late for that.
Said Morris here.
Starflight turned to face the flames. and
realized that this had been Mario Seer's
plan all along.
That's why he'd chosen a remote location
with a limited number of dragons.
That's why he didn't care if the soldiers
questioned Squid's presence.
It was all part of the test.
But whether the Dragonettes passed or
failed, he'd planned to kill all the Sky
Wings, no matter what.
To erase any evidence that we were here
by murdering any witnesses who might
wreck our story.
He stared hopelessly into the fire
certain that he'd be hearing dragons
screaming in his dreams for the rest of
his life.
They nearly killed me.
Squid shouted at Maru Seer, just like I
said they would.
I quit.
I don't want to be in the prophecy
anymore.
There's no treasure and it's boring and
stupid.
I'm hungry and I hate your island.
I wanna go home.
Fine.
Maro Cyr snarled coldly at him.
I've never met Dragonette more pointless
than you.
Go sniveling back to the talons of
peace.
See if you can find them by yourself.
I hope you die on the way.
He shoved squid forcefully in the chest.
Get out of here.
Go. Squid stumbled back, slipping on the
wet rocks.
It took him a moment before he could
talk.
By myself?
He squeaked.
But, but you wouldn't, my dad is the
leader of the talents.
You have to be nice to me.
You can't send me off.
I certainly can.
Morrissier hissed.
Lightning flashed in the sky above him
illuminating the dark mountains looming
over them all.
Leave.
Oh, I will kill you.
I never want to see you again.
Three moons, Starfly thought.
He really hates squid.
Wait, fate speaker said, reaching toward
the sea wing.
Marcier, wait.
He's one of us.
We can't lose him.
Squid grabbed your front talons and
squeezed, looking desperate.
We have another one.
Morris here said.
We just have to retrieve her from the
rainforest.
But she's clearly made an impression on
any dragons who run into her, so we're
stuck with her.
Whereas this one is nothing but useless.
It's not fair.
Squid whined.
It's not my fault.
Some other sea wing is better than me.
That's true, Starflight thought.
Feeling an unexpected stab of pity for
the sniveling green dragonette.
No one could live up to tsunami.
You can't do this!
Bates speaker cried.
Flame.
Viper, tell him.
Viper shrugged, and Flame hunched his
wings.
His eyes were fixed on the cave where his
fellow sky wings were burning.
He said he doesn't want to be in the
prophecy anyway.
Ogre said to fate speaker.
I didn't mean it, Squid cried.
Maro Seer whipped his tail around and
smacked Squid hard over the head.
Leave now.
Be grateful I'm not killing you instead.
Whimpering, Squid backed away, spread his
wings, and lifted into the storm soaked
sky.
Starflight watched him flap slowly toward
the claws of the clouds mountains.
A sea wing, alone in sky wing territory.
Squid wouldn't last a day.
Starflights had pounded, and he felt
nauseous.
Every time he thought he'd seen the worst
of Maro seer and the night wings.
They did something even more horrible.
Fate speaker was crying.
Tears and raindrops together soaking her
face.
She pressed her talons to her eyes, as if
she wished she could claw them out.
Starfly put one of his wings around her
and she leaned into his shoulder
shaking.
Maybe he'll be all right, he whispered.
Sometimes dragons surprise you.
Don't get comfortable.
Marosir said to Starflight.
You are running out of chances to show me
you can obey orders.
Starflight wound his tail around fate
speakers thinking, why should I have to?
Who decided you get to order me around?
He realized he didn't even care if Maro
Seer read his mind, and he stared at the
big dragon, waiting for a reaction.
Mara seer looked away first.
Back to the island.
He ordered.
The others will clean up this mess.
He flicked his tail at the ruined
guardhouse, then leaped into the sky.
Fate speaker turned toward the mountains
as if she was thinking about going after
squid.
Starflight wished he were that kind of
dragon.
Would he disobey Maro seer, and chase
after one of his friends, if this had
happened to them?
He thought he would for Sonny.
He would never let her fly away alone
into death.
He thought perhaps he could be brave for
her, if he ever needed to be.
Not brave enough to escape right now
though, he realized.
But maybe they're coming to rescue me.
Maybe I should wait for them anyway.
Or maybe.
I'm looking for excuses to do nothing.
Come on, before anything worse happens, he
said gently to fate speaker.
She wiped her eyes and followed him into
the rain soaked sky.
The flight back to the island was even
more exhausting than the flight out, and
the storm was relentless the entire way.
Starflight's whole body felt numb by the
time they touched down in the Nightwing
fortress.
None of the dragonettes spoke as they
trudged back to the dormitory behind
Morrow Seer.
Training at dawn tomorrow, Morris here
said, stopping at the doorway.
The room was empty.
The other night wing dragonettes were
nowhere to be seen.
He eyed Starflight and fate speaker, then
turned to go.
So, nothing to eat?
Okre ventured in a woebegone voice.
It had now been days since Starflight's
last meal, tiring energy sucking days, but
he didn't think he had the strength to
eat anything tonight anyway.
He just wanted to close his eyes and
tried to forget the sad, dripping shape
of squid flapping away into the
mountains.
No, Marosia rumbled, and then he was
gone.
Ogre sighed pitifully.
Viper hissed and marched to the sleeping
hollow she'd chosen, burying herself
immediately in a thick canvas blanket.
Flame lashed his tail for a moment
studying the room.
Not much better than last night's dungeon
he muttered.
He and Ocher found spots beside Viper at
the far end of the room, and soon the mud
wing was snoring, but the Sky Wing
Dragonette sat and stared into the coals
unmoving.
Starflipe was half asleep already, but
the minute he curled onto his bed, fate
speaker hopped up beside him.
Starflight objected sleepily.
I know what we have to do, she
whispered.
We have to talk to the queen.
We?
Starflight asked.
You and me, without Morrow's here.
Maybe she has no idea how awful he is.
I bet he's lying about her ordering him
to kill one of us.
I bet he came up with that himself.
Starflight coiled his tail, feeling
uneasy.
He wondered how involved Queen Battle
Winner was in decisions about the
dragonettes and the prophecy.
Had she ordered their trip to the
mainland, and the deaths of those
Skywings?
I bet, fate speaker said fiercely, that
she won't be too happy with Morrow Seer
for sending Squid away.
Maybe she trusts him, Starflight pointed
out.
Maybe she lets him do what he wants
without direct orders, in which case, we
could get in really big trouble for going
behind his back.
Or maybe she has no idea what he's up
to.
Fate speaker pointed out.
And maybe if we talk to her, she'll let
us both live, free the rain wings, stop
the experiments, and let the prophecy
happen however it's supposed to, without
Marosir ruining everyone's lives.
Starflight tilted his head at her.
That's a lot of hope piled onto a very
slim possibility.
It's worth a try, she insisted.
He thought for a moment.
His brain felt sluggish and confused.
He needed real food, and he needed sleep
and he really needed his friends.
Maybe we can ask for a private audience
tomorrow.
He suggested.
No, fate speaker said.
Maro Sier won't allow it.
We have to go find her ourselves.
She doesn't want to be found.
Starflight pointed out.
Maybe she keeps herself hidden for a
reason.
He hadn't come up with any good theories
about that yet.
Right.
And maybe we need to know what that
reason is, fate speaker said.
She had a point.
More knowledge would make them more
powerful.
If they found out something they could
use.
Oh, right, he said with a sigh.
We'll go look for her.
Fate speaker shook out her wings and
smiled at him.
Tonight, she said, tonight?
Starflight covered his head with his
aching wings.
Don't make me leave this bed before dawn
please.
This is important, Starflight.
Sleep now, and I'll wake you later.
Deal?
He sighed again.
Deal.
He felt her hop off the bed. listening to
her footsteps patter away.
His tired brain began spinning in
hypothetical circles.
What is the queen's secret?
Why doesn't she let herself be seen?
He thought of Queen Glacier, and how she
kept her sandwing ally Blaze, cozily
confined in a fortress built just for her
under instructions never to leave or do
anything risky.
What if Queen Battle Winners being
controlled by someone?
Like blazes?
What if staying hidden isn't her own
choice?
If something was wrong, if he could help
battle winner, maybe she could help him
in return.
Stop thinking and sleep.
He told himself.
He could see the thin trail of smoke from
where Flame sat, hunched and brooding
just like he was.
But despite the exhaustion that seemed to
weigh down every bone in his body, sleep
was a long time coming for both of them.
Starflight was surrounded by scrolls
stacks of scrolls, walls of scrolls as
high as 10 dragons, scrolls as far as he
could see in every direction.
His intense joy, so much to read.
Surely everything you could wish for had
to be in here.
All the answers to all his questions, ward
with deep, paralyzing anxiety.
How would he ever learn all this?
How could he possibly get through it all
before the test?
What was the test?
Something about wings of fire.
There had to be a scroll on wings of fire
in here.
Whoops, said a voice from the next aisle
as a pile of scrolls went tumbling
scattering all around Starflight's
talons.
Clay's face poked out of the wreckage, and
he grinned at Starflight.
Oh, hey, there you are.
Clay, be careful, Starflight said.
He started picking up scrolls and
restacking them as neatly as he could.
We need all this.
Do we?
Clay wrinkled his snout.
Does the prophecy say a bunch of scrolls
are coming to save the day?
Funny?
I don't remember that part.
Starflight gave him a look and picked up
the next scroll.
How to free the rain wing prisoners.
See?
he said, waving it at clay.
All the answers we need.
He unrolled it eagerly, only to find it
completely blank inside.
Smooth empty parchment stared back at him
indifferent to his disappointment.
Come on outside.
Clay said, we could use your help.
I can't.
I have to read all of these first.
Starflight started to spread his wings
knocked over another stack of scrolls and
turned in an agitated circle.
Had the walls of scrolls gotten taller?
He picked up another scroll.
Secrets of the night wings.
That's what I need, he muttered, rolling
it open, but it was blank too.
Clay was still waiting.
I can't help you until I know everything
Starflight told him.
I should stay in here.
It won't take long.
Soon I'll know a lot more than I do now.
But I can't go out there yet.
He pulled a shimmering golden scroll out
of a pile.
Surely something so beautiful had to have
something useful in it.
How to tell Sonny that you love her.
Starflight sighed.
He knew before he unrolled it.
Blank, blank, blank.
Starflight, Clay said.
Starflight, come on, hurry.
Starflight.
He's going somewhere.
Come on.
It wasn't Clay's voice anymore.
And someone was shaking his shoulder, and
Starflight blinked awake, muddled and
still sleepy.
Come on.
Fate speaker whispered again.
Flame just snuck out.
Let's follow him, quick.
Why?
Starflight mumbled, rubbing his eyes.
He won't know where the queen is.
But fate speaker was already hurrying to
the doorway.
He stretched, knowing he definitely had
not gotten enough sleep, and followed
her.
Flame's red tail was just disappearing
around a corner at the far end of the
hallway.
Fate speaker and Starflight scurried
quietly after him.
She didn't speak, so he kept silent as
well.
His dream had left him feeling disturbed
like he'd forgotten something really
important.
Someone he had to warn.
Soon Flame found a long staircase that
wound down, and down through the fortress
each level darker than the last, despite
the cold glowering in the walls.
He stopped a few times, listening, and
fate speaker and Starflight stopped too
ducking their heads and letting the
shadows envelop their black scales.
Finally they reached the bottom of the
staircase, and Flame chose one of the
tunnels, which seemed to lead directly
into the rock of the volcano.
Heat pulsed beneath their claws.
Starflight paused to touch the walls.
Worried that he was feeling rumbles of
movement from deep within the earth.
And then they came to the 1st cage.
It was empty.
The Starflight could guess what the bars
and the shackles were four.
This was the Nightwing Dungeon, where
Flame and Ogre had been imprisoned
overnight.
Most of the cages were empty, but in the
4th one was a skeletal, drab gray rain
wing, fast asleep.
Fate speaker and Starflight paused
outside her cage, looking in.
Starflight wondered why this rain wing
was kept separate from the others in the
caves outside.
What are you doing here?
Flame's accusing face appeared from the
shadows, making Starflight jump.
Following you?
Fate speaker said breezily.
What in the 3 moons are you up to?
None of your business.
Flame snapped.
Go away.
What if a guard catches you down here?
Starflight pointed out.
You'll be in much more trouble as a
skywing alone prowling the fortress than
if you're with 2 night wings.
The Red Dragonette considered that for a
moment.
Smoke rising from his nostrils.
Fine, he said ungraciously, do whatever
you want.
I don't care.
He turned and stomped away.
Fate speaker and Starflight exchanged a
glance and followed him.
The last cage in the hallway contained a
night wing.
This was where flames stopped, and
wrapped on the bars with one claw.
Not just any night wing, death bringer.
The assassin lifted his head and regarded
them.
His wings rose and fell as he breathed
and the cage seemed too small for him.
Hello, Skywing.
Glad to see you on the outside of the
cages this time.
What does it take to become an assassin?
Flame blurted.
I want to know the best way to kill
another dragon fast.
Deathbringer stood up and took a step
toward the bars.
You mean the best way to kill another
dragon. and not care, he said.
Flame hissed and lashed his tail.
You have to be doing it for really good
reason, said Deathbringer.
And you have to believe in that reason
completely.
You also should avoid talking to your
targets, in case you find out that
they're beautiful, sarcastic, and
fascinating, for instance.
Is that what happened to you?
Flame masked with a snort?
Is that why you're in here?
The silver scales under Deathbringers
wings glinted faintly in the torchlight
as he shrugged.
Perhaps.
But it's not a terrible thing to question
your orders, if you ask me.
Flame flicked his tail and fidgeted with
one of his wings.
What orders?
Fate speaker asked Flame and Starflight.
Who is this?
Can't one of your visions tell you that?
Flame asked Snidely.
This is Deathbringer, Starflight
explained.
He was sent to kill my friends, but
instead he let us go, and he saved glory
from the other night wings.
Three moons.
Keep your voice down.
Deathbringer said, looking nervous for
the 1st time.
I think I'm the only dragon down here
apart from Queen Splendor, but you never
know.
That's Queen Splendor?
Starflight ass.
The 1st rain wing captured by the tribe
said Deathbringer.
She's the one who accidentally scarred
vengeance.
The idea was, once we had their queen
they do whatever we wanted.
Little did we know that not only do they
have multiple queens.
Apparently they can go for months without
noticing one is missing either.
Yikes, said fate speaker.
Doesn't surprise me, Flame said.
That's all going to change, Starflight
said.
Glory will make sure of it.
Because of glory, Deathbringer asked.
Starflight jumped, had the other dragon
read his mind?
They stared at each other for a moment.
Yes, Starflight said finally.
The look on Deathbringer's face was so
obvious.
So real and sad, that Starflight had the
weird experience of being able to see
what his own expression must be every
time he thought of Sonny.
Whose glory?
Fate speaker asked.
That's a long story.
Starflight said.
I'm going back to bed.
Flame growled.
A small burst of fire curled out of his
snout as he pushed past fate speaker.
This is pointless.
Wait, Deathbringer said.
Just remember that you're your own
dragon.
You don't have to do what you're told.
You can at least ask questions.
So I can end up like you, Flame snapped.
Behind bars, soon to be dumped into a pit
of lava?
That does sound like great advice.
Death bringer shrugged.
A ghost of a smile crossed his face.
It could be worse.
Like, if you'd killed any of my friends
Starflight said, that would be worse.
Flame snorted again and slithered away up
the tunnel.
Starflight watched the flickers of fire
around his snout moving through the
shadows, past Splendor's cage, and back
to the stairs.
So, glory's all right.
Deathbringer said to Starflight.
She made it back.
Starflight nodded.
But she's pretty mad about all the
imprisoned rain wings.
He hesitated, thinking that he really
shouldn't trust this night wing, no
matter how much he'd helped them.
Of course she is, said Deathbringer, with
another half smile.
I never thought that was a good idea for
the record.
The niches for the coals down here were
rough.
Hacked out of the jagged rock walls
instead of neatly carved and chiseled
like the ones on the upper floors.
So the shadows all had sharp edges, like
talons trying to claw their way out of
the stone.
The heat was even worse than the blazing
sun in the kingdom of sand.
And Starflight's head was starting to
ache.
You don't?
Um, you don't seem fate speakers started
then trailed off.
Like a typical assassin.
Deathbringer finished for her.
Well, a lot of energy went into training
me.
But then I was sent to the continent, and
my guess when you're on your own for a
while.
You start thinking your own thoughts
instead of anyone else's.
I'm afraid that makes me quite a
disappointment to the queen.
Fate speaker grabbed the bars.
You've met a queen?
He tilted his head at her.
No, not face to face, of course.
She watches us through screens and speaks
through her daughter, greatness.
It's been like that as long as I've been
alive anyway.
Starflight's scales prickled.
What if the queen had screens like that
all over the fortress?
What if she was always watching her try
without any of them realizing she was
there?
He looked around uneasily, thinking that
the dungeon shadows could easily hide a
few holes in the walls.
We need to talk to her, fate speaker
said.
How can we find her?
I've spent all night searching the whole
Moon's begotten fortress, and I can't
figure out where she might be.
You have?
Starflight said, surprised.
While you were sleeping, she said.
I told you, I'm wide awake at night.
I wanted to get started.
I'm the same way.
Deathbringer said to her.
Listen, it's not safe to seek out the
queen.
She wouldn't like it.
We don't have to invade her magical
privacy or whatever, fate speaker said.
Does she have a throne room?
Somewhere we could talk through the wall
and probably find her?
Deathbringer hesitated.
This isn't a good idea.
I don't think she'll help you.
I think she will, fate speaker said.
She pressed her front talons to her
forehead dramatically.
I saw it.
In a vision.
Deathbringer gave her an extremely odd
look.
Really?
My visions are never wrong.
Fate speaker said breezily, although I
wish they'd warn me about more useful
things sometimes.
She glanced down at her claws, and
Starflight guessed she was thinking of
squid.
Well, Deathbringer said slowly.
If you really want to try the throne
room.
It's on the far side of the fortress from
here. 2 doors past the library for coming
from the council chamber.
But even if she's behind that screen in
the middle of the night, which she won't
be.
She won't speak to without greatness
there.
She doesn't have to speak, Fate speaker
said passionately, she has to listen.
Deathbringer met Starflight's eyes, and
then shrugged again.
Well, good luck, but hurry, it'll be dull
soon.
How can you tell?
Starflight asked.
There were no windows in the dungeon
nothing to mark the passage of time
nothing but pockmarked black rock
surrounded the prisoners.
I can sense it, Deathbringer said.
Spend a few months sleeping out in the
open, and you'll get the knock of it
too.
What were you doing on your own on the
continent for so long?
Starflight asked.
I had a list, Deathbringer said.
And regular meetings to receive new
orders.
Did you ever notice that whenever one
side appeared to be winning the war?
One of their top generals would
mysteriously die.
Not that I am taking credit for anything
of course.
I did notice that.
Starflight said.
At least, from what I could figure out
from the newest history scrolls.
But if that was you, well, it seemed to
happen to all 3 sides, so I thought it
had to be a coincidence.
Deathbringer spread his wings.
We only chose a side recently.
He paused.
I was not consulted in that choice.
You don't like blister either.
Starflight realized.
Starflight, we have to go.
Face speaker said, tugging on his tail.
I want to find a queen tonight, before a
Maro seer can do anything else awful.
Come on.
Starflight stepped back reluctantly.
He felt as if he still had so many
questions for Deathbringer, and this
might be the first night wing who would
actually give him real answers.
I'll come back, he promised, soon.
I'll, I'll see what I can do to help
you.
Don't get in trouble said Deathbringer.
I'll be all right.
Good luck.
He tipped his wings toward fate speaker.
Starflight wished he could do something.
You should try to save Deathbringer the
way the Nightwing had saved glory, both
from assassination and from the prison
caves.
He should do something brave, something
bold and kind and heroic, but he had no
idea how to even begin.
Instead, he followed fate speaker back
into the fortress, back through the
tunnels and hallways, in search of the
throne room, and the queen who might or
might not be there, who might or might
not listen, and who almost certainly
would not help them.
Tudors past the library.
Fate speaker muttered.
Something about a council chamber.
She paused in an intersection, looking
down both tunnels and pressing our claws
together.
I think I remember where the council
chamber is, Starflight said.
He'd been trying to create a map of the
fortress in his head every time they left
the dormitory.
That way, if I'm right.
He pointed.
Then we go this way, she said.
I think we'll pass the library this way.
Library.
Starflight echoed, finally hearing what
Deathbringer had said.
There's a library.
Fate speaker, have you seen it?
How many scrolls do they have?
Like a million, she said.
A million.
Starflight felt momentarily faint
thinking of a 1000000 scrolls he'd never
read.
It would be just like his dream.
That wasn't a real guess, fate speaker
said, stopping to give him an amused
grin.
I just meant lots, really.
I didn't try to count them.
Lots is exciting too, Starflight said.
He felt a little silly getting so excited
over scrolls, but there had never been
enough of them under the mountain.
He'd read the same ones over and over and
over again.
Something new, something with more
answers, more of the information he
needed.
That would be everything.
Here it is, fate speaker said.
Pausing at a tall, open archway.
Starflight peered inside, his heart
pounding.
The room was cavernous, even bigger than
the council chamber.
Instead of coals lying open in wall
niches, here the light came from fire
that was carefully trapped in metal
globes and kept away from the scrolls.
Square nooks were carved out of the wall
all the way up to the ceiling, and in
each square there were between 3 and 6
scrolls, neatly rolled and labeled and
organized, organized.
With a mark next to the square, and a
large scroll rolled out on a main table
as a catalog.
He could see how it worked in the 1st
glance, and his talons ached to rush
inside and start reading.
You are so cute.
Fate speaker said.
Look at your face.
Like someone just opened up a giant
treasure box and it's all for you.
That was exactly how Starflight felt
looking at all these scrolls.
He took a tentative step inside, and Fate
speaker immediately grabbed his tail.
Oh, no, you don't. she said.
We find a queen first.
You can come back and moon over scrolls
tomorrow.
If Maru Seer lets me.
Starflight said wistfully.
Fate speaker dragged him away from the
library and stopped 2 doors down in front
of a round stone room that was completely
empty, with no windows and no furniture
and only one niche for glowing coals.
The wall opposite the door was a strange
lattice of stone studded with diamond
shaped holes no bigger than ladybugs.
I did see this room, fate speaker said.
I just didn't guess it was the throne
room.
Shouldn't a throne room have a throne in
it, even if no one plans to sit on it?
Maybe there's a throne behind the screen
Starflight suggested.
Hmm, she said.
Still seems like it shouldn't get to be
called at throne room then.
She stalked up to the lattice wall and
pressed one eye to one of the holes.
Fate speaker, Starflight said, shocked.
We're not supposed to try and look at
her.
Don't panic, she said.
It's all dark back there anyway.
She tilted her head and tried another
hole lower down.
Maybe there's something glowing, but it
just looks like fire.
I can't see the queen.
Do you think she's there?
She rapped on the screen.
Hello, your majesty?
Silence from the wall.
Queen Battle Winner?
Fate speaker tried again.
We really need to talk to you.
It's us.
The dragonettes from the prophecy.
Whoa, the 2 night wing options.
Starflight amended.
Hello, fate speaker said.
Nothing.
Fate speaker knocked and kicked the wall
a few times, but there was no response.
That is so frustrating, she growled.
Your majesty?
I'm not impressed.
It is the middle of the night.
Starflight pointed out.
She's probably not even there.
She must sleep somewhere.
Fate speaker hunched your wings, then
sighed and nodded.
All right.
We'll sneak away from MaroCer and try
again tomorrow.
Starfly did not love the sound of that
plan, but he already knew better than to
try arguing with fate speaker.
They turned to go, but just then
Starflight heard a noise.
A noise like scraping coming from behind
the wall.
He looked at face speaker and saw that
she'd heard it too.
They both returned to the screen.
Your majesty?
Fate speaker said.
When there was still no answer, Starflight
said, if she's back there, she doesn't
want to talk to us.
Fate speaker folded her wings in close
and scowled.
Then we should make her see us.
She started pacing along the wall with a
screen.
There must be a door here somewhere.
She has to get in and out somehow, right?
Unless she always stays in the same room
Starflight said.
His mental map of the fortress started
clicking together.
I think, I think the room behind this
wall could also overlook the council
chamber.
Maybe that's where she lives.
So we just have to find a way into it
fate speaker said, charging into the
hallway.
Is that a good idea?
Starflight asked.
His claws caught on the rocks as he
hurried behind her.
I'm pretty sure she won't be pleased.
Too bad, fate speaker cried.
We're her subjects too.
She has to listen to us.
Clearly, fate speaker didn't know very
much about queens or tribes and how they
worked.
Perhaps the talons of Peace Cam was a
little more open to input from all
dragons.
Or perhaps fate speaker would have been
like this no matter where she was
raised.
She stopped abruptly, frowning and
tipping her head from side to side.
How do we get there?
She muttered to herself.
She closed her eyes and took a deep
breath.
Having a vision?
Starflight asked, recognizing the
expression on her face.
Trying to she said.
But all I can see is walls.
Let's try this way.
Starflight suggested.
They followed winding passages that seem
to be circling the council room, but he
couldn't find any doors that might lead
to the place where the queen had been
hidden.
But he did find one room with the door
open, and it was empty when he peered
inside.
It was a strange room too.
The space was dominated by a giant map on
the wall.
Pyria, but with more detail in it than
he'd ever seen on any map before.
Every inlet, every fjord was drawn with
scientific precision.
Even the rainforest sparkled with
information.
The location of the main rain wing
village, all the rivers and streams that
crisscrossed the jungle, and the 2
tunnels that led to the kingdom of sand
and the night wing island, each was
marked and carefully labeled.
Starflight noticed that the Sea Wings
Summer Palace was noted on there as
well.
In ink that looked darker and newer than
some of the other marks, and he wondered
whether the night wings had only learned
of its location when it burned.
The deep palace was not on there, still a
sea wing secret, apparently.
But strangest of all, the map was covered
with tiny squares that were each labeled
scavenger den.
There were 7 of them, from the outer
islands of the kingdom of the sea, to the
peninsula below the kingdom of sand.
There was even one among the snowy wastes
of the ice kingdom, and each one had a
careful, deliberate X slashed across it
in green ink.
What are they doing?
Starflight thought, staring at the map.
Why track scavengers?
What do the X's mean?
What's a scavenger den?
Fate speaker asked from behind him?
Have you ever seen a scavenger?
Starfly asked.
She shook her head.
There are these little creatures with
hardly any fur, and they run around on 2
legs, and they love to steal treasure
kind of like magpies or raccoons, but
bigger.
And sometimes they get pointy sticks, and
poke dragons with them, which means they
can't be very intelligent.
Oh, fate speaker said.
Right.
Like the scavenger who killed Queen Oasis
and started the whole war in the 1st
place.
Exactly, Starflight said.
He shivered, remembering the only ones
he'd ever encountered, the 2 who'd tried
to kill him in Scarlet's arena.
In his nightmares, they always stared at
him with big dragon like eyes, and even
though he found them terrifying.
He couldn't help thinking, they're in the
same situation I am.
They're just trying to survive this
arena.
So, these dens, that's where they live?
Fate speaker reached up and traced the
outline of one of the dens with her
claw.
I guess so, Starflight said.
I've never seen one.
I always imagined warns of tunnels.
The scrolls say they like to live in big
groups, like meerkats, but they try to
keep their dens hidden according to what
I've read.
They're safer from predators that way.
Predators like us, fate speaker said
cheerfully.
I have no idea why the Night Wings would
care about them.
Starflight said, scratching his head.
A theory was bubbling at the back of his
mind, but before he could put it together
Fate speaker slid her talons along to the
outer edge of the map and let out a
yelp.
Look, there's something behind here.
She unpinned one corner of the map and
lifted it up, and sure enough, there was
a small tunnel hidden behind it.
Let's go. she whispered, ducking into it
with no hesitation.
Starflight's heart was trying to clamber
up his throat and strangle him, but what
else could he do?
If this tunnel led where it looked like
it might, he couldn't leave fate speaker
to face Queen Battle winner alone.
If only tsunami were here, or clay.
They'd at least be some use in a fight
unlike him.
His claws shook as he lifted the corner
of the map, and slid into the dark tunnel
behind fate speaker.
I am having a vision.
Fate speaker whispered dramatically in
his ear, nearly making him leap out of
his scales.
Of us standing in front of Queen Battle
Winner, this is going to work.
You scared me half to death. he said
clutching his chest.
Sorry, she said, and even in the dark, he
could sense her grinning.
So, he whispered, as they started
creeping forward.
In your visions, there is a queen battle
winner.
She's alive?
She exists?
Of course.
Fate speaker said.
What?
Nothing, Starfly said.
It's just, I've been wondering, since no
one ever sees her, and apparently no one
even hears her accept greatness.
Well, if she were dead.
This would be a pretty clever plan is
all.
As long as greatness claims Battle winner
is alive, she can issue orders and do all
the things a queen might do, in Battle
winner's name, but no one can challenge
her to try to take the throne.
That is way sneaky, fate speaker said.
I would never have thought of that.
I could be wrong.
His nose bumped suddenly into stone.
He stood up on his back talons and poked
the low ceiling above their heads, then
breathed out a plume of fire.
The tunnel ended at a large boulder right
in front of them.
Fate speaker hissed, no way.
This has to be it.
Starflight gingerly felt around to the
back of the boulder and realized there
was empty space under his claws.
The tunnel keeps going only smaller, I
think, he said.
There was a hole in the wall, hidden by
the boulder, barely big enough for a
dragon to fit through.
He reached his talons inside, and guessed
that the hidden tunnel led up in the
right direction.
Ooh, fate speaker said, sniffing at the
darkness.
I foresee that this is going to be mad
scary.
You go first.
It felt like a volcano was about to
explode out of Starflight's chest.
Well, if anyone does catch us, they can't
kill both of us.
They need at least one of us alive.
He didn't find that thought very
reassuring as he climbed into the dark
tunnel and felt sharp black rocks digging
into his talons.
The only thing that was oddly comforting
was the sound of fate speaker clambering
behind him, close enough to step on his
tail a few times.
The tunnel sloped up and around in a kind
of spiral.
When a last twist suddenly left them
standing in an open cave.
They were both caught by surprise.
Starflight froze, and fate speaker
blundered into him.
This is it.
On one wall, the circle shape punctured
with holes, looking out over the council
chamber, on another wall, the screen that
faced the throne room, and then there was
a 3rd wall with only a few carefully
hidden eye holes for spying on something
or someone, or somewhere without being
noticed.
But no queen.
There were no dragons here, no signs of
life.
Where else could she be?
Or am I right?
Is she dead after all?
In the center of the cave was an enormous
cauldron full of lava, big enough for 2
morrow's ears.
It looked like a jagged black bowl that
had been yanked and pummeled out of the
volcanic stone.
Molten lava filled it to the brim
bubbling and spitting and gurgling
weirdly.
A few drops spattered over the side, and
Starflight took a cautious step back
remembering the stinging burn on his
foot.
The room was stiflingly hot, almost
painfully so.
Starflight slid around the cauldron
hugging the walls, to peer through the
secret eye holes across from the tunnel
entrance.
Fate speaker followed him
uncharacteristically quiet.
Starfly didn't recognize the room on the
other side of the 3rd wall, but he could
see a low table and the leftover bones of
prey were strewn around the floor.
I bet this is where the council members
eat, he said quietly to fate speaker.
It's a good time to spy on dragons, when
they might say anything, if they don't
realize she's watching.
He glanced at the other 2 screens and
shook his head.
Then again, it looks like she's not doing
much watching right now.
He leaned in to peer through at the
dining cave again.
Maybe you're right about fate speaker
started.
Then cut herself off for the cry of
terror and seized Starflight's shoulder
at the same time, clutching him so hard
he thought she might draw blood.
Ow, what?
He began, then turned and saw what she
saw.
A dragon was rising up out of the lava.
Starflight had been terrified plenty of
times since leaving the caves where he
grew up.
He thought nothing could ever be worse
than the moment Queen Scarlet walked in
with her guards, killed Dune, and took
all the dragonette's prisoner.
But then there was the moment he stood in
her arena. knowing that she intended for
him to be violently dead by the end of
the day.
That was followed by the moment Queen
Coral had them thrown in her prison.
Tsunamis plunge through the electric
eels.
The Sky Wing attack on the Summer
Palace.
Their frantic escape right through the
middle of a battle, and perhaps the
actual worst, when Sonny had disappeared
right in front of him in the rainforest
not to mention all the scary things he'd
faced since being abducted by the night
wings.
In fact, he'd spent most of the last few
weeks in a state of near constant
terror.
This was a whole other level, a level of
that's not scientifically possible.
And has it been under the lava this whole
time?
And that's not possible.
And now this is really it.
And there's no one to protect me, and I'm
definitely, absolutely 100% going to die
because that is a dragon who lives in
lava.
Its head and wings came first, and a
fountain of gold and molten lava, and
then a set of claws shot out, and
clutched the side of the cauldron.
The dragon shook itself, sending
splatters of lava flying.
Slowly the lava poured off her head
revealing a thick set neck, a battle
scarred snout, and black scales that
gleamed like polished ebony against the
orange yellow pool around her.
Starflight?
Starflight, Starflight, Fate speaker
whispered in a panicked rush, shaking his
arm violently.
Do something?
Like what?
he whispered back.
The tunnel was on the far side of the
cauldron.
They'd have to get past the dragon and
the lava she was dripping everywhere if
they wanted to run away, which was what
he really, really wanted to do.
The dragon in the lava leaned forward and
glared at them.
Buzzing white steam seemed to be rising
from her scales.
Her tongue flicked in and out as she
studied the 2 dragonettes, and Starflight
realized.
There was a glint of icy blue in the
depths of her dark eyes.
When she opened her mouth, he spotted 2
teeth that were the same shade of blue
looking more like icicles than regular
teeth.
Hoo.
She rasped suddenly.
Her voice was hard to hear, creaky, and
quiet, and rough, and eerie, like claws
scraping on ice several caves away.
No one?
Starflight stammered.
Please don't kill us.
Fate speaker squeaked.
Don't make me. said the lava dragon.
She hissed again.
Her claws flexing around the edge of the
cauldron.
How?
Did we find you?
Starflight filled in.
We were looking for the queen, queen
battle winner.
I, said the dragon.
Her eyes narrowed.
You.
We're, we're the dragonettes of the
prophecy, fate speakers said.
I'm fate speaker, and this is
Starflight.
Ah.
The queen sank lower in the lava.
Hmm.
Unimpressive.
How is this happening?
Starflight burst out.
Why aren't you dead?
The temperature you're immersed in, the
boiling point, the physical reaction of
lava and scales, I saw what happened to
vengeance.
You can't be swimming in lava.
It just isn't possible.
Even dragons born from blood red eggs
like clay, could probably only withstand
that kind of heat for a minute or two.
And as far as I know, night wings don't
have eggs like that anyway.
So, this can't be happening
scientifically speaking.
The queen let out a small, possibly
amused snort, blowing bubbles across the
surface of the lava.
Masterminds, son.
She rasped.
She studied him for a moment, then leaned
forward, opening her jaws as wide as they
would go.
For a moment.
Starflight thought she was about to lunge
out of the cauldron and bite their heads
off, but then he realized, from her odd
position, that she was actually holding
herself so he could look inside her
mouth.
His fear slowly started to fade as
curiosity took over, and he stepped
closer.
Starflight?
Fate speaker whispered anxiously.
This wasn't in any of my visions.
I'm really not sure about this.
Three moons, he said, his eyes widening.
Fate speaker, look.
You can see right down her throat.
And it's blue.
The walls of battle winner's throat were
lined with what looked like pale blue
froth, small swirling patterns that were
feathery or sharp, and all glinted
oddly.
What is it?
Starflight met Battle winner's eyes
again.
She snapped her mouth shut.
I...
The creak of her voice seemed to rattle
her to her wingtips.
She took a deep breath, tipped her whole
head in the lava, and emerged again.
Ice?
Starflight echoed.
His mind whirled into gear, trying to
solve this mystery.
Was this connected to the night wing
bacteria that killed their prey?
Or had she just swallowed a lot of ice to
combat the lava?
That made no sense.
Where would the dragons even get ice out
here on the island, where it was
perpetually too warm?
Queen Battle winner was watching him, as
if this was a test, and she had decided
to save her breath and see if he could
figure it out.
Her breath.
Ice wings.
Starflight burst out.
Their weapon.
The frost breath.
Battle winner nodded, her heavy shoulders
sliding up out of the lava and back down
again, her black tongue flicked in and
out again, and this time he saw that it
also had a layer of thin, shimmering
frost on it.
You got blasted by an ice wing, he said
slowly.
You must have been on the continent when
you ran into one.
Is that it?
And you fought, and it hit you.
But not only outside.
Maybe your mouth was open and it went
right in and down your throat to freeze
your insides.
Which means you should have been dead
within a day.
The queen flicked her wings back
scattering sizzling orange droplets
around.
Not so easy.
She growled.
To kill you, Starflight finished.
You made it back here.
And the lava.
The lava stops the effects of the
freezing.
Is that it?
Indeed.
The queen hissed again.
A balance.
But how?
Fate speaker said.
I mean, how did you know the lava
wouldn't just kill you right away?
Starflight could imagine it clearly.
Battle winner on the continent, perhaps
looking for a new home for the night
wings, running into an ice wing, and
nearly dying in battle, but she staggered
back through that long, awful flight to
the island, feeling colder and colder and
closer to death by the minute.
The fire that burned inside fire
breathing dragons, like night wings and
sky wings, would have been working
against the eyes to keep her alive for a
while, but it wouldn't be enough to save
her.
By the time she'd made it to the island
she would have been shivering violently
and feeling terribly sick as her stomach
and intestines began to freeze and fuse
together, spreading the icy plague out
from her organs toward her scales.
At that point, he could imagine she felt
so cold that diving into lava sounded
better than anything, even if it killed
her.
And maybe she expected it to.
It couldn't be worse than what she was
already feeling.
And instead, it saved her life.
Queen Battle Winner was alive now.
But the frost breath was still inside
her.
She could never leave the lava, or else
it would finish its work.
The rest was details, although he was
still curious about all of it, like who
knew her secret besides greatness, how
this room had been built, and the screens
put in, how the cauldron had been filled
with lava and prepared for her.
He wondered if she could still eat.
Or if she existed in kind of a suspended
state, right on the edge of death.
The queen was watching him closely
perhaps reading his mind as he put all
the pieces together.
He guessed that speaking was painful
scraping and cracking the ice in her
throat and mouth, and that was why she
did as little of it as she possibly
could.
I'm sorry, he said to her finally.
It seems like an awful thing.
What's happened to you?
Battle winner's head spikes flattened and
her snout lifted.
No pity, she snarled.
Revenge soon.
That sounded ominous, but worrying about
ice wings would have to wait.
Starflight reached out and took one of
fate speaker's talons in his.
We wanted to talk to you about the
prophecy, he said hesitantly.
We're afraid Morosier is being too cruel
and interfering too much.
The queen cut him off with a barking
laugh and then doubled over in pain
clutching her neck.
After a moment, she recovered enough to
glare at him.
Do as he says, she hissed.
The prophecy is everything.
But he sent squid away to die today.
Fate speaker pleaded, and he says he's
going to kill me or Starflight, and the
rain wing prisoners are being treated so
terribly.
Please, it doesn't have to be like this
does it?
Anything to...
Save the tribe.
Said the Queen.
She began to sink down into the lava.
Leave now.
Wait, please, cried fate speaker.
But lava was already closing over the
dark dragon's head.
She was gone.
They had failed.
Fate speaker and Starflight trudged back
to the dormitory in weary silence.
He hoped against hope that dawn was
farther away than Deathbringer had said
but he had a feeling Marosera would be
breathing angry heat into his face within
a horribly short span of time.
Poor squid.
Fate speaker said, pausing outside the
dormitory entrance.
I guess now we'll have to work with your
sea wing instead.
She sighed and headed back to her
sleeping spot.
Chills rippled through Starflight's
scales, like the clouds billowing outside
the skylight.
Tsunami.
That was who we had to warn.
Maru Seer had said, We have another sea
wing.
We just have to retrieve her from the
rainforest.
Had they gone after her already?
Had they tried?
Was she all right?
I can warn her, if it's not too late?
He hurried to his bed, and scrabbled
among the rocks until he found the tiny
hole where he'd stashed the dream
visitor.
This time he'd find someone in the
rainforest who would listen to him.
He had to.
He pulled the blanket over himself again
and cupped the jewel in his talons, then
pressed it to his head.
Tsunami.
Please be there.
As always, his 1st thought was of Sonny
and then the others flashed through his
head.
Tsunami, clay, glory, and then he was
falling.
Suddenly, through a bright, cloudless
blue sky.
He snapped his wings open, catching a
rising wind, and looked up.
Above him, glimmering in the sun, where 5
shapes.
He recognized Sonny immediately.
Her golden scales couldn't be mistaken
for anyone else's.
She was playing a looping game of chase
with clay.
Her quick agility outmaneuvering his
giant wings, both of them laughing.
Tsunami and glory circled them, calling
out suggestions.
Glory's wings were dark purple, and she
wore a small woven crown of iridescent
ruby red flowers, and there was
Starflight himself, flying along with the
others and smiling, like nothing could
ever be wrong.
He looked different here, bigger, kinder
warmer somehow.
In fact, they all did.
Tsunami and Glory rarely smiled so much
in real life.
Clay was almost never this fast or
graceful.
Whose dream is this?
He wondered, but it wasn't hard to
guess.
Sunny darted away from the others I could
dragonfly, and dropped toward him
beaming.
Two of you in one dream, she said
happily.
How weird is that?
She flitted around him, brushed her wings
against his. and then zipped back up to
tug on Clay's tail.
He couldn't bring himself to speak.
Being near her, it all came rushing
back.
How he'd loved her his whole life, and
how impossible the whole thing was, not
least because they were from different
tribes.
If he could make himself talk.
If he could warn her about tsunami, maybe
she would listen.
But the blue sky was abruptly swallowed
in darkness, and he was falling again
until he was surrounded by bubbles and
cool green light, underwater.
This must be tsunami's dream.
He waved his wings and spun slowly in the
water.
Sure enough, there she was, with her
claws wrapped around the neck of a
skeletal green dragon.
Gil, Starflight remembered, her father
the one she killed in the arena, before
she knew who he was.
This was a nightmare.
Her face was twisted in despair.
She'd never hear him like this.
Her little sister, Anemone, came swimming
up.
And seeing her, tsunami suddenly released
the older dragon, he fell back, his jaws
opening and closing pitifully.
Tsunami turned to anemone with her talons
outstretched, like she was apologizing.
But then Anemone's eyes narrowed, and she
lunged toward Gil, seizing his throat
herself.
Her tail smacked tsunami aside as her
talons sank into his neck.
Thick blood bubbled out staining the
water.
Tsunami grabbed anemone and tried to pull
her away.
But it was too late.
Starflight closed his eyes.
He understood what tsunami was worrying
about, that anemone would turn evil if
she used her anima's powers, and that
there was nothing tsunami could do to
save her.
Just one more reason why we have to stop
this war.
If there was no war, there would be no
one trying to force anemone into using
her powers.
She'd be safe.
Crunch, crunch, crunch, crunch.
Starflight opened his eyes again.
He was sitting in a vast dry cave, with
torches flickering along the walls.
The floor was nearly covered with all
kinds of prey, four, chickens, a cow
several ducks, 2 deer, and a hippo.
Some of them were still alive, wandering
around, bumping into walls, oblivious to
the 2 dragons in the cave with them.
The other dragon was Clay, who sat with
his tail curled around his back talons
happily munching on something charred.
Oh, hey, Starflight, he said, as if it
were perfectly natural for his friends to
suddenly pop into his dreams.
Clay!
Starfly cried.
You can see me.
Clay blinked a few times.
Should I not be able to see you?
This isn't just a dream, Starflight said
quickly.
I'm really here.
I mean, I'm really talking to you.
Of course you're really talking to me.
Clay said cheerfully.
Hungry?
There's a great pheasant around here
somewhere.
He looked around, scratching his head.
Oh, uh.
I think I already ate it.
Sorry.
Starflight was hungry, but he knew dream
food wouldn't do him any good.
Clay, listen to me.
I'm using a dream visitor.
I'm talking to you from the Nightwing
Kingdom.
Very cool, Clay said in an agreeable
voice.
How about a pig?
No, wait.
I ate that too.
I'm serious.
Starflight said, lashing his tail.
Don't you remember learning about dream
visitors?
There are these ancient sapphires that
were animus touched generations ago.
I found one, and I'm using it to visit
your dream and tell you something really
important.
Clay's forehead was scrunched in a
puzzled way.
Sure, Starflight.
I have dreams about you lecturing me all
the time.
That stopped Starflight for a moment.
You do?
Clay drew himself up and adopted a stuffy
scolding voice.
Weren't you listening?
Didn't you read the scrolls?
That was before the scalding?
Everyone knows that?
The scorching.
Starflight corrected automatically.
And I do not sound like that.
Sure, Clay said.
Anyway, Hippo?
Starflight stamped one foot.
Fine, but just listen.
Tsunami is in danger.
Morosier and the Night Wings are coming
after her.
Will you tell her that?
Look, Clay said delightedly.
My brothers and sisters.
He jumped up and hurried to the cave
entrance, where a small band of mud wings
were coming in.
The smallest dragonette jumped up to hug
Clay's big neck, and the largest one
inclined his head with a friendly smile.
Starflight hadn't met Clay's siblings, but
he'd heard about Clay's encounter with
them in the mudwing village.
They were all soldiers now in the great
war, fighting under Queen Moorhen on
Burns side, even though they weren't full
grown yet.
One of them had died in battle already.
More dragons we need to save.
He thought.
Anxiety and fear turning his scales
cold.
He wasn't sure Clay had really listened
to him.
He had to keep trying.
Glory, he thought, closing his eyes.
The sound of paper rustling let him know
that he was somewhere new, right before
he opened them again.
Glory sat at a low table in one of the
treetop huts in the rainforest, studying
a scroll.
In her own dream she wasn't wearing a
crown, and she looked more tired than
anything else.
Her scales were dark green and dappled
with light, matching the leaves around
her.
The furry shape of her sloth curled
around her neck.
Glory, Starflight said, his voice
breaking.
Would she listen to him?
He remembered what he'd heard Sonny say
the last time he'd used the dream
visitor.
If Glory thought he was a traitor, she
wouldn't have any reason to believe
anything, he said.
The new queen of the rain wings slowly
raised her head and met his eyes.
They stared at each other for a long
moment, her green eyes searching for
something in his face.
Wow, she said.
You found a dream visitor.
He exhaled.
Feeling relief flood through his scales.
Of course, she remembered learning about
them.
He'd always wished he could remember
things as easily as she did, instead of
having to study so hard all the time.
I didn't run off, he said in a rush.
The night wings took me.
I swear, glory, I would never have left
you all.
Morusir is, is testing me to see if I'm
worthy of the prophecy.
He has these other dragonettes that he
wants to use instead.
Only he needs a sea wing now, so tsunamis
in danger, and I had to warn you.
Stop, stop.
Glory said, rolling up her scroll and
leaning on the table.
Tell me everything.
So he did.
From the moment he was abducted through
the terrifying encounter with a night
wing queen.
At 1st he had that sinking sensation in
his stomach again, worrying that he was
betraying someone.
This time his tribe.
But then he thought of orchid, clamped to
the wall, the sky wings burning, and
squid flying slowly away to his death, and
he squashed any guilty felt.
He was sure now who deserved his
loyalty.
So, he finished, I'm worried about
tsunami, please tell her to be careful.
Glory laughed.
Oh, sure.
And you tell Clay to stop being hungry.
Starflight felt a smile trying to
struggle onto his face.
He really does dream about food, it turns
out, he said.
Like, lots and lots of food.
Oh, clay, glory said affectionately.
Well, apparently I dream about homework
even though there aren't any scrolls in
the rainforest.
She waved her talons at the dream table
in front of her, and then her face turned
serious again.
I'll talk to tsunami and put some guards
on her.
But I'm more worried about you.
We're not ready to attack yet, but if
you're in danger.
She carved a line in the table with one
of her claws.
I mean, it sounds like Morrow Seer might
kill you at any moment.
She looked out the window.
Where glimmers of rainbow wings were
visible in the trees around them.
But my tribe, they're not ready.
If I take them through today, they'll be
slaughtered.
I understand, Starflight said.
Glory was a queen now.
She had to think about protecting her
tribe as much as taking care of her
friends.
Every single bit of him wanted to yell
Forget the rain wings.
Please rescue me.
Come as soon as you can.
But it was too easy for him to imagine
everything glory was thinking.
All the information she had to take into
account. the pros and cons and best
battle strategies, and unacceptable
losses, and collateral damage.
All the things they'd studied as distant
theories, but never had to deal with
themselves.
So instead, he said, I'm all right.
I'll take care of myself until you get
here.
Glory looked back at him, tilting her
head to the side.
Warm pink suffused with purple spread
along the edges of her wings.
Starflight.
I think that might be the bravest thing
you've ever said.
He ducked his head, looking down at his
talons.
Well, he added, you know, don't take too
long.
She laughed again. and he felt a fierce
awful longing to be back with his friends
where, even if everything wasn't easy, At
least he felt like he meant something to
somebody, something more than a line in a
prophecy.
Her face went serious, and she toyed with
a corner of one of the scrolls between
her claws.
So, Death Bringer is in trouble for
helping me.
She said.
I'm sure he understood the risks when he
decided to set you free, Starflight
pointed out.
Hmm, Glory said skeptically.
I'm sure he thought he could charm his
way out of anything, idiot.
Well, he still might, Starflight said.
I don't think greatness wants to execute
him.
Glory shook herself.
Can you tell me anything else about the
night wings?
She asked.
Anything that might help us when we do
attack?
Like, do they have mind readers posted at
the tunnel entrance?
That's what I would do, so they could
sense anyone coming through, and maybe
even read our battle plans before we got
there.
I want to send in a camouflaged scout
just to see how many guards are in the
cave now, but that's why I haven't yet.
I don't dare.
I don't know, Starflight said.
I'm sorry.
I don't know anything useful about what
the Night Wings are doing.
I bet you know more than you think.
She said.
Can you tell me more about the fortress
or the layout of the island, or how we
might get there if we flew from the
continent instead of using the tunnel?
His heart sank.
You'd have to get through Mudwing and
Skywing territory first, he pointed out.
Before you could fly across the ocean to
the island, even if I could find a way to
describe the route.
And that would take weeks, he thought.
Weeks to travel the whole length of the
continent.
Can I survive for weeks on my own?
Yeah, it's probably not the safest plan
Glory said thoughtfully.
Starflight shifted his wings.
He felt chilly air against his scales, and
it wasn't coming from Glory's rainforest
dream.
I think I have to go, he said in a
panicked whisper.
It must almost be dawn.
All right, she said, standing up.
But come back tomorrow night if you can.
We can figure this out, Starflight.
It's going to be all right.
She stepped over the table and wrapped
her wings around him, which didn't work
very well since he wasn't really there
but somehow, it was still comforting.
See you soon.
He said.
Remember to watch out for tsunami.
Glory rolled her eyes.
At this point, I bet most of my tribe
would invite the night wings to abduct
her.
She's not the calmest general empirea, I
can tell you.
Starflight smiled, and lifted the dream
visitor to his forehead.
The rainforest disappeared.
He was back in the gloomy, dimly lit
night wing dormitory.
Had he heard a scrabble of claws right
before he'd opened his eyes?
Starflight glanced around, and realized
that his blankets had shifted, so he
wasn't as well hidden anymore.
Or someone moved them.
His talons, with a glowing sapphire
trapped between them were visible.
He pulled them back close to his chest
then leaned over the side of the bed to
tuck the jewel into its hiding spot.
Sleepy mutters indicated that the other
dragonettes were waking up.
But when he looked around the room, he
couldn't see anyone who looked awake
yet.
Did someone see the dream visitor?
Was someone spying on me?
Maybe I imagined it.
But he couldn't shake the uneasy feeling
that his secret might not be entirely
safe anymore.
Starflight lay curled on top of the
blanket, trying to calm his pounding
heart.
I've done what I had to do.
I warned glory.
Now I just have to wait until they rescue
me.
Survive until they get here.
Surely I can do that.
Oh, snarled Maro Seer from the doorway.
All the dragonettes in the dormitory
scramble to their feet, neck spikes
bristling.
The Maro Sears gaze was fixed on the
prophecy dragonettes, who came forward to
stand in front of him.
Starflight noticed that Flame kept his
head down, so he didn't have to meet the
Nightwing's eyes.
Yesterday was stupendously unimpressive.
Morosio growled.
Starflight glanced over his shoulder and
saw fierce teeth watching them with an
alert expression.
Next time you're in that kind of
situation.
The night wing went on.
I want to be sure you can fight your way
out of it, even without backup.
So, today, battle training.
Starflight's wings drooped.
Battle training was always his least
favorite thing.
Next time?
Viper snapped.
I'm not stupid enough to go through that
again.
Marosir hissed at her.
If you would like to take yourself back
to the Thailands of peace too, there's
the door.
He swept his wing toward the outside.
Viper hesitated, scowling, then ducked
her head and stopped arguing.
My throat hurts.
Flame said tomorrow seer, without looking
at him.
There's water in the trough down there.
Morris here waved at the other end of the
dormitory.
Catch up to us as fast as you can.
The others followed Maro Seer out to the
archway a few moments later, Flame caught
up, coughing and scratching his throat.
Maro Siera led them out to the prison
caves side of the mountain, where a few
rivers of lava flowed as swiftly as if
they'd just erupted yesterday.
The biggest was the one that ran in front
of the rain wing prison caves.
They landed a few lengths away from it
and Starflight spotted guards in every
cave mouth, bristling with armor and
spears, and alarm gongs.
I should remember to tell glory that to
night, he noted.
Looks like 2 guards for every rain wing
prisoner.
He saw Marosir and noticed the direction
of his gaze, and hurriedly filled his
mind with other thoughts.
Aren't we a little close to the lava?
Starflight asked, nodding at the golden
orange liquid fire that flowed from the
top of the mountain.
Everywhere on this island is close to
lava.
Marasira growled.
Let's begin with you two.
He flicked his tail at ochre and flame. to
Starflight's relief.
Try to kill each other, and I'll step in
when I think it's necessary.
Okre regarded flame dubiously.
Try to kill each other, he said.
With no breakfast?
Flame flexed his claws. fine by me.
Any rules?
There are no rules on the battlefield.
Morrow Sierra pointed out.
Flame immediately leaped at Ochre.
His claws slashed across the mudwing's
nose, leaving a bleeding gash, and then
he spun and kicked the mudwing in the
chest.
Oh!
Ogre roared, lunging at the sky wing.
They grappled on the dark, rocky ground
red and brown scales flashing and soon
smeared with the blood.
With a lava river so close.
There wasn't a lot of room to maneuver or
get out of the way.
At one point, a burst of fire from flame
nearly singed Starflight's wing, and
Ochre stepped on Viper's foot, earning a
ferocious hiss.
Here, Fate speaker grabbed Starflight and
tugged him up onto a tall boulder.
He sank his claws into gaps in the rocks
nervously eyeing the lava below, even
from up here, he could feel the heat
blasting along his scales.
His fear should have helped keep him
awake, but he was a little dizzy with
exhaustion, and the heat made him
drowsier.
He rubbed his eyes, wondering what would
happen if he fell asleep.
He guessed he'd either tumble right off
the boulder into the lava, or he'd wake
up in Marrow Sears talons, dangling over
the volcano.
He tried to pay attention to the moves
the 2 dragonets were using, but unlike
Clay and Tsunami, he could never figure
out what was going on in a fight like
this, everyone was moving too fast.
Oker suddenly burst into the air, winging
in a circle around flame, yelling, stop
it.
I want to stop.
Morris here snorted.
An opponent on the battlefield wouldn't
stop just because you asked them to.
He's bleeding pretty seriously.
Fate speaker pointed out.
Look at the cut on his wing.
Hmm.
Maru seer said, studying ochre.
All right, mud wing.
You're out, and you're in.
He seized fate speaker's shoulder and
threw her toward flame.
The Sky Wing didn't wait to be told
twice.
He jumped forward and sank his teeth into
her neck.
Yow!
Fate speaker shrieked.
She beat his head with her wings until he
let go and fell back, and then she clawed
the air in front of his face and darted
away.
Send me in too, Piper said tomorrow, Cyr.
I want to bite her.
I can definitely kill her.
Just give me a chance.
Go ahead and try.
Morris Seer said, tilting his head at the
small night wing.
Viper hissed with delight and rushed
forward with her tail raised, just like a
scorpion attacking.
Fate speaker yelped with dismay and shot
behind the boulder, appearing around the
other side as Viper chased her.
That's not fair, Starfly cried.
Fate speaker against both of them?
Battles are never fair in real life.
If she doesn't survive, well, we have
you.
Starflight clenched his talons, watching
the writhing shapes below him anxiously.
Viper and Flame were both so angry.
They hated being here, and he wouldn't be
surprised if they took it out on fate
speaker.
Flame shot a burst of fire at fate
speaker's snout.
She docked and rolled away, barely
escaping before Viper's poisonous tail
stabbed into the ground beside her.
If she's even scratched by Viper's tail
she could die.
Starflight said tomorrow, seer.
Maybe not right away, but the
infection...
He'd watch the wound blister had given to
webs for days as it got worse and worse.
Only a particular cactus from the kingdom
of sand could reverse the effects, and
there certainly wasn't any of it on this
island.
If you're so worried, jump in yourself
Morris here said, he was studying the
fight intently.
Skywing, has nobody ever told you how to
hold in your fire until it's at maximum
temperature, like this.
He shot a bolt of flames over their
heads.
By the moon's fate speaker.
Stop rolling around and use your claws.
Starflight, help me.
Fate speaker yelped.
He had no choice.
It was beyond terrifying to think of
facing Viper's tail and flames talons, but
he couldn't leave her to fight alone.
He knew what his friends would do if they
were here.
He closed his eyes, braced his legs, and
vaulted off the boulder onto flames
back.
The sky wing roared and twisted, sending
Starflight tumbling across the black
rocks, sharp stone edges slashed his
scales and the membranes of his wings.
He struggled up, bleeding from several
small cuts, and saw Viper knock fate
speaker to the ground, and loom over her
with her tail raised.
Marosir watched, his claws tapping
thoughtfully.
Stop!
Starfly cried, running at Viper.
Leave her alone.
This is your fault.
Viper hissed at fate speaker.
I could be back at camp with my parents
if it weren't for your stupid tribe.
Starflight smashed into Viper, just as
her tail jabbed down toward fate
speaker's neck.
A sharp smell of venom filled his nose
and his head collided with one of her
wings.
As she staggered back, her tail flew out
for balance and sliced neatly across
Flame's face.
Flame roared with agony, clawed
frantically at his snout, and slammed his
body forward into Viper's side.
The force of the blow sent her reeling
away.
Starflight watched in horror, as Viper
teetered on the edge, and then fell with
an ear splitting shriek right into the
lava river.
No, Morris here roared, leaping forward
but he wasn't reaching for Viper.
He seized Flame's head between his talons
and glared at the wound she had
inflicted.
Skywing.
Don't move.
Can you see?
Flame's only response was a keening
guttural sound of agony.
Viper.
Fate speaker cried.
Starflight followed her to the edge of
the river, but the sand wing had vanished
below the lava.
Viper!
Fate speaker screamed.
Through his horror, Starflight's brain
flashed him a message, and he whirled
around.
Ogre, you can go get her.
He yelled.
Maybe we can save her if you pull her out
right away.
Okre blinked, slow, painfully dull eyes
at him.
What in the 3 moons are you talking
about?
Your scales.
Starflight grabbed Okra's forearm and
tried to drag him toward the lava.
The mud wings sat down firmly, as heavy
as an entire fortress.
Ogre, please, you have fireproof scales.
You can go into the lava without getting
hurt.
You can find her and drag her out.
Please, please just try.
Fireproof scales?
Fate speaker said.
Because he was born from a red egg
Starfly said, like it says in the
prophecy, and that means fireproof scales
come on, why are you moving?
Let go of me.
Oka growled, planting all his limbs even
more solidly on the ground.
I have no idea if my egg was red or
whether my scales are fireproof, and I am
certainly not jumping into a pit of lava
to find out.
But Starflight protested.
But if you're in the prophecy, if you
could be the mud wing, then you must have
been born from a blood red egg just like
clay.
His heart wasn't in it anymore.
He turned to look back at the lava
knowing it was already too late.
Viper hadn't even come up to the surface
once.
She was gone.
Prophecy schmophasy, said Ogre.
I wasn't hatched on the brightest night
either.
So I'm not going to base any life or
death decisions on some old words in a
scroll.
Starflight pivoted it slowly to stare at
the mudwing.
You weren't hatched on the brightest
night?
he echoed.
Okre shrugged.
Neither was he.
We had the same hatching day.
A few weeks before the brightest night.
He nodded at Flame, who was curled on the
ground now, still making that horrible
sound of pain with his talons pressed to
his face.
Morosir stood over him, lashing his tail
furiously.
But, Starflight's words failed him.
Suddenly, everything seemed a lot clearer
and yet more confusing at the same time.
The alternate dragonettes weren't real.
They couldn't be the dragonettes in the
prophecy.
They were entirely false.
An illusion Marosir was trying to
create.
The giant night wing wasn't just
tinkering with fate.
He was trying to rewrite it entirely.
Fate speaker was crumpled in a ball by
the lava river, with her wings over her
head, weeping.
Viper and Squid were horrible to her from
what I saw.
Starflight thought.
Viper was trying to kill her just a
moment ago, and yet she's still
devastated by losing them.
Because she's not a heartless monster
like some dragons.
Get up.
Moro CR snarled at Flame.
You are not expendable.
The Red Dragonette's only response was a
low moan.
Tsunami would yell at Maru Seer.
Sonny.
Sonny would probably try to reason with
him.
Starflight's wings were shaking
uncontrollably.
But he made himself step in front of
Morosier.
Pretend your tsunami, or clay, or glory
or sunny.
What are you doing?
Starflight blurted.
Maro seer glare down at him.
Now is not a good time to annoy me.
These dragonettes can't be in the
prophecy, Starflight said.
They don't even have their right hatching
day.
Is there anything about them that does
fit?
Was Viper's egg found on its own in the
desert like Sunny's?
Was Flames Egg the largest in the Sky
Palace?
Why are you pretending they could fulfill
the prophecy when there's no way they can
be the right dragonettes?
You don't know what you're talking
about.
Maro seer bared his teeth.
Maybe, said Starflight, but I want to
know.
Everything I ever read.
All the scrolls written by Nightwings for
generations said, don't mess with fate.
Things will happen the way they're
foretold, and nobody can change that.
Prophecies aren't like treasure hoards
where you can mix and match which gems
you like, and trade out the ones you
don't.
I bet these dragonettes are dying because
you're trying to force them into a
destiny that's not meant for them.
You should leave us all alone and let
fate unfold the way it's supposed to.
He took a deep breath, astonished and
terrified at his audacity in talking
tomorrow, see her this way.
That's, that's what I think anyway.
You are an ignorant dragonette, said
Marusier, with no powers of your own, and
no one will ever listen to you.
Starflight felt as if he'd been stabbed
in the heart by a sandwing.
He stared up at Morrisier, unable to
breathe.
Did you think I wouldn't notice?
Morosier snarled?
It's obvious how useless you are.
You'll never be a true night wing.
You don't belong anywhere, least of all
here.
If he had read Starflight's mind.
And maybe he had.
He couldn't have found anything that
would have hurt Starflight more.
All his nightmares had centered around
this moment.
You are not a real night wing.
There is something wrong with you, and
you are a failure in every way.
Starflight took a trembling step back, and
felt fate speakers wings brush against
his.
He hadn't noticed her coming up behind
him.
Leave him alone, she said tomorrow, seer.
He's only telling you the truth about the
prophecy.
I have the wrong hatching day too, and
you know that.
I know a lot more about prophecies than
either of you.
Marusir snarled.
He shoved them aside and seized Flame's
forearm, yanking him up.
You're not allowed to die.
We're going to the healers.
The rest of you.
Stay out of my way, or you'll be joining
that sand wing.
He glared at Flame's face, which the Sky
Wing was still keeping hidden.
Starflight could see blood dripping
between the red dragon's claws.
Moro Sears shook his head and muttered.
Now we need that stunted sandwing too.
I'm going to.
Starfly didn't hear the rest.
As Maro Cyril launched himself into the
air, forcibly dragging flame along behind
him, but he'd hurt enough.
Sonny's in danger now too.
He had to use the dream visitor again as
soon as possible.
He turned and found fate speakers staring
at the lava, her wings drooping.
The red gold light of the river reflected
off her silver scales, making them glint
like rubies.
Well, said Ogre.
If no one cares what I'm doing, I'm going
to find some decent prey, if there is any
on this stupid island.
He backed away, as if waiting for one of
them to argue with him, then stamped
around and flew off.
Starflight gently put one of his wings
around fate's speaker.
Let's go back to the dormitory and rest
he said.
You haven't had any sleep, right?
How can I?
She started.
Then stopped herself.
Actually, sleeping sounds like the only
thing I could do right now, although I'm
afraid it'll be nothing but nightmares.
Starflight knew what she meant.
He helped her up, and they flew side by
side back to the fortress.
The dormitory was deserted.
Starflight guest, the other night wing
dragonettes were at class, presumably
learning something more useful then, how
to push your friend into some lava, or
your whole life is pointless.
Fate speaker collapsed onto one of the
stone hollows and closed her eyes.
You're lucky, she said, just as
Starflight was about to move away.
He hesitated.
I am?
I mean, if what Maro Seer said is true.
She opened her eyes again and looked at
him.
If you have no powers, I've always been
so excited about being a night wing.
I thought my powers must be the most
amazing thing, but clearly they're
totally useless.
If they couldn't even warn me about what
was going to happen to my friends.
She curled her wings and tail in
clothes.
All my visions were walruses, and welcome
home parties, and parents who were happy
to meet me.
So much for that.
Have you?
Starflight started.
I mean, do you know who your parents
are?
Do any of you?
Squid's dad is the leader of the talons
of peace, she said.
All of their parents are in the talons.
That's why Maru Seer picked us. them
because we were convenient.
She frowned.
I guess you are the only night wing
dragonette who hatched on the brightest
night.
My egg hatched a couple of months later.
Here, actually.
I have this really vague memory of fire
and rough scales rubbing my back.
I didn't remember that until I smelled
this place.
She paused for a moment, then sighed.
But Maru Sier took me to the talons when
I was still newly hatched.
I bet that was when they decided they
needed a backup plan, Starflight said.
Another set of dragonettes were close
enough, just in case they didn't like how
we turned out.
He shifted his wings, which they sure
don't.
I like how you turned out.
Fate speaker said softly.
Starflight took her front talons in his
and squeezed them.
You too, he said.
I like you much better than all the other
night wings I've met who were raised
properly.
I think we're actually lucky, in a way
that we didn't have to grow up here.
She nodded, but she still looked sad.
And I'm even luckier.
Growing up with dragonettes like my
friends.
The cruelty of their guardians had been
far outweighed by Clay's protective
caring, tsunami's fierce loyalty, glory's
insight, and humor, and Sonny's
everything about Sonny.
Feeling suddenly awkward and guilty.
He let go of fate speaker's talons.
You have the face you get when you're
missing your friends, she said.
He nodded, surprised that he was that
transparent.
Sometimes I think there might be no other
dragons like them in all of Pyria.
You're probably right.
She said with a sigh.
Well, there's fate speaker.
He touched her shoulder lightly.
Get some sleep.
She obediently closed her eyes, and he
moved back to his own side of the
dormitory, waiting until he was sure she
was asleep.
After a few moments, her breathing evened
out, and he reached for the hole where
he'd hidden the dream visitor.
Starflight?
Star Light was so startled, he nearly hit
the ceiling.
He whirled around and saw mastermind
standing in the doorway, staring
curiously around the room.
I haven't been back here in a while.
Mastermind said with a chuckle.
Marsier said this was where I'd probably
find you.
I'm in a bit of a conundrum, and I was
hoping you could help me.
Starflight edged toward the wall, trying
not to look at his hiding spot.
He didn't have time for a chat with his
sociopathic father.
He needed to contact Glory, or someone
who could tell her to put a guard on
Sonny.
But Mastermind held out one wing, and
Starflight realized that saying no wasn't
an option, not without a lot of very
convincing explanations.
Walk with me. insisted the older
Nightwing.
Have you seen our marvelous library?
Starflight reluctantly trailed after him
casting a longing glance back at his
bed.
Soon, sonny.
I'll make sure you're safe.
I promise.
Mastermind took a deep breath as they
stepped into the library.
There's something about the smell of
scrolls that always calms me, he said
waving one talent at the walls.
Me too.
Starflight admitted reluctantly.
He didn't want to believe he had anything
in common with his father.
It frightened him to think of how he
might have turned out, if he'd been
raised on the Nightwing Island.
Would Mastermind have taken him under his
wing?
Would Starflight be helping him torture
rain wings without any guilt or remorse?
Would he be inventing new, horrible
experiments to try on them?
Never thinking about how they were real
dragons he was harming?
He'd be eating rotting animals, and
studying with the other night wings and
arguing with fierce teeth, and he'd
believe, like the rest of them did, that
he was superior to all other dragons in
the world.
Except that Starflight had no powers.
So he'd have been an outcast eventually
even if he had grown up here.
He never would have belonged.
Not that he wanted to, but he didn't want
to be useless either.
Let's see, Mastermind said.
Studying the large catalog scroll on the
main table.
Each end of the scroll was rolled around
a spindle with a handle that could be
turned to navigate quickly through the
entire thing.
Mastermind spun the scroll rapidly
through to the M's, and paused on
medicinal records.
Hmm.
He tapped his claws on the list, then
turned to the niches in the wall.
Help me brainstorm, son.
The queen is very angry about what's
happened to the Sky Wing Dragonette.
I'm afraid he'll be dead by morning if we
don't find some way to combat the sand
wing poison, which is apparently my
responsibility for some reason, as if I'm
not already swamped trying to construct
then improve helmets for the entire night
wing tribe in 2 days, using only my
regretfully flawed prototype, which the
queen says will simply have to do for
now.
He paused for a breath, pulling scrolls
out and tucking them under one wing.
Did you say 2 days?
Starflight echoed, trying to sound
casual.
In case the council votes to attack
Mastermind answered with a snort, I try
to tell them that my research is still
incomplete, and I cannot guarantee that
any operation will go smoothly.
I'm pretty sure I can guarantee that it
won't.
Starflight thought, remembering the look
on glory's face.
Mastermind flicked his tail.
So, if you have any ideas, let's hear
them.
The problem is that naturally, I've never
studied sandwing venom, orders were to do
nothing to antagonize our ally.
But if it's anything like rain wing venom
there is nothing that counteracts its
effects.
Starflight blinked with surprise.
His father hadn't figured out that the
antidote to a rain wings venom was venom
from a blood relative.
It was kind of impressive that none of
the rain wing prisoners had revealed that
information.
Perhaps they were a little tougher and
smarter than Starflight had given them
credit for.
It was also interesting that the
Nightwing seemed to have so much
knowledge.
This entire library full of scrolls, and
yet they didn't know something as
essential as how to cure someone who'd
been stabbed by a sandwing.
Sunny had been able to get that
information out of Blaze in a matter of
minutes.
Perhaps that's one downside to staying
isolated.
Starflight thought.
They keep themselves separate to seem
more powerful, and yet they're cut off
from so much potential knowledge.
If they didn't feel superior to all other
dragons, maybe they'd be better at
listening to them, and maybe they'd learn
something new.
Mastermind had his nose in a scroll and
was muttering grimly.
Unlikely.
Try that on rain wing venom, and it
didn't work.
None of that nearby.
Doubtful.
Imagine how much we could know, if the
Nightwing studied the right things.
Like the medicinal properties of all the
rainforest plants, instead of torturing
dragons and obsessing over their secret
plan.
Starflight realized that the section they
were standing in was labeled for
Nightwing Eyes only.
He pulled out one of the scrolls at
Random, curious.
It turned out to be a treatise by 2
authors about the plan to take over the
rainforest.
One author argued in favor of killing all
the rain wings right away, while the
other author suggested that enslaving
them would be more useful in the long
term.
Feeling ill, Starflight shoved the scroll
back into its slot with so much force
that it wrinkled and nearly ripped in
half.
His father looked up at him.
Well, any thoughts?
He barreled on without waiting for a
response.
We may have to contact blister, although
I fear she'll want to trade information
this valuable for something of equal
worth to her, like the location of our
island.
Mastermind scratched his snout with a
worried frown.
Personally, I'm not sure it's advisable
to give her any power over us.
Definitely not, Starflight said.
I don't trust her.
Mastermind nodded.
Well, alliances aren't always about trust
I'm afraid.
He picked up another scroll and unrolled
it.
Star Light shifted uncomfortably.
Flexing his claws.
He knew the antidote to sandwing venom
but should he share it with mastermind?
On the one talent, it seemed dangerous to
hand the night wings any more secrets
than they already had, he could easily
imagine them abusing that information, by
attacking sand wings, for instance, with
no more fear of what their venom might do
or they might take all the cacti in the
desert and hoard it for themselves, so
only night wings would have the ability
to heal from a sand wing attack.
Or, from what he'd seen of Nightwing so
far, they'd probably come up with
something even more horrible that
Starflight would never be able to imagine
on his own.
But on the other talent, flame was
dying.
Without the cactus remedy, there was no
hope for him.
If Starflight told mastermind, there
might still be time for someone to fly to
the mainland and get what was needed to
save the sky wing.
Wasn't that the most important thing?
Starflight couldn't let him die.
His friends would choose to save flame no
matter the consequences, wouldn't they?
Sunny would.
Claywood.
Glory.
I'm not sure.
She might say to look at the bigger
picture instead.
And tsunami would say that this is
classic Starflight.
Dithering indecisively instead of doing
something.
So fine.
If I can't make my own decision, then do
what Sonny would do.
Starflight opened his mouth to tell
mastermind about the cure, but before he
could, 3 night wings encased in armor
came rushing into the library.
Mastermind!
one of them shouted.
You'll need it in the council chamber
immediately.
Starflight's father sprang to his feet
and started re shelving the scrolls with
fast, neat movements, carefully checking
their marks to make sure they went into
the right niches.
Why?
He asked the guard at the same time.
What's happened?
The extraction was a failure, said one of
the other night wings.
They tried to jump through and snatch her
while she was watching the tunnel, but
there must have been about 40 other
dragons hidden nearby, like they were
guarding her or something.
You should see what they did to the 3 we
sent through.
You say they, said the 3rd soldier.
But we all know most of the damage was
done by the sea wing herself.
Starflight tried to contain the joy
bursting under his scales.
He hoped none of these dragons could
sense it in his mind.
They had to be talking about tsunami.
She was safe.
At least for now.
His warning had helped.
The 1st guard shook his head.
I hope her majesty never sends me after
that dragonette.
I'd rather carve out my eyes than try to
grab her.
I heard she nearly bit wisdom's ear off
said the second.
The healers are there already.
But the queen wants you too.
The 3rd said to mastermind.
Hurry up.
Mastermind shelved the last scroll, and
hurried after the guards.
No one had told Starflight not to follow
them, so he did, hoping he'd learn
something before anyone noticed he was
there.
The council chamber echoed with the roars
of angry dragons.
Slumped by the entrance were 3 dragons
who certainly looked as if they'd run
into the sharper side of tsunami.
Claw marks were slashed along their wings
their tails looked bitten and dented, and
all of their snouts were bleeding.
Two other night wings were dabbing at
their wounds with bandages, ointment, and
disgusted expressions.
The longer we delay, the stronger they
get, shouted one of the council members.
They could attack at any moment.
We should block off the tunnel so they
can't come through, cried another.
It's the only way to be safe.
Say, full few days, perhaps.
Greatness interjected from her spot by
the hidden queen.
But what about the plan?
What about the future of this tribe?
We need that tunnel.
What we should do is attack right now
bellowed one of the old dragons on the
ceiling.
Without the sand wings.
Maro Sear's voice interjected.
Starflight realized that the giant night
wing was perched not far from greatness
but he didn't look in Starflight's
direction.
Perhaps he hadn't noticed him yet.
Starflight ducked behind Mastermind, and
the 3 guards, watching through the gaps
between their wings.
Our plan is proceeding as it's supposed
to.
Morris here insisted.
We've chosen our ally, and we have.
Well, we have most of the dragonettes of
the prophecy.
But we need time to get them ready and
marshal our forces for the attack.
The plan was supposed to give us 2 more
years.
Look at those soldiers.
Another night wing shouted, gesturing at
the wounded dragons by the door.
We don't have 2 years.
We don't have 2 days.
Your dragonettes are out of control.
They're making even the rain wings
dangerous, and they're threatening the
whole plan.
We need to go in now.
Take out the rain wings and contain the
dragonettes before they do any more
damage.
We're not ready, growled the dragon with
a missing tooth.
Mastermind said, we still don't know
enough about the rain wings.
We know how to kill them.
That's all we need to know.
But where are our extra weapons?
Where is our specially designed venom
proof armor?
Where are our helmets?
What has mastermind been doing for the
last 3 days?
It takes a bit more than 3 days to make
400 helmets.
Mastermind called from the doorway
bristling.
Suddenly, greatness rose to her full
height, and spread her wings.
Silence fell almost instantly around the
whole chamber.
Every dragon turned to face the screen
watching intently as she leaned in to
listen to the queen's instructions.
Starflight imagined the creaky rasp of
Battle Winner's voice echoing through the
Hidden Room.
Finally, greatness straightened up and
fixed the cavern full of dragons with a
black eyed glare.
Queen battle winner has made her decision
she said.
We cannot delay any longer.
She looked around, as if daring anyone to
argue back, but no one did.
We must go through undercover of darkness
kill all the rain wings, and take the
rainforest as planned.
Not a sound disturbed the terrifying
stillness of the cavern.
The night wings were frozen, listening.
Greatness took a deep breath.
Tonight, at midnight.
We attack.
Part three.
The truth.
Starflight raced through the empty
halls.
All the night wings in the fortress
seemed to be clustered around the council
chamber, trying to hear what was going on
once he'd fought his way out through the
crowd.
The passages were clear all the way back
to the dormitory.
I can warn them.
For once, I can really help.
I just have to get through to my
friends.
Fate speaker was still asleep.
Her wings tented over her, her side
rising and falling with deep breaths.
No one else was in the dormitory.
Starflight had seen most of the night
wing dragonettes in the crowd outside the
council chamber.
He bolted over to his bed and reached
into the hole where he'd hidden the dream
visitor.
Even in the middle of the day.
Someone will be asleep.
Maybe Kinkaju again.
Another rain wing if I have to.
Maybe Glory will be having her suntime.
I can get a message through to someone.
I have to, or they'll all be killed
tonight.
His claws closed on empty space.
Starflight's chest constricted, and he
crouched, scrabbling through all the
holes around his bed.
He flung the blanket aside and searched
from one end of the hollow to the other.
He checked the beds on either side, his
heart pounding faster and faster.
But there was no doubt.
The dream visitor was gone.
No, he whispered.
Scratching at the hiding spot again.
How could it be gone?
Someone must have seen him.
Someone had lifted the blanket last night
and realized what he had in his talons.
Someone had watched from the shadows and
taken it while he was away.
But who?
Could it be Marosier?
Surely the large dragon would have
punished Starfight severely if he'd
caught him with a dream visitor.
But maybe the punishment just hadn't
landed yet.
More important.
What do I do now?
Starflight?
He whirled around and realized that fate
speaker was awake and right behind him
watching with a confused expression.
She hopped up on the nearest bed and
peered into his face.
Why are you flapping around like a
scavenger with its head bitten off?
I lost something, Starflight said.
I mean, I left it right here, but it's
gone, and I really, really need it.
Did you see anyone over here today?
She shook her head.
Why?
What is it?
It's, he hesitated.
How much should he tell her?
She seemed like the only dragon he could
trust on this whole island, and he needed
help, but would she be willing to betray
her tribe?
Do you want to help the rain wings?
He asked.
The sad dragons?
she said blinking.
Of course I do.
Not just the prisoners here, he said.
The whole tribe is in danger.
The night wings are planning to invade
their rainforest through that tunnel I
told you about.
They're going to kill all their rain
wings, and they're doing it tonight.
Fate speaker's eyes widened.
Why?
She cried.
To steal the territory for their own, he
said.
That's the thing, fate speaker.
If you help me help the rain wings, it
means stopping the night wing plan.
It means leaving our own tribe stuck on
this island.
It's hard.
I can see how miserable they are here, but
I can't let them do this to the rain
wings.
Me neither.
Fate speaker said firmly.
Tell me what I can do.
Well, Starflight said, I have no idea.
She smacked him with one of her wings.
You can't get me all wild up and tell me
there's no plan?
We're going to warn the rain wings
right?
He turned back to his bed.
That's what I was trying to do, but the
dream visitor's missing and...
He turned back around and found her
halfway to the door.
Wait, fate speaker.
He leaped after her, caught her tail and
dragged her back toward him.
Where are you going?
She looked at him as if he were crazy.
To warn the rain wings, like we just
decided.
You mean, go to the rainforest?
He said.
His heart was hammering, and his legs
felt as though they could barely hold him
up, but something in his head was also
shouting, yes, yes, this is what you have
to do.
Go do it.
He started pacing.
We can't fly there.
It'll take too long.
We have to go through the tunnel, but
that's impossible.
There will be a 1000000 dragons guarding
it.
I'm not clay or tsunami.
I can't even fight one dragonette, let
alone a whole squadron of full grown
night wings.
But we have to try, fate speaker said.
So let's do it.
She pressed her front talons to her head
and smiled.
My vision says we shall succeed.
Let's charge the tunnel and see how far
we get.
Starflight winced.
Not to argue with your visions, but I can
tell you exactly how far we'll get, into
the cell next to Death Bringers, if we're
lucky, or tossed into the volcano, if
we're not.
She dropped her arms and looked
thoughtful for a minute.
So, what if I distract the guards and you
sneak through?
I have a vision that says that will
totally work.
He shook his head.
That's how Death Bringer got clay here.
I doubt they'll fall for that again.
We have to do this the smart way.
Maybe there's a way to trick them.
Who would be allowed through the tunnel?
He tapped his claws on the floor.
The soldiers who tried to grab tsunami
were allowed through.
Perhaps we could say the queen sent us to
kidnap Sonny.
Fate speaker looked down at herself
dubiously.
Right.
Two Dragonettes.
They won't believe that at all.
Starfly picked up a scroll from
Mindreader's bed and turned it nervously
between his talons.
So who else?
Or why else?
It was like a thunderbolt hitting him.
Ooh, you have an idea, fate speaker
said.
I do, Starflight said.
It's worth a try, but we need one more
dragon to make it work.
In her nighttime wanderings.
Fate speaker had found the healer's hall
and she was able to lead the way back
there without hesitation.
Star Light glanced in first.
As he'd hoped, the healers were still in
the council chamber with the soldiers
who'd fought tsunami.
The large room was mostly deserted.
A few dragons slept restlessly on the
narrow stone beds, most of them with lava
related injuries from the looks of it.
Two of the night wings bore recent rain
wing venom scars, and he realized those
must have been the ones Gloria attacked
during her escape.
They smelled slightly of poppies and
anise, and he guessed they were in some
kind of medicine induced stupor.
A fire blazed in a rough fireplace in the
center of the wall, and in the bed
closest to it was Flame, fast asleep.
There was a strip of cloth tied around
his head, but now Starflight could see a
little more of what Viper had
accidentally done to the sky wing.
A vicious slash ran from one corner of
his mouth, sideways and up across his
face, straight through the opposite eye.
It oozed blood, and something darker.
Oh, flame.
Fate speaker whispered, her voice
breaking.
It's not as bad as I thought, Starflight
whispered to her, trying to be
reassuring.
Viper only hit one of his eyes.
That means, hopefully, he'll still be
able to see out of the other one, so he
won't be completely blind.
If we can save him.
Fate speaker said.
Right.
He took a deep breath.
I wish we didn't have to wake him, she
whispered.
I'll do it.
He touched Flame's shoulder with one
wing.
Flame?
Flame, wake up.
It's important.
The sky wing blearily opened his good
eye.
He moaned at the side of them and closed
it again.
You have to come with us, fate speaker
said.
We know how to save you, Starflight added
but it'll only work if we go now.
Flame mumbled something that sounded like
why would you save me?
Because you're my friend, and it's the
right thing to do.
Fate speaker said. muttered Flame.
Starflight poked him in the side, because
we can use your tragic phase to get us
off this island.
There was a pause.
Flame lifted his head and squinted at
Starflight.
That sounds like a real reason, he said
in a stronger voice. although it still
had a blurry sound to it, and his head
wobbled like his brain was wrapped in
sheep's wool.
Starflight held out his wing, and their
red dragonette slowly slid off the bed
resting his weight on Starflight's
shoulder.
Fate speaker hurried ahead to the door
waved an all clear, and led the way to
the nearest balcony overlooking the
prison caves.
Starflight paused on the edge of the
balcony, looking out.
Down there was the black sand beach.
Down there was the tunnel to the
rainforest.
Down there was the gateway back to his
friends.
And down there, were an unknown number of
Nightwing soldiers who might take one
look at Starflight, Flame, and Fate
speaker, and send them to the dungeon for
life, or until the volcano erupted and
killed them anyway.
There's no time to be afraid, Starflight
told himself.
This is the only thing you can do, and
you must do it.
Supporting flame between them, Starflight
and fate speaker launched themselves into
the sky and flew toward the tunnel.
It wasn't hard to guess where the tunnel
to the rainforest was.
Once they reached the Black Sand Beach
the cluster of armed night wings gathered
in the entrance of a certain cave was a
fairly strong clue.
Be confident.
Starflight said to fate speaker, thinking
of tsunami bluffing the seawing
soldiers.
Act like we're doing exactly what we're
supposed to be doing.
Not a problem, fate speaker said.
I mean, we are.
Starflight guessed that she rarely had
trouble with her confidence.
Now he just had to follow his own advice
and he had to hope that the news hadn't
gotten here from the council chamber yet
that these guards wouldn't know about the
planned attack tonight.
They landed just inside the cave mouth.
Staggering forward under Flame's weight.
The red dragonette slid slowly to the
ground.
He looked groggy and close to fainting.
Stay with us.
Starflight said to him, squeezing one of
Flame's talons.
What is the meaning of this?
Growled the biggest night wing guard?
He paced forward to loom over them
glaring at flame in particular.
Here we go, Starfly thought.
Maybe all those games of pretend we used
to play will turn out to be useful after
all.
Didn't you get the message?
I knew that would happen, he said.
He wanted to sound bold and authoritative
like tsunami, but his voice sounded
higher and more anxious than he'd hoped.
So work with that.
It makes sense that I'd be anxious about
this plan.
If I can't be tsunami, then try to
convince them as Starfight, the nervous
know it all.
He pointed at Flame.
This is one of the dragonettes of the
prophecy.
As you can see, he was slashed by a
sandwing tail today.
Starflight peeled up the bandage a little
so the guards could see the oozing wound
underneath.
All of them let out a collective gasp of
horror and stepped back.
Starflight straightened and folded his
wings.
The venom is extremely deadly.
The queen has ordered us to take him
through to the rainforest, and from there
to the kingdom of sand to find a cure.
You, said the head guard skeptically.
I know.
I was nervous about the whole idea too
Starflight said, hoping they'd believe
that was why his talons were shaking.
But she said, I'm the only night wing who
won't be attacked or chased away by the
dragonettes in the rainforest.
They know me.
They'll think I'm on their side.
Can you imagine?
A night wing being friends with a sea
wing or a mud wing or a rain wing of all
creatures?
A few of the guards were nodding, but the
biggest one didn't look convinced.
I'll have to verify this order. the big
guard said, signaling one of the other
dragons forward.
Of course you do, Starflight said, letting
his panic spill into his voice a little.
I said this would happen.
She's going to be so angry, he said to
fate speaker.
Then turned back to the guard.
I told them you delay us by sending
someone back to the fortress.
I told them this Sky Wing would be dead
before we got through, but nobody listens
to me.
Her majesty said, you'd take one look at
him and understand the urgency, and that
I shouldn't worry.
He rung his claws together, but of course
I was right to worry.
I am always right about worrying.
Um, said the guard.
He was starting to look almost as nervous
as Starfight felt.
He's really that close to dead.
It's all right, Starflight said, rubbing
his head anxiously.
I do exactly the same thing in your
place.
She'll probably kill all of us, but what
else could you do?
He nodded at the messenger.
Go ahead.
You can tell her it doesn't really matter
since he'll be dead by the time you
return.
He nudged Flame with one toe.
The Skywing obligingly looked even more
like a dying fish.
But he can't die.
Fate speaker jumped in, as if she'd been
having this argument with Starflight the
whole way here.
He's the only sky wing we've got without
him?
No prophecy, no plan, no rainforest home
for our tribe.
The guards behind the leader were
starting to mutter, and crane their necks
to peer at flame.
But he has to check the order, Starflight
argued back.
What's he going to do?
Just let 2 night wing dragonettes wander
through the tunnel with a sky wing?
Why, we might, we might...
He paused, then looked at the guard.
What are you worried we'll do?
Well, I don't know, he said, shifting a
spear from talent to talon.
I'm just following protocol.
See?
Starflight said to fate speaker.
Protocol.
Flame wheezed in a dying gasp kind of
way.
We gotta let them through, chief. said
one of the guards.
The queen is right.
This dragonette is the only one who can
get into the rainforest.
That's where we grabbed him from.
He can get that sky wing to the cure.
No one else can.
Starflight gave her a grateful look that
was entirely heartfelt.
The head guard flexed his claws with an
uneasy expression.
No funny business, he said to Starflight
you fix that sky wing and come back.
We'll be back by nightfall, fate speaker
promised.
Maybe we'll even learn something about
what they're planning over there.
They'll probably tell this one
everything.
She jerked her head at Starflight.
He's got them wrapped around his tail
from what I hear.
Makes sense, said another guard.
Let him through. chorused 2 more.
Their leader glanced toward the fortress
again, and then finally, warily stepped
back out of their way.
Starflight heaved flame up, flopping the
dragonette's red wing over one of his own
shoulders, and then he and fate speaker
dragged him down the long corridor to the
back cave, where a dark hole in the wall
radiated the wrongness, the Starflight
remembered from the tunnels in the
rainforest.
The Nightwing guards stared at them as
they went past.
Starflight kept expecting one of them to
yell, it's a trick.
They're lying.
He forced himself to concentrate on their
story.
Flame needs the cure for Sandwing Venom.
We have to take him through to save him.
It had the advantage of being true, which
helped.
As they reached the hole, one of the
guards stepped forward suddenly, and
Starflight just barely managed to stop
himself from clenching away.
It turned out, she was reaching to help
them lift flame into the hole.
Starflight nodded to her, and then hopped
out to join the sky wing.
We did it, but we're not safe yet.
In the tunnel, there was just enough
space to fly.
Fate speaker went first, then flame at a
wobbly flap that felt excruciatingly slow
to Starflight, and they began the winding
trek back toward the rainforest.
The air grew warmer and wetter, and the
sounds of insects and monkeys chittering
began to reverberate off the walls.
Fate speaker twisted to glance back at
Starflight with a grin, but he couldn't
force his mouth into a smile, not yet, not
until he felt the jungle earth crumbling
between his claws.
Green sunlight shone up ahead of them.
Fate speaker twitched in a happy way, and
sped up without seeming to realize it.
She shot out into the rainforest several
lengths before flame.
Starflight heard her scream, and then the
scream abruptly cut off.
He shoved flame forcefully out of the
hole and burst out into a glorious warm
day.
Magenta pink flowers dripped from the
trees, and a number of silvery sloths
poked their heads through the leaves to
examine the newcomers.
A bird with long blue tail feathers
strutted by, eyeing him beadly.
Stop right there, a voice yelled.
Don't move, and put your talons on your
head and surrender, and claws where I can
see them.
Starflight wasn't sure which conflicting
order to follow.
He twisted rapidly in a circle and
spotted fate speaker lying next to the
stream, with an orange gold rain wing
sitting cheerfully on top of her, wrapping
vines around her snout.
Another rain wing materialized slowly in
front of him, her scales changing colors
so she no longer blended into the
background.
You're my prisoner, she cried.
Run for your life.
Mango.
You can't just yell things at random, said
a familiar voice.
Tsunami dropped down from one of the
branches, frowning.
Try to think about what comes out of your
Starflight.
She interrupted herself with a cry of
joy.
At the same time, another dragon cannoned
out of the foliage and crashed right into
Starflight, Starflight found himself
circled by strong brown wings as Clay
nearly flung him into the treetops with
delight.
You escaped.
Tsunami yelped.
Elbow and clay aside so she could wrap
Starfly in her own blue wings.
That's unbelievable.
How, how, how, how?
I'll tell you everything, but I have to
see glory right away, Starflight said.
He glanced around, hoping Sonny was also
concealed in the bushes, but she didn't
appear.
He turned to Flame, who had collapsed
unconscious.
And this sky wing needs the cactus we got
from the desert.
He's been slashed with a sand wing tail.
Oh, poor guy.
Clay said, crouching beside Flame's inert
form.
The mud wing gently lifted flames snout
and peered at the wound.
He waved to the trees and 6 more rain
wings popped into sight.
In minutes, they had produced a kind of
hammock net, which they tucked around
flame so they could carry him off toward
the village.
To the healers, as fast as you can.
Clay told them.
Glory told us everything you said in her
dream, which, by the way, is crazy
visiting a dragon's dreams, tsunami said
to Starflight, winding her tail around
his, well, except she didn't tell me
about the stealth rain wing bodyguards
she put on me.
That was pretty hilarious.
Everyone should suddenly have the air
turn into 7 bright purple dragons yelling
hysterically whenever she gets attacked.
Yeah, I wouldn't have minded something
like that.
Starflight said.
The sunlight felt as if it was melting
through his scales, chasing away all the
darkness that had started to gather
around his soul.
You scared the moonshine out of those
night wings.
It was amazing.
Tsunami beamed.
Who's that?
Clay asked, nodding at fate speaker.
She's my friend, Starflight said
realizing guiltily that she was still
gagged.
You can trust her.
Her name is Faith Speaker.
She's the alternate night wing.
I told glory about.
Tsunami signaled to the rain wing to let
her up, and fate speaker came bounding
over to them, unwrapping the vines from
her snout.
Hi, hi, this is the most beautiful place
I've ever seen, she said, as soon as she
could talk.
I've never even had a vision of somewhere
this pretty.
No wonder the Nightwings want to live
here.
She seized Clay's front talons and shook
them vigorously.
What's edible?
I haven't eaten in days.
You wouldn't believe how hungry I am.
Starflight felt his own empty stomach
twist as she chattered on, but it was
much more than food that was worrying
him.
War was coming to this peaceful
rainforest, no matter what anyone tried
to do to stop it.
After tonight, would it be so beautiful?
He remembered some of the awful things he
and his friends had seen since leaving
the caves.
The violence in the Sky Palace Arena, the
dead mud wings lying broken in the swamp
the panicked sea wings crushing one
another, as they tried to escape the fire
bombs when the Summer Palace was
attacked.
It was hard to imagine any of that here
hard to imagine anyone burning these
trees, or hurting these harmless, happy
go lucky dragons, but Starflight had seen
the cruelty of night wings, and he knew
how desperate they were for a new home.
He believed they'd do anything, no matter
how awful, to escape their volcanic
island.
Fate speaker was eating ravenously from
the pile of fruit clay had offered her
but Starflight didn't think he could
possibly eat until he felt that his
friends were safe.
Although, that might be never, he
realized ruefully.
I have to see glory right now.
He said to tsunami, the night wings are
planning to attack tonight.
She gasped, and the trees around her all
gasped at the same time.
Tsunami turned to frown at the apparently
empty branches.
I told you all you could go back to the
village.
She said.
I don't need a bodyguard.
I can take care of myself.
Nobody answered.
Tsunami side.
You've never seen instant loyalty like
these rain wings have for Queen Glory, she
said to Starflight.
Don't even try to convince them to
disobey her.
Never going to happen.
That's great, Starflight said, pleased.
At least one of us is fitting into her
tribe.
For her war strategy, yes, tsunami said.
For the size of her head, no.
She waved over the rain wing who had been
sitting on fate speaker.
Fate speaker eyed him warily, but his
tangerine orange face was cheerful and
extremely non-threatening.
Take these night wings to the queen
tsunami said.
Clay and I have to stay on guard here.
She explained to Starflight, especially
on a really sunny day like this, I'm
afraid rain wings have a tendency to fall
asleep all over the place.
Sure, Starflight said.
But if there's any battle planning, I
want to be involved.
Tsunami added fiercely.
Of course, Starflight said, spreading his
wings.
How long did they have until dark?
Would the night wings even wait until
midnight?
Once they realized that Starflight had
come through?
Surely Maro Seer would guess that
Starflight would warn his friends.
What if that spurred them to attack
sooner, they might invade at any moment?
They might even be on their way right
now.
He cast a worried look back at the hole.
Be careful, he said to tsunami.
I'm ready for them, she said.
Don't worry.
She curled her claws menacingly.
Starflight and fate speaker followed the
orange gold rain wing up into the
treetops, where there was even more
sunlight.
Fate speaker ducked as a flock of tiny
purple birds exploded past her head.
She kept twisting to watch the shimmering
azure butterflies that flitted by, and
once she startled a large spotted jungle
cat, so he nearly fell off the branch
where he was sleeping.
I can't get over how amazing this place
is, she said to Starflight.
The rain wing village is really cool
too.
He said.
It makes me feel sad for the night
wings.
Fate speaker tilted her head to catch
more sunlight on her snout.
I mean, what if they had grown up
somewhere like this?
Would they still be the way they are?
Or would they be happy and kind, like the
rain wings?
It's not their fault they hatched in such
a miserable place.
Maybe they could have been good.
Or at least better, if they'd lived
somewhere else.
Maybe, Starflight said.
In fact, probably.
But I think being a good dragon is about
the choices you make, no matter where you
are, or who raised you, or how.
The Night Wings chose to kidnap and
torture rain wings, that makes it hard
for me to feel sorry for them.
True, fate speaker said, and lapsed into
uncharacteristic silence for the rest of
the flight.
The orange rain wing led them to a tree
house that matched the one in the dream
Starflight had stepped into.
The walls were mostly open to the outside
letting sunshine and fresh air pour in
and Glory stood behind a wooden desk
although there were no scrolls in front
of her in real life. 3 small rain wings
were lined up before her in varying
shades of green, apparently relaying
reports from around the forest.
Glory saw Starflight coming and flared
her wings.
Starflight, she cried joyfully.
She jabbed her own forearm with one of
her claws.
I'm not dreaming.
You're really here.
He landed beside her.
We found a way out.
Fate speaker and I, this is fate speaker
because I had to come warn you, he said.
His eyes drifted to the trees around
them.
We're sunny.
Teaching a dragonette class how to read
or helping the healers with webs, I
think.
Glory said, waving her claws.
Warn me about what?
The night wings are planning to attack
you tonight at midnight.
Starflight said.
Maybe sooner, if they figure out where
I've gone and why.
Tonight?
Glory rubbed her front talons over her
head.
Go get me mangrove, she said to one of
the small rain wings, and you, find
grandeur.
The 2 of them nodded and flew off in a
hurry.
I have some ideas for defense.
Starflight started.
I hope one of those ideas is attack them
first, Glory said, because that's my
plan.
She glanced out the window at the
position of the sun in the sky.
I can get my army ready to fly in an
hour.
Sure, organizing rain wings, no problem.
It's only roughly as hard as getting a
100 butterflies to fly in a straight
line.
Starflight?
A glimmer of gold scales flashed in the
corner of his eye, and Starflight felt
his whole body fill with light as he
turned around and came face to face with
Sonny.
Sunny spread her warm golden wings and
Starflight fitted his own wings around
hers for a hug.
It always felt like exactly where he
should be, even if just for a moment.
I'm so glad you're all right, she said
stepping back and examining him for
injuries.
I was checking on webs, and then this sky
wing came in, of all things, and I was
showing the healers how to get the cactus
milk into his wound, when someone said 2
night wings brought him in, and I knew it
must be you, you know, I wanted to go
through and find you, but glory said no.
She wrinkled her snout at the new queen.
Glory was right.
It's too dangerous there, Starflight
said.
Oh, please, where have we been lately
that isn't dangerous, Sonny said.
All the more reason we should go rescue
you.
Although I wasn't really worried, because
of course you had to be fine so we could
fulfill the prophecy, right?
And look, you rescued yourself, which is
so impressive.
Starflight guessed that a grin on his own
face was probably a little goofy, but he
couldn't seem to squelch it.
And you are?
Fate speaker interjected, clearing her
throat and sidling so close to Starfly
that she bumped one of his wings.
I'm sunny, said the little sandwing.
She tilted her head at fate speaker.
Wow, your silver scales are so cool.
That one looks like a bracelet, like you
were born with your own treasure.
Fate speaker's wings relaxed a little.
She held out her talons to peer at the
anklet of star bright scales.
I never thought of it like that.
I was about to say your scales are a
great color.
All the sand wings I've met were sort of
pale and dusty looking.
I know, I'm weird.
Sonny said agreeably.
You're the alternate night wing, right?
Gloria said Starflight had lots of nice
things to say about you.
Fate speaker gave Starflight a delighted
look that made him unaccountably
nervous.
What was it like growing up in the talons
of peace camp.
So bizarre, fate speaker said, folding
her wings and leaning towards Sonny.
We were always moving so no one could
find us, and everyone talked about peas
but it seemed like all we were doing was
avoiding soldiers and waiting for the
prophecy to come true.
But it must have been amazing to live
with so many dragons from different
tribes, Sonny said.
Her eyes shining.
You'd get to see what really makes them
different.
And the ways they're all the same too.
I was thinking about that, fate speaker
said.
I was the only nightwing, so I was always
trying to figure out which other tribe I
was most like, but you could find
something in common with all of them
Sonny guessed.
Exactly.
All right, Gloria interrupted.
As strangely adorable as you 2 are, I
need you to either go away and discover
your twin souls somewhere else or focus
on battle planning with me.
Battle planning.
Fate Speaker and Sonny said
simultaneously.
Glory gave Starflight an odd, somewhat
amused look, and he shifted uncomfortably
although he wasn't sure why.
He liked that fate speaker and Sonny
liked each other, but it also made him
weirdly uneasy.
Luckily, at that moment, Mangrove arrived
with the elegant older dragon Starflight
had seen in Kinkachu's dream.
Let's take this meeting to the tunnel
Glory said, I need tsunamis and clays
input too.
She gathered her wings and soared off the
balcony into the trees.
Fate speaker and Sonny went next, talking
to each other as they flew.
Starflight followed, trying to keep his
mind on the impending attack.
Only a few minutes of sunshine and fresh
air, and he was already finding it hard
to believe what he'd gone through on the
Nightwing Island, or that an army of
angry dragons was preparing to destroy
all of this before the next sunrise.
Once they were all gathered, within sight
of the tunnel, but out of hearing
distance to be safe, Glory had Starflight
explain everything he'd heard in the
council chamber.
So at least some of them are afraid of us
she said when he'd finished.
I'd say most of them, Starflight said.
I mean, I think that's the whole reason
they've been kidnapping rain wings and
studying them, and why they haven't
attacked before.
They are terrified of your venom.
Glory showed her teeth and hissed.
They should be.
Yours, maybe, tsunami said, but the rest
of these dragons?
I really can't guarantee that any of them
will use it on another dragon, even in a
life or death situation.
They've been told their whole lives to
never, ever use it as a weapon.
I've done my best, but you tried changing
an entire tribal philosophy of life in 3
days.
I know, Glory said, starting to pace.
Which I'm not even sure we should, Sonny
interjected.
I like their philosophy.
I could do it.
Grandeur said.
Attack another dragon with my venom, I
mean, for the sake of my tribe, but I
agree that the others would have
trouble.
She glanced at Mangrove.
I'd try, he said.
For orchid.
She's really still alive.
He asked Starflight.
And waiting for you.
Fate speaker said.
Starflight told her you were looking for
her, and she said she'd survive until you
came.
A faint wave of pink rippled across
mangroves scales.
I'm worried about attacking first, Clay
said.
We'd have to come out the other end one
at a time.
If they're smart, they'll be waiting, and
then they can pick us off one by one.
But if we wait here and let them attack
we could do that to them instead.
We'd be in the stronger position.
I don't want them in my rainforest, Glory
snapped.
If they think they're losing, they'll set
the whole place on fire just to be
horrible.
Besides, we have to go there to rescue
the rain wings.
Even if we drive back their attack, we'd
still have to go through at some point
and we'll have wasted resources on our
defense.
No, we go to them first.
We just have to find a way to get
everyone past the guards at the
entrance.
I have an idea, Sonny said.
Changing your scales will help, Tsunami
said at the same time.
They won't see the rain wings coming
along the tunnel if you're all
camouflaged.
Then maybe we burst out and start
attacking and hope we've surprised them.
Doubtful, Starflight said.
Once Maru seer figures out I went through
they'll be on high alert to the tunnel
opening.
I think it's a good idea, said Sonny.
The one I have, I mean.
We need to choose the bravest rain wings
for the 1st wave, Glory said.
Tsunami, I want you to make a list for me
based on what you've noticed during
training.
Tsunami snorted.
A brave list might be asking a lot.
You can have a less sleepy than the
others list.
One does not speak to a queen that way of
her citizens.
Glory said with mock haughtiness, then
lapsed back into a regular voice.
Anyway, I think their rain wings will
surprise you.
I've been meeting them all one by one, as
fast as I can, and they're a lot more
complicated than they seem.
Doesn't anyone want to hear my idea?
Sonny asked.
I do, said Starflight.
But glory was already speaking to
Mangrove.
We have to make sure that we pair up
related rain wings in each squadron, so
there's always someone to counteract the
venom if there's an accident.
I know Sonny's been taking notes on that
so make sure we use her chart when we
form the squadrons.
With a stab of jealousy.
Starflight saw Sonny lean toward clay and
whisper in his ear.
Sometimes it seemed to him as though
Sonny and Clay were always together, like
the mud wing was the one she could trust
more than any other dragon.
He wished he could be that for her
instead, but he wasn't anything like clay
and the truth was, if he had to choose
someone to trust with his life, he'd pick
clay over himself as well.
I don't know how to prepare them to fight
Nightwing Fire, tsunami said, a little
hopelessly.
Most of these dragons have never even
seen fire.
They'll probably think it's shiny and
pretty and try to touch it.
Glory coiled her tail and stared at the
sky through the trees.
Starflight guessed from her expression
that she was thinking about how rain
wings were going to die.
There was no way to avoid it.
Becoming queen of an entire tribe, all of
a sudden was hard enough, but leading
dragons into battle, especially woefully
underprepared dragons, was something none
of the dragonettes knew anything about or
ever wanted to do.
We wanted to stop the war, not start a
whole new one.
Do the rain wings have any chance against
the armor clad, fiercely desperate
violently unhappy night wings?
Are we all going to die today?
We're only dragonettes?
We shouldn't be leading anyone to their
deaths.
But this is happening no matter what we
do.
We have no choice now.
I tried to draw a map of what I could
remember of the island, Glory said to
Starflight.
I want you to fill in as many details as
you can.
I guess we should have several dragons go
straight to the prison caves and try to
free the trapped rain wings.
Queen Splendor is inside the fortress
Starflight said. in the same dungeon as
Deathbringer.
Oh, Glory said, and several colors
shifted across her scales at once, so
another wing should go in there.
Maybe tsunami can lead that group.
Sleeping darts.
Clay suddenly yelled, making everyone
jump.
Glory stared at him.
What?
Those sleeping darts the rain wings used
to knock us out.
When we 1st got to the rainforest, Clay
said.
He nudged Sonny forward.
Sonny says, the healers have 100s of
them.
The rain wings use them all the time.
They play this game where they try to
sneak up on each other before getting
shot.
That's true, Mangrove said, lashing his
tail.
And we take turns patrolling so we can
shoot strange dragons who come into the
forest, like you 5, which is even more
fun.
Every rain wing already has a blow gun
Sonny said. arm them all with as many
sleeping darts as they can carry. and use
those instead of fighting.
That's it.
Glory flared her wings, turning dark
purple with lightning bolts of excited
gold all along her scales.
That's exactly how rain wings should
fight.
It was Sunny's idea, Clay said, nodding
down at the sand wing.
Maybe we can do this without casualties
Glory said animatedly.
Clay and Sonny.
You're in charge of arming all the rain
wings.
Get all the sleeping darts you can find.
Mangrove, grandeur.
It's time to tell the village.
Everyone who's willing to fight.
Meet by the stream here in one hour.
We're doing this before nightfall.
She turned to Starflight as the others
flew off.
Let's review the map.
Tell me everything you know.
Tsunami unrolled a giant leaf with a
sketchy map of the Nightwing Island
marked out on it in some kind of dark
fruit ink.
War is coming.
There's no time to be scared.
Starflight told himself as he leaned over
the map.
You can't be the most cowardly dragon on
Pyria right now.
Remember, you've read all the history
scrolls you could find about famous
battles.
Now use that knowledge.
It's time to prove that you really do
belong in this prophecy.
Two hours later, Queen Glory's army was
on the move.
The sun was just starting to sink below
the trees.
It wasn't dark here yet, but it would be
soon.
Starflight dug his claws into the mud by
the stream, trying to beat down his
terror.
The clearing bustled with activity, but
it was unsettling activity, because most
of the gathered dragons were essentially
invisible, carefully camouflaged against
the background.
Starflight kept being bumped and jostled
by what appeared to be empty air.
Tsunami was trying to make all the rain
wings face her and shut up, so she could
give them a rousing battle speech.
The fact that this was proving difficult
did not bode well for the overall attack
Starfly thought anxiously.
Starflight, Glory said, materializing
beside him.
Her scales shimmered from dark green to a
sort of worried looking pale blue and
back.
Are you all right?
I guess, Starflight said.
He shifted from one foot to another.
You know, nervous.
Do you want to stay here?
She asked him quietly.
I'd understand if you do.
No, Starflight said.
I mean, I shouldn't.
I can't.
He glanced at Sonny, who was sorting
piles of sleeping darts into little bags
that could go over the rain wings necks.
She had none of the weapons other dragons
had, no venom, no camouflage, no
fireproof scales like clay, not even the
poisonous tail barb a sand wing should
have.
He'd never let her go off to a battle
without him.
Stay behind while his friends threw
themselves into danger.
How could she ever love him if he made
that choice?
I promise, I won't be scared.
It's normal to be scared, Glory said.
I'm scared.
You'd have to be crazy not to be.
Well, crazy or tsunami, which is
basically the same thing.
You just have to push that aside and do
what you have to anyway.
But I meant, do you want to stay here
because we're going to fight your tribe?
If it's too much to ask, I understand if
you want to sit this one out.
They are not my tribe.
Starflight said.
You are.
You and Sonny and Tsunami and Clay.
Ah, you big sap, she said, but her
wingtips went all rose colored, and he
knew glory felt the same way, even if
she'd never say it out loud.
All right, she said, punching his
shoulder.
A rare gesture of physical affection from
her.
Let's go change the world.
She bounded to the tunnel opening and
summoned the 1st wave of rain wings with
a flick of her tail.
They huddled listening to her orders.
Star Light looked around at Sonny again.
I might die today.
What if she never knows?
What if I die without ever telling her
how I feel?
He lifted his face toward the setting
sun.
He'd bluffed the night wing guards.
He'd escaped from the Nightwing Island.
Surely he could say 3 words to one
dragon.
When he looked down again.
Sonny was right in front of him.
His heart seized, as though someone had
wrapped fierce talons around it.
We're going to be all right, she told him
shaking out her wings.
Just think of the prophecy.
We have to be alive to stop the war
right?
So we can't die today.
Isn't that comforting?
I wish I had your optimism, he said.
It's not optimism, she objected.
It's faith.
There's a reason we're here.
What we do today is part of it, but
there's more too, and we have to survive
to make it all happen.
Her smile made him feel as if lightning
were crackling under his scales.
Sunny, he said hesitantly.
There's something, I mean, something I've
wanted to tell you.
For a long time.
I'm listening, she said, tilting her
head.
Across the clearing, glory was flaring
her wings and waiting for silence.
It was now, or possibly never, depending
on what happened today.
I love you, he blurted.
Sonny blinked. and then blinked a few
more times.
I, I love you too, Starflight.
No, he said.
I mean, I mean, you're all I think
about.
And I want to be near you, and it hurts
when I'm not.
And everything I do, I think, what would
Sonny want me to do?
And I think you're the only dragon who
sees me the whole way I am and likes me
anyway?
He thought uncomfortably of fate speaker
and spotted her at the same time, across
the clearing near glory, watching the
rain wing queen with her eyes wide and
her head upturned, but his feelings for
her and his feelings for Sonny.
Well, they couldn't be the same.
And I had to tell you, he hurried on, in
case something happens to either one of
us today, although if anything happens to
you, I don't know how I'd be able to
breathe or think or do anything ever
again.
Oh my gosh, Starflight, stop, Sonny said
in a rush.
This, right now, how can I say anything?
let alone the right thing when we're, when
everything, She spread her wings
helplessly, indicating the mob of rain
wings around them.
It's all right, Starflight said, and
realized that he meant it.
Don't say anything.
You don't have to.
I just wanted you to know.
Just in case.
She wrinkled her forehead, as if that
didn't seem right to her, but he twined
his tail around hers, and looked down at
their talons sinking into the riverbank.
Just promise me you'll be safe, he said.
I hardly get to do anything in this
battle, she said fiercely.
You promise me you'll be safe.
He opened and closed his mouth, wishing
he could promise that, and mean it.
Exactly, she said.
So stop talking like a scroll and just
tell me you'll see me soon.
Okay?
I'll see you soon, he said.
And for a moment, her certainty made him
believe it too.
Good luck.
Kick a night wing for me, she said, as
Starflight stepped away, and then she
pulled him back for a quick hug, and a
moment later, he found himself walking
over to glory, his mind a daze.
I did it.
I told her.
And the world didn't collapse.
The queen of the rain wings flared her
wings one more time and the clearing
finally fell silent.
You know I don't like giving speeches
Glory said.
So I'll just say this.
We're going to save our fellow rain wings
and we're going to make this rainforest
safe, and we're going to do it like real
rain wings.
And by the 3 moons.
Try not to talk or sneeze or fall asleep
in the tunnel on the way there.
All right?
She turned to the dragon standing next to
her.
It took Starflight a moment to recognize
Glory's brother, Jambu.
He wasn't his usual vibrant raspberry
color.
But a rippling, shadowy black that would
blend in well with a tunnel walls.
He was apparently one of the best shots
with a blowgun, and he'd volunteered to
be the 1st one through the hole.
Starflight wasn't sure if that was
bravery, or just not knowing what he was
getting himself into, but right now, it
amounted to the same thing.
Jamboo hopped up to the hole and slid
in.
Glory followed immediately behind him, and
then Mangrove, Liana, grandeur, and 3
other rain wings armed with blow guns.
According to the plan, Starflight and
Fate speaker were next.
So that once the guards were knocked out
they could lead the rain wings to the
prison caves and the fortress.
He took a deep breath and looked back
hoping to catch Sonny's eye.
She was watching him, her scales glowing
in the fading sunlight.
I can do this.
Starflight clambered into the hole, and
almost immediately fate speaker followed
nearly stepping on his tail.
Neither of them said anything, but he
felt a little safer knowing she was at
his back.
It was stifling in the tunnel, and eerily
quiet.
The rain wings ahead of him were
stealthier than he'd have expected.
He wasn't sure how far ahead they were
exactly.
Even with his excellent night vision.
Starflight couldn't make out the
difference between shadows and here.
The tunnel tilted down, and he crept
along as fast as he dared, keeping his
wings carefully folded to hide the silver
scales.
Ahead of him, he heard a quiet, and then
another. and then 7 more in rapid
succession.
Sleeping darts fired from blow guns
straight out of the shadows, hopefully
knocking out all the guards by the hole
before any of them noticed and sounded
the alarm.
Next, Starfly heard a muffled thump, as
one rain wing after another jumped into
the cave, and then he saw the flicker of
firelight.
A moment later, he climbed out of the
tunnel and felt the warm rocks scraping
below his scales.
Nine Nightwing guards were lying around
the cave, each looking as if he or she
had just fallen asleep all of a sudden.
Their chests rose and fell peacefully.
Their spears rested harmlessly on the
ground nearby.
Glory turned to Mangrove and pointed at
the spears.
She made some kind of signal Starfly
didn't follow, but Mangrove apparently
did.
He started gathering all the weapons in
the cave, and passed them to the dragons
still coming through the tunnel.
They were handed back talon over talon
until they were safely stashed in the
rainforest, far away from night wing
claws.
The night wings are still dangerous.
We can't take away their talents, or
teeth, or fire, but one less weapon in a
night wing's claws can't hurt.
Jambu and grandeur had already crept
ahead.
If he strained his ears, Starfly could
hear the, of the blow guns taking out the
guards by the cave entrance, how long was
this going to work?
How many night wings could they send to
sleep before somebody noticed?
And once someone sounded the alarm?
How soon before rain wings started
dying?
All clear.
Grandeur's voice whispered along the
tunnel, like leaves rustling.
Glory's scales had shifted to gray and
red and black to match the cave.
Starflight couldn't see her, but he felt
her wings lightly brush his.
It was his turn to lead the way.
He glanced back at the hole that led to
the rainforest.
Tsunami, and Clay, and Sunny, were
supposed to stay out of sight during the
1st wave.
If anyone spotted blue or brown or gold
scales on this island, They'd know the
tunnel had been breached, and the night
wings would be on them all immediately.
So they were to stay hidden until the
stealth campaign turned into a real
battle.
On the one talon, Starflight was relieved
that he didn't have to worry about Sonny
but on the other, he'd feel a lot better
if Clay and tsunami were leading the
charge instead of him.
But this is the smart way to do it.
The only way to do it.
He padded down the tunnel with fate
speaker beside him, stepping over the
slumbering night wing guards, he could
hear the sound of the ocean waves
crashing on the black sand below
outside.
The sky was even more gray and ominous
than before, with grim, lowering clouds
that flickered with lightning, all lit by
the red glow from the volcano.
After the bright warmth of the rainforest
the island air seemed even darker and
smokier.
As Starflight stepped out onto the cave
ledge.
He felt the ground tremble beneath his
talons, then stop.
That's unsettling, he thought.
What a nightmare.
Grandeur's voice whispered behind him.
It's worse than I expected, said Jamboo.
How can anyone live here?
You carry this, Glory said, handing
Starflight one of the guards' spears.
We might need it, and it'll look less
weird in your claws.
If I hold it, it'll look like it's just
flying around through the air by itself.
Starflight knotted, although the weight
of the spear felt extremely strange in
his talons.
It was more likely that he'd accidentally
poke his own eye out than that he'd be
able to use this to fight.
He tried to hold it as far away from
himself as possible as he lifted up into
the sky.
Take us to the prison caves first.
Glory's voice said from the air beside
him.
Once Mangrove and the others are set up
to free the prisoners, you and I can head
for the fortress.
You, Starflight said.
It was really odd not being able to see
her.
He felt as if he were arguing with the
air.
That's the most dangerous part, as the
queen, shouldn't you keep yourself safe?
You can send someone else for splendor.
He tilted his wings to soar toward the
prison caves, and the lava river.
He could feel air currents shifting
around him as several invisible dragons
flew alongside.
He wasn't sure how many rain wings were
following him, but he hoped none of the
night wings would hear the wing beats and
get suspicious.
There were very few night wings in
sight.
One or 2 on the balconies of the fortress
plus the guards in the cave entrances
below.
Starflight guessed that the rest were
assembling in preparation for their
planned attack tonight.
I'm not going to be the kind of queen who
sends other dragons into danger that I'm
not willing to face myself, Glory said.
And even if I could send someone for
splendor, I can't send anyone else to
face battle winner.
Starflight sucked in a surprised breath.
Battle winner?
he said.
Is that a good idea?
Weren't you the one who suggested
diplomacy?
Glory said, and he could hear amusement
in her voice.
Yes, but that was before I knew anything
about the night wings.
Rescuing the prisoners is the top
priority, she went on.
But if I can threaten her somehow.
Maybe if I tell her I'll expose her
secret.
Perhaps I can get her to leave us in the
rainforest alone from now on.
I doubt it, fate speaker said.
The Night Wings really want your
rainforest.
Well, too bad.
Glory snapped.
Starflight said.
They were approaching the 1st prison
cave.
He dipped his head toward it and fell to
whoosh of wind as one of the rain wings
dove past him.
A moment later, the 2 guards in the cave
entrance both reached for their necks
looking confused, and then, in slow
motion, they crumpled into slumbering
heaps.
We're lucky the caves line the river
Starflight said, circling around in the
sky.
The guards at each entrance can't see any
of the others get knocked out.
He saw the guards in the next cave
collapse to the ground, and then the next
and the next.
The rain wings were fanning out.
Following instructions Glory had given
them before leaving the rainforest.
He saw the shimmer of scales and teeth
here and there as the rain wings landed
in pairs, shifted color, and darted into
the prison caves.
You said you saw orchid in one of these
caves.
Glory said to fate speaker.
Do you remember which one?
Fate speaker nodded and twisted into a
dive, aiming for one of the caves closest
to the fortress.
As they approached, its 2 guards looked
up.
Although all they could see were 2
Nightwing Dragonettes, one of them
frowned a little, as if he sensed
something was amiss.
Starflight's stomach lurched as the guard
reached for the gong that would summon
the rest of the tribe.
Then the air beside Starflight seer went
zit, zit.
And the 2 guards wobbled and went down.
That was close, Starflight said.
But after a moment, he realized he really
was talking to empty air.
Below him, the 2 guards were dragged
aside, and as he landed, he heard the
thump of talons hurrying to the back of
the cave.
I want to see this, fate speaker
whispered, darting inside.
Starflight followed just in time to see
Mangrove appear in front of Orchid, his
gray and black scales shifting all at
once to a joyful pink, shot through with
worried green.
Orchid let out a cry of joy that was
muffled by the iron muzzle around her
jaws.
She reached toward mangrove, and he
leaped for her, wrapping his wings all
the way around her and twining his tail
with hers.
I'm here.
He said.
I wouldn't give up.
I'd never give up on you.
She couldn't speak, but the rose colors
of orchids, scales said everything.
Let's get her out of here as fast as we
can, Glory said.
If they're all chained to the wall like
this, we have extra work to do.
Starflight, give me the spear.
Starflight held the spear out, and it was
whisked away from him.
A glory shaped shadow approached orchid
and carefully stuck the points of the
spear into the lock on the mouthband.
Liana, grandeur.
Are you paying attention?
Glory asked.
Yes.
Two voices said from the air.
Starflight jumped.
He hadn't realized the other 2 rain wings
were with them.
This is how you undo the locks.
Glory said, twisting the spear.
The muzzle fell off of a clank, and Glory
set to work on the chains that bound
orchid to the wall.
I was afraid.
You wouldn't care where I was.
Orchid said to Mangrove.
I thought you'd move on and find someone
else.
Never.
Never, never.
Mangrove said fiercely.
Do you feel the earth shaking or get
asked?
I think that's me.
Mangrove said, holding out his trembling
claws.
Like all the happiness inside us is
trying to burst out.
Actually, I'm pretty sure that was a real
earthquake, Starflight thought.
He'd felt the tremor in the earth as well
rumbling up through his talons before it
stopped.
Done, Glory said, and the spear moved
through the air, she handed it to one of
the other rain wings.
Orchid shook off the loose chains and
spread her wings, beaming and glowing
like a ball of pink sunshine.
Orchid.
This is our new queen, glory, said
mangrove.
She's the reason we found you, and she's
the dragon who convinced everyone to come
get you.
It was really, thanks to Mangrove, said
Glory.
He's the one who knew you were missing
and wouldn't shut up about it.
If we hadn't brought an army to save you
he'd have come over here and done it
himself.
Thank you, Your Majesty.
Orchid said with a half bow.
That is too weird.
Starflight whisper to fate speaker.
Hearing my friend called Your Majesty.
I bet watching her lead an invasion is
fairly strange too.
Fate speaker whispered back.
Grandeur, Liana, disguise yourselves as
night wings.
Take the guards, spears, and go to the
other caves.
Glory ordered.
Show everyone how to free the prisoners.
Move as quickly and quietly as you can
then get everyone back to the tunnel.
The most important thing is getting all
14 prisoners home safe.
Mangrove.
You and Orchid take a moment to calm your
scales down, and then you can head back
to the rainforest too.
I should come with you, Mangrove said.
If you're going into the fortress.
You'll need backup.
I'll have it, Glory said.
I hope she doesn't mean me.
Starflight thought anxiously.
But we went to a lot of trouble to
reunite you and Orchid, so go be happy
with her for a little while.
We'll let you know if we need you.
Mangrove and Orchid both bowed.
Wings brushed against Starflight's
shoulder, and he started back for a
moment before he realized it was glory
heading up the tunnel to the lava river.
Come on, Starflight, she said from the
darkness.
Let's go have a talk with a night wing
Queen.
The fortress seemed eerily quiet as they
flew toward it.
The air felt thick with ashy smoke.
Starflight's nose and throat hurt even
worse than before, and occasionally he
heard glory and fate speaker coughing
behind him.
He rubbed his stinging eyes, and stared
at the fortress ahead, wondering where an
entire night wing army would assemble.
Queen Battle Winner wouldn't be able to
lead it, since she couldn't leave the
lava.
Greatness would have to really make some
queenly decisions if she was planning to
lead their attack.
Had Starflights absence been noticed
yet?
If not, surely at least Morrow's here
would have gone to check on Flame and
found him missing.
How had he reacted?
Maybe he'll think Flame tried to fly home
to the continent.
Starfly thought.
We'd be in luck if Morrow Seer tried to
follow him.
He really did not want to encounter
Morrow Seer in the halls of the
fortress.
Please tell me there's an invisible army
with us.
Starflight said.
I'm your invisible army.
Glory said cheerfully.
I'm serious, Starflight said.
We shouldn't go in there alone, just the
3 of us.
Tell me something, Glory said.
The dungeons you saw.
How do we get them open?
Will those spears work on the doors, or
do we need keys?
Starflight closed his eyes for a moment
picturing the dungeon.
We need keys, I think, he said.
So let's start with a queen.
Glory said.
We'll make her tell us where to find the
keys.
Starflight cannot imagine making battle
winner do anything at all, but then glory
was a lot more persuasive than he was, and
even more so now that she had a queen's
authority.
He swerved down toward the entrance
closest to the council chamber.
The 3 of them padded silently through the
hallways.
Loud voices rang out from a few of the
rooms.
Starflight caught snippets of an argument
about who would get to wear some shared
armor, a monologue about another battle
the storyteller had been in, and a
conversation about how killing rain wings
would have to be easier than killing mud
wings.
He'd forgotten all about the dead mud
wings on the rainforest border.
Why would the night wings kill them?
He asked himself.
And almost immediately, a possible answer
came to him.
To keep the mud wings out of the
rainforest.
If they believe there's a deadly monster
lurking in there, that it's not safe to
go anywhere near it.
They won't be tempted to conquer their
rainforest themselves.
Leaving it untouched and ready for the
night wings to move in any time.
That explains the howler monkeys too.
He remembered Jambu saying that the
monkeys used to make a normal monkey
sound, but then suddenly they started
screaming like dying dragons instead.
I bet my dad is responsible for that.
I bet he did something to the monkeys so
their screams would scare the mud wings
away.
Everything the Night Wings did was part
of their grand plan of taking over the
rainforest, Starflight side, and glanced
at the map as he led the way into the
room with his secret entrance.
If only there was somewhere else, the
night wings could go, but they'd clearly
been all over Pyria, destroying scavenger
dens for whatever reason, and if there
had been somewhere else for them to live
surely they would have found it.
Someone's coming.
Glory whispered.
A heartbeat before Starflight heard claws
tapping on stone, and smelled the rank
odor of night wing breath.
Fate speaker shot across the room to the
map, but before she could lift the corner
and duck underneath, scales slithered in
the doorway, and they all whirled to see
greatness staring at them, the ground
rumbled under their feet.
What are you doing in here?
The night wing princess asked.
Her glittering diamond necklace was askew
as if she'd slept in it, and had
forgotten it was on.
Her eyes looked exhausted, red and raw
from the smoke in the air.
Why aren't you with the others?
We got lost?
Starflight tried.
Greatness squinted at them.
Oh, you're the 2 little prophecy
dragonettes.
Mozier was looking for you in quite a
towering rage earlier.
Listen, like I told him, the prophecy is
important, but it's even more important
that we win this battle tonight.
So the whole tribe is going.
No exceptions.
Everyone else is in the great hall.
If you follow this tunnel down and take
the 4th left, you'll be halfway there and
someone can guide you.
What about you?
Fate speaker asked.
Why aren't you there?
I'm going to speak with a queen first
Greatness said.
Her eyes darted involuntarily to the
map.
Actually, Glory's voice said from the air
we're all going to speak with a queen.
Greatness stiffened and pulled in her
wings.
Starflight saw a flash of scales changing
color, as glory's claws rested on the
artery in the night wing's throat.
Don't call for help, Glory said.
I'm not an ordinary rain wing.
My venom is aimed at your eyes right now
and I am not afraid to use it.
The dangerous one.
Greatness whispered.
That's right, Glory said.
Now, we're all going up the hidden tunnel
to the queen, and you're leading the way
and you're going to keep in mind that my
fangs are right behind you.
Greatness blinked and nodded several
times. looking queasy.
She hurried to the map and ducked into
the tunnel.
The rustle of wings indicated that glory
had followed her.
Fate speaker and Starflight were right
behind them.
The rocky floor felt hot under
Starflights, talons, hotter than it had
before.
Another rumble shook the mountain as they
pressed forward.
Um, Starflight said, as a horrifying
thought struck him.
There's no chance this volcano is about
to erupt.
Is there?
Up ahead in the shadows, the bulky figure
of greatness paused and looked back.
It shouldn't, she said.
Our scientist predicted that we have at
least 2 more years before another major
eruption.
How can they be sure?
Fate speaker asked.
Did someone have a vision?
Greatness turned around and kept walking
without answering?
Starflight braced himself against another
tremble in the ground.
I don't like the feeling in the air.
He whispered to fate speaker.
I don't know much about volcanoes, but
I'm pretty sure it's a bad sign when they
start doing this.
Poor Night Wings.
Fate speaker said softly.
Hmm, said Starflight, more like poor us
if we don't get out of here soon.
They abruptly came around the bend into
the Queen's cave.
Queen Battle Winner was sitting erect in
her boiling lava cauldron, glaring at
them with fierce eyes that reflected the
red light around them.
Starflight inhaled sharply as he spotted
another dragon in the back corner of the
cave.
His father, mastermind.
The scientist was fussing over several
hunks of metal on the floor, and after a
moment, Starflight remembered seeing them
in the lab, all put together.
They looked like a suit of armor that
would fit over an entire dragon, with
room to pour something in between the
dragon's scales and the metal.
Lava.
He realized.
This is how Battle winner plans to get to
the rainforest.
Mastermind has been building her a
portable lava device.
His brain immediately started taking
apart the science of the idea.
But how would it stay hot, away from the
volcano?
Can any metal really contain it?
He also realized, tangentially, that his
father had lied about not seeing the
queen, he must be one of the few dragons
who knew her secret and was working to
help her keep it.
Mastermind looked up as they came in, and
locked eyes with Starflight.
His expression was startled, but in a
distracted way, as if he was dealing with
something far more important.
And after a moment, he bent back to the
armor without saying anything to his
son.
Fool.
Battle winner snarled at greatness.
Greatness hung her head, looking less
like a queen than ever.
Preparations.
The night wing queen hissed.
Everyone is gathering, greatness said.
But, mother, I can't lead them into
battle by myself.
Can't we postpone the attack?
Mastermind says your armor isn't ready.
It will be.
Battle winner hissed.
Tonight.
I don't think so.
Mastermind said anxiously from behind
her.
He dropped a curved tail plate with a
loud clatter and winced.
Your majesty.
I don't understand why you have to go.
I need more time to make sure this will
work for you.
Must.
Do this, right?
Battle winner snarled.
Can't trust you to invade properly.
She cast a scornful look at greatness.
You shouldn't, greatness said, fingering
the diamonds around her neck.
I don't know what you want me to do.
So I was coming to ask you, and then, And
then she ran into me.
Glory said.
Mastermind let out a yelp of fright, as
glory's scales shimmered into sight
shifting from the camouflage of the
shadows to a bold royal blue shot through
with veins of gold.
She looked regal and out of place in this
smoky red and black cave.
Well, she added, more accurately, she ran
into my claws.
She flexed her talons and narrowed her
eyes at Queen Battle Winner.
And you are, growled the queen.
Queen glory of the rain wings.
I have come to give you one chance to end
this war before we destroy you.
The dragon and the lava made an
involuntary scoffing sound that clearly
hurt her throat.
She paused for a long moment, clutching
her neck, then dipped her whole body
under the lava and emerged again.
Funny, she said finally.
Not very, Glory said.
If you think an ice wing attack is hard
to live with, wait until you experience a
little rain wing venom, I'm afraid your
lava bath won't be able to help you with
that.
Smoke hissed softly through battle
winners' nostrils as she stared at
glory.
Oh, 3 moons, greatness said anxiously
wringing her talons.
What do you want?
We're taking our prisoners back, Glory
said.
You will never set foot in the rainforest
again.
You will leave the rain wings alone
forever. will destroy the tunnel between
our kingdoms.
You'll call off the invasion, and we'll
never even sniff, another night wing near
our village for the next 12 generations.
Starflight cleared his throat a few times
significantly, and Glory glanced at him.
Also, she added, you will stop meddling
with a prophecy dragonettes, both the
real ones and the fake ones.
You'll let them save the world and stop
the war however they decide to.
Never, hissed Queen Battle Winner.
Never.
Never what?
Glory said, because you don't have a lot
of options here.
I see one.
Battle winner croaked, you die.
Glory bared her teeth the night wing
queen, but greatness interrupted, her
voice pleading, please, listen, you're
dooming us to a horrible end, she cried.
The volcano is not only a future threat.
It's killing us now.
There's almost no prey left.
We're all starving.
Fewer dragonettes are born each year, and
we're barely night wings anymore.
Don't you see?
The tribe is dying.
We need a new home.
Well, you can't have ours, you murderous
entitled worms.
Glory flared.
Why not?
Mastermind asked.
Sounding genuinely confused.
Because a whole tribe already lives
there.
Glory scales were flashing to red and
orange in places, hints of her anger
showing through, although she quelled
them quickly.
And if you try to hurt my rain wings, I
will make you regret it.
Wait, Starflight said.
His brain was suddenly spinning forward, a
new idea unfolding across his mind like a
scroll rolling open.
Wait.
Maybe, maybe there's a way to
compromise.
Glory.
Stop and think.
There's lots of space in the rainforest.
The rain wings say so all the time.
What if we let the night wings move in
and build their own village somewhere in
the rainforest, but only if they all
swear to accept you as their new queen.
There was a shocked pause.
What?
Battle winner roared.
Glory tilted her head at Starflight
looking skeptical but intrigued.
Think about it, Starflight said.
A new home for the night wings, safe and
peaceful, and all they have to do is give
up their cruelty and violence and obey
you.
You know you'd be as great at being night
wing queen as you are at rolling the rain
wings.
Hmm, Glory said.
There would be something poetic about
being the boss of a tribe that's always
called me lazy and useless.
Never.
Battle winner shouted, then had to stop
and double over coughing for a long
minute.
Uneasily, Starflight felt the ground
shake again, much stronger this time.
Will never bow to rain wings.
Battle winner snarled finally.
Actually, mother, greatness said
nervously.
It sounds like a decent plan to me.
Battle winner spat out a shard of ice
that sizzled into steam when it hit the
lava.
You never wanted to be queen, she
rasped.
You're a pathetic air.
I know I am.
Greatness said.
Being queen is awful.
Battle winner hissed again, loud and
long.
Starflight realized that he was also
hearing something else, a far away
rumbling that seemed to be getting louder
and closer.
What about our real queen?
Mastermind asked.
Starflight stared straight into the icy
blue depths of battle winner's eyes.
I think she knows she's not making it to
the rainforest.
There's nothing you can build that will
work to keep her alive there.
She's going to die here.
Crushed by the volcano along with a
nightwing home.
And if she wants her tribe to survive.
She needs to hand them over to Queen
Glory.
Battle winner's tale was thrashing hard
enough to spill lava over the edges of
the cauldron, splattering dangerously
close to their talons.
I am the queen.
I am, she spat.
Wait, Starflight.
Glory said.
I haven't agreed to this.
How could we ever trust the night wings
in our rainforest?
These are the same dragons who've been
abducting and torturing my tribe.
How can we just forgive them?
I don't want them anywhere near us.
She shook her head.
I don't think it'll work.
Mastermind looked sick at the words
abducting and torturing.
He turned away from Starflight, staring
down at the armor in his claws.
It might work.
Greatness said desperately.
Give us a chance, please.
I promise we can be better.
Shameful.
Battle winner snarled.
It's not up to you, Starflight said to
the Nightwing Queen, and realized his
voice wasn't even shaking.
He was right.
He could feel it, and that helped him get
past his fear.
You're stuck here.
We're negotiating with greatness now.
He turned to the night wing princess.
Come on.
Let's talk about this somewhere else.
No, Ward Battle Winner.
You can't do this.
I won't let you.
She gripped the sides of the cauldron
with glistening claws, and then, to
Starflight's horror, she heaved herself
up and out of the lava, her back talon
crunched down on the edge of the cauldron
her wings flared open, scattering molten
orange droplets across the room.
Her thick head swung back and forth
glaring at all of them.
She was massive, as big as morrow sere
and glowing horribly, as lava dripped
between her scales and claws and
slithered off her tail.
Mother, stop.
Greatness cried.
Your majesty.
Mastermind shouted.
You can't come out.
Wait, my experiment.
He scrabbled frantically at the armor
around him.
I will lead my tribe to safety.
The queen hissed.
She landed on the rocky ground with a
thud, but the aftershocks went on too
long to be caused by her.
It was an earthquake, a serious one
Starflight realized, as bits of the walls
began to crumble.
We have to get out of here. said to
glory.
Queen Battle Winner took a step toward
glory and Starflight, then stopped
clutching her neck again.
She hissed in a frightening, hoarse way
and took another step.
Her tongue flicked out and in as she
started to shake.
When she stared around at all of them.
Starflight could see the icy blue
spreading rapidly over her eyeballs.
Mother, greatness yelped.
Get back in the lava.
She darted to her mother's side and tried
tugging on Battle Winner's wing.
Mastermind dashed up on the other side
and started wrapping bits of metal around
the queen's limbs.
But Starflight could tell that even if
the armor would work, it was already too
late.
With a bone rattling shriek, Battle
winner threw off her daughter and
mastermind and surged toward glory.
Glory took a step back, and the night
wing queen collapsed on the floor in
front of her.
Her limbs twitched violently, her wings
spasmed, her tail thrashed back and
forth.
White frost was starting to march between
the scales of her neck, spreading rapidly
across her body.
Lava dripped off battle winner, faster
and faster, as the ice started to win the
battle for her body.
Greatness pressed herself against the
wall, whimpering, as far away from the
dying queen as possible.
Starflight wanted to look away, but
somehow he couldn't.
He felt fate speaker bury her face in his
shoulder.
The Nightwing Queen's neck froze solid
first. then her chest, her ears, her
wings, her snout, all the way out to her
claws and her tail.
Within moments, the dragon's entire body
was encased in jagged whorls of ice.
Her eyes were blue pools of rage, her
mouth froze wide open, as if she'd wanted
to end her life with a howl of fury, but
it was too late.
Nothing could come out.
Greatness and mastermind stared down at
the queen, disbelief and horror warring
on their faces.
Then, the entire island shook, as if a
giant dragon had pounded his talons into
it, and Starflight felt his stomach twist
with terror.
The volcano was about to erupt.
We have to go.
Now, Starflight said, grabbing glory and
shoving her toward the door.
He bundled fate speaker ahead of him too
and they fled down the tunnel.
Wait!
He heard greatness yell as they ran, but
when fate speaker tried to stop, he
pushed her forward.
There was no time for more diplomatic
conversation.
Feet thumped behind them.
Greatness would have to talk to them
somewhere else, such as not in the middle
of an exploding volcano.
The map caught on Starflight's horns and
ripped away from the wall as he threw
himself out of the hole at the end.
He rolled forward, wrestling the map off
his head, and bundling it in his talons.
Without really thinking about it, he
shoved it under one arm and carried it
with him as he bolted for the door.
Where are the dungeons, Glory shouted.
There's no time, Starflight yelled.
Couldn't she feel the volcano shaking?
Ash was raining down all around them.
Cracks were zipping across the fortress
walls like lightning.
We are not leaving Deathbringer.
Glory grabbed fate speaker.
Point the way, and I'll go by myself.
Starflight, get out of here.
Get everyone off the island.
Death bringer?
Starflight opened and closed his mouth.
He hadn't realized that rescuing the
Nightwing assassin was even on Glory's
agenda, let alone that it was important
enough to risk an erupting volcano for.
But she's right.
He risked everything for us.
For her.
Fate speaker pointed in the direction of
the dungeons, and glory took off without
waiting for any more arguments.
I can't let her go by herself.
Starflight's heart was trying to pound
its way out of his chest.
He remembered the night wing skeletons in
the old treasure room.
He thought of the lava flow that had
consumed the old forest and the skulls
sticking out of it.
He could feel the heat of the volcano, as
if it were trying to batter its way
through the walls toward him.
All he wanted to do, was fly as fast as
he could to the tunnel and escape to the
cool safety of the rainforest.
But glory didn't know where she was going
or what to do when she got there.
He whirled around and found greatness
behind them, wringing her talons again
and looking utterly wrecked.
Where are the keys to the dungeon prisons
he yelled at her.
The, oh, there's a set hidden in a coal
niche on the dungeon stairs, she said.
What are we going to do about the
volcano?
Is this it?
The one that kills us all.
Yes.
Not necessarily, Starflight said. trying
to sound far less panicked than he felt.
Take fate speaker to the great hall and
tell all the night wings our terms.
If they'll swear loyalty to Queen Glory
we'll consider letting them live in the
rainforest.
Anyone who agrees, send them through the
tunnel as fast as you can.
Anyone who doesn't, tell them to fly for
the continent immediately.
They need to get far away from here
before the eruption.
The lava and smoke could reach for
miles.
But glory didn't say yes.
Fate speaker pointed out.
I'll talk her into it.
He promised grimly, go quickly.
He wrapped his wings briefly around fate
speaker, feeling her scales slide against
his, and then let go, and ran after
glory.
He foundered the next intersection
looking around in furious indecision.
This way, he called.
He ran past her toward the stairs that
led down to the dungeon.
There was no time to talk, and the
rumbling of the volcano was now loud
enough to drown out any attempt at
conversation anyway.
The heat increased as they went down and
the noise grew, and the walls seemed to
shake even more.
We're going to die down here, Starfly
thought, with absolute certainty.
He stopped at each niche on the stairs
feeling gingerly around the coals and
singeing his talons more than once.
Finally, in the last one, he felt
something metal and heavy hanging from a
hook inside the opening, and when he
tugged on it, he found keys resting in
his claws.
In the dungeon, Splendor was awake
shaking like a leaf in the middle of her
cell, with her wings over her head.
It's all right.
Starflight called through the bars, trying
keys in the lock one after another.
We're here.
We're rescuing you.
You're going home.
Splendor looked up, blinking.
Her scales were bright acid green, and
her expression was dazed with fear.
Starflight glanced around and realized
that glory had gone right past them.
She was at Death Bringer's cage, grabbing
the bars.
As he watched.
Deathbringer reached his talon through
the bars and wrapped them around hers, and
they exchanged a look that said, thank
you, and a whole lot more.
The lock finally turned under his claws
and the door swung open.
Splendor stumbled toward him.
Wait here, he told her, hurrying to Death
Bringer's door.
Why aren't we leaving?
Splendor wailed.
Glory grabbed the keys from him and
started trying them.
It was hard to tell whether her talons
were shaking from nerves too, or whether
it just looked that way, because the
whole mountain was quaking now without
stopping.
You don't have to do this.
Deathbringer said.
His gaze fixed on glory.
Oh, I don't?
Glory said, without looking up from the
keys.
That'll save me some time.
Good luck with a volcano, then.
Starflight glanced up at the ominous
cracks appearing in the ceiling.
He spotted a symbol at the top of
Deathbringer's cage, a symbol he'd seen
on one of the keys.
Try this one, he said, reaching over and
taking the keys from glory.
He stuck the key with a symbol on it in
the lock and turned it.
The door swung open.
Deathbringer yanked on his chains as they
hurried into the cell, Splendor ran in
behind them, flapping her wings in a
frantic whirl of green.
Something is coming through the walls.
She shrieked.
We're all going to die.
Starflight looked out at the dungeon
hallway and saw lava glowing in the
cracks of the walls.
She's right, he said quietly to glory.
You 2 go ahead, she said, concentrating
on the keys and death bringer's chains.
We'll be right behind you.
Let's go.
Splendor cried.
One more minute, Starflight told her.
He held his breath as glory tried key
after key.
We don't have any more minutes.
Splendor sobbed.
We're going to be exploded and covered in
lava and melted and dead.
A ferocious rumble answered her, knocking
them all off their feet.
Glory scrambled up and stuck the last key
in the lock around Deathbringers' chains.
That's it.
She cried as they fell off, clanking and
clattering like living things on the
quaking floor.
Come on.
She seized Deathbringer's forearm and
yanked him up.
They took off down the hallway, with
Starflight and splendor right behind
them.
The mountain was shaking so violently now
that it was hard to run.
Starflight kept getting thrown into walls
or the other dragons.
He concentrated on the stairs up ahead.
Watch your feet.
Deathbringer called.
Hot coals were scattered across the steps
where they had fallen from their niches.
Glory swept several aside with her tail
wincing, as even that brief contact
burned her scales.
They raced up the steps, covering their
heads with their wings as bits of rock
plummeted from the ceiling.
Starflight stepped on a coal and bit back
a yowl of pain.
The stairs felt endless, like they were
staggering upward for days, but finally
they burst out onto a level floor.
This way.
Death Bringer hurtled down the hall in a
direction Starflight hadn't been before.
A loud crash sounded from the direction
of the council chamber, and Starflight
thought he heard a dragon screaming.
He shoved Splendor ahead of him.
Even glory was green now.
Neither rain wing could camouflage their
scales while their fear was so strong.
They all raced after Deathbringer
twisting through the fortress labyrinth
until up ahead, they saw the sky, or at
least, the dense cloud of ash and smoke
that now surrounded the volcano.
Try not to breathe, Glory said to
Splendor.
It's not far to the tunnel.
Starflight flung his wings open and
leaped off the ledge, flapping furiously
through the thick air.
He could see the lava river glowing and
churning below him, faster and wider than
ever.
He could also see a growing crowd of
black dragons down on the beach, some of
them fighting one another, tooth and
claw.
We have to bring them to the rainforest.
He called to glory, coughing and gasping
or else the whole night wing tribe could
be wiped out today.
Serves them right, she called, but he
could see from her face that she couldn't
let that happen either.
Chunks of fiery rocks were starting to
shoot out of the volcano, blasting into
the sky, and slamming into the ground
with explosive force.
One came so close to Starflight's wing
that he felt the heat of it crackle along
his scales.
Glory twisted in the air, scanning the
caves below her.
I hope all my rain wings made it back
safely.
Starflight found himself making a
decision that shocked him, but the words
were out of his mouth before he could
take them back.
You go ahead to the rainforest, make sure
they're all right and prepare them for
what's coming, he said.
I'll gather the night wings and bring
them through.
She gave him a surprised look, but didn't
argue.
We'll have our spears and fangs and
sleeping darts ready, she said.
Come on, you two.
She flicked her tail at Death Bringer and
Splendor, who sped after her.
Starflight watched them all die for the
cave entrance, where green scales flashed
as 2 half camouflaged rain wings reached
to welcome them in.
Now Starflight could see a cluster of
spears bristling in the air by the cave
and he realized, with a sinking sensation
that the rain wings probably weren't
letting any night wings through.
He'd sent fate speaker and greatness on
that mission, but the rain wings didn't
know them.
They barely met fate speaker, and had no
reason to trust them.
They would listen to him though.
If he could convince the night wings to
accept glory as their queen, if he could
lead them into the rainforest
peacefully.
But if he couldn't, there were a 1000000
things that could go wrong, the rain
wings might panic and attack the night
wings as they came through, even with
glory standing over them, or the night
wings might lie to get to safety, and
then attack the rain wings anyway, or the
volcano might kill them all before they
got anywhere.
Another blast from the volcano sent sharp
rock shards zinging around him.
Starflight felt a stabbing pain in his
side as one of them grazed his scales.
No more time for worrying, he thought
tucking his wings and diving toward the
beach.
We escape now together, or we all die.
It looked as though the entire tribe
might be gathered on the beach below
him.
Starflight flew in a wide circle, scanning
the crowd, until he saw greatness and
fate speaker standing on a boulder, waving
their wings and trying to get everyone's
attention.
They'll never let us through, shrieked a
night wing with long scratches along his
side.
We have to take the rainforest by force.
We can't fight them, yelled another.
They infiltrated the island, took out all
our guards, and escaped with the
prisoners, and we never even knew they
were here.
They'll kill us the moment we step into
that tunnel.
The volcano shot another blast of fiery
rocks into the air, and many of the black
dragons flung themselves to the ground
with cries of terror.
Listen to me, Starfly called, hovering
above greatness.
There is a way to escape safely.
I promise you that the rain wings will
show you mercy.
If you accept glory as your queen.
How can a rain wing lead our tribe?
shouted a voice that Starflight
recognized as his sister's.
Fierce teeth flared her wings and shook
her talons at him.
Better than Queen Battle winner can.
Starflight said, since she's dead.
Shocked silence fell over the tribe.
All of them stared at him in disbelief.
Starflight spotted mastermind, hopping
agitatedly from one foot to the other
with his arms full of scrolls.
And finally, Starflight saw Marsir at the
back, glowering at him.
The look on the giant dragon's face gave
Starflight chills from his wings to the
tip of his tail.
But greatness.
One of the night wings said half
heartedly.
I've already agreed to this plan.
Greatness called.
It is the only way for our tribe to
survive.
Glory will take care of you.
Starflight said firmly.
She will be a fair and just queen, and
you'll be safe in the rainforest instead
of trapped here.
The smoke had gotten so dense that it was
getting hard to see the dragons in front
of him.
Fine gray ash coated all their scales and
made the sand slick beneath their claws.
The volcano rumbled ominously.
I'll do it, mighty Claus said from the
front of the crowd.
It has to be better than this.
How do we know they won't kill us all?
asked another dragon.
I trust her, said greatness.
And guess what really will kill you all?
Fate speaker added, pointing.
That volcano.
So come on, let's get out of here.
All hail queen glory.
She took to the sky, flying toward the
tunnel.
Queen Glory, shouted mighty Claus, leaping
into the air.
Queen Glory, shouted another dragon, and
then another and another.
Starflight hoped that glory could hear
them.
This had to be the strangest thing that
had ever happened to her.
The tribe that was always supposed to be
so superior, now bowing down to the most
useless of the dragonettes.
He darted ahead of them to the ledge, and
found that their rain wings were gone.
In their place were clay, tsunami, and
sunny, and he felt himself breathe a
little deeper when he saw them.
I hope you know what you're doing.
Tsunami said to Starflight as he landed
beside her.
This is a terrible plan.
Night Wings can't be trusted.
I think it's brilliant.
Sonny said warmly.
I think you're brilliant.
I think it's the best idea in the world.
Starflide hadn't even thought about what
Sonny would think of his idea.
For once.
He gave her a shy smile, pleased that he
had accidentally done something she was
so excited about.
We'd better hurry, Clay said, glancing up
at the mountain, which was spitting
bright orange sparks into the sky.
Come on, quickly.
He called to the approaching night wings
holding out his talons.
Mighty Claus was the 1st to land on the
ledge.
Queen Glory, he cried, charging past them
down the tunnel.
Starflight followed far enough to see the
dragonette leap into the hole and
disappear.
Greatness was next, moving just as fast.
She paused briefly beside Starflight, her
wings filling the tunnel, her eyes
darting anxiously back toward the
smoldering volcano.
I'm so glad I won't ever have to be queen
she whispered to him. then hurried off.
Escaping ahead of the rest of her tribe.
Starfly thought, instead of waiting to
make sure everyone else gets away
safely.
The night wings should all be glad she
won't ever be their queen.
He stepped back as a flood of night wings
started coming through.
To our new queen, he heard a few of them
cry.
Queen Glory.
This is so wrong, somebody muttered.
Think of all the food, said someone
else.
And the smell of the rainforest, have you
been there?
said another.
It's amazing.
Like the air itself is full of water and
light.
You'll finally get to try a coconut, one
dragon said to another as they went by.
Real trees.
A few of the dragonettes were whispering
to each other.
Real sunshine, mangoes every day.
Starflight pushed back through the tide
of black dragons until he reached his
friends on the outer ledge.
The sky was full of boiling dark clouds
and gray ash was raining down like snow.
A new rivulet of lava had snaked out of
the top of the volcano, and was bubbling
down one side.
The earthquakes were coming in waves now
and getting stronger, like a giant dragon
stamping its way toward them across the
ocean.
We're making all of them say Queen Glory
on their way past, tsunami said to
Starflight, grabbing one Nightwing's
tale.
Hey, you, speak up.
Queen Glory, he grumbled, and Starflight
recognized Strong Wings, his father's
burly lab assistant.
Once more, like you mean it. tsunami
prodded, or you can discuss it with a
volcano up there.
The volcano obligingly growled.
Queen glory.
Strong wings blurted loudly.
Better, tsunami said, letting him go.
Starflight was startled to see one brown
dragon approaching in the middle of all
the black, and for a moment he thought it
was clay, but clay was right next to
him.
Then, with a huge stab of guilt, he
remembered Ocher, who had gone off to
hunt earlier that morning, which felt
like weeks and weeks ago.
I might have left him here, I didn't even
think to look for him.
Oh.
Hey, Ogre said, flapping onto the ledge
and bobbing his head at Starflight.
So, I'm not sure what's happening, but it
seems like everyone's leaving in kind of
a hurry, and someone said something about
bananas this way.
Just follow the others into the tunnel
Starflight said.
We'll explain everything later.
Sure.
All right, Ogre said.
In a moment, he'd disappeared in the
direction of the rainforest as well.
Star flight.
This dragon wanted to talk to you, Clay
said, tugging Starfly aside.
Oh, Starflight said, meeting his father's
eyes.
Clay, this is mastermind.
My, my father.
The thin black dragon still had several
scrolls clutched to his chest, and he was
fidgeting with his claws anxiously.
He tried to reach for Starflight's talons
dropped a few scrolls, gathered them up
again, and blurted.
It occurred to me at this rather
inopportune juncture, that how new hosts
may very well er hate me.
What do you think?
Should I be concerned?
Will they really let me live there?
After everything.
I'm afraid they might have some
grievances.
Starflight sensed that his father wanted
a reassuring lie, but it wasn't about to
give him one.
They probably do hate you.
He said.
I think they should, don't you?
But, mastermind fretted, twisting a
scroll between his claws.
But, but science, and my orders, and
Don't make excuses, Starflight said.
When you get there, tell the queen you're
sorry, and accept whatever punishment she
gives you.
That's my advice.
Or don't come at all.
Tsunami chimed in from behind him.
Take your chances on the ocean instead.
She nodded out to sea.
Mastermind flicked his tail with a
worried expression, watching the night
wings pour past them into the cave, faster
and faster, as the volcano's rumbles grew
ever more ominous and closer together.
I'll apologize, he said with a deep
breath.
To our new queen.
He added.
All right, go on.
Tsunami said, stepping back.
Take this with you.
Starflight interjected, realizing he
still had the map with all the scavenger
dens on it.
He tucked the folded paper in among the
scrolls in his father's arms, and
mastermind hurried into the tunnel with
them all pressed to his chest.
Just like you.
When we had to escape the mountain, Sonny
said, bumping Starflight side, trying to
take all the scrolls.
I hope we don't have anything else in
common.
Starflight said, with a flick of his
tail.
Don't give up on him yet, Sonny said.
Starfly thought she must be the only
dragon in the world who'd be willing to
forgive what mastermind had done.
Guys, tsunami said quietly.
Look who the last night wing is.
Starflight turned, already knowing the
answer.
The last few night wings hurried by
blurting, The new queen.
Queen Glory, as they ducked into the
tunnel, and then the 4 dragonettes were
left standing on the ledge, facing Morrow
Seer as he landed.
He loomed over them, terrifying and
menacing and furious, looking exactly as
he had when they 1st met him under the
mountain, only a few weeks ago.
Night Wings are superior to every other
tribe.
Starflight remembered him saying in their
secret meeting.
You have to act like a leader to be
treated like one.
Don't let anyone see your weaknesses.
Don't have any weaknesses.
All his life.
Starflight had often felt like he was
nothing but weaknesses.
But after everything he'd done today, He
was starting to think maybe he wasn't so
useless after all, powers or no powers.
This will never work.
Maro seer growled down at them.
Night Wings will never bow to a dragon
from another tribe, least of all a rain
wing.
Once we're safe, we'll turn on you all.
Then you'll end up back here.
Tsunami spat, waving her talent at the
ash covered blackened landscape behind
him, or dead.
Either would be fine with me.
We made you.
Maro seer snarled.
You dragonheads are only important
because of us, and we can destroy you
just as easily.
No, you can't, Sonny spoke up.
We have a prophecy to fulfill, and
there's nothing you can do to stop it
from happening.
Morosir barked a laugh.
Stop it. he said.
I've been trying to make it happen for
almost 10 years.
Prophecies don't work like that.
Sonny insisted.
You can't make them happen the way you
want.
Whatever's going to happen will happen.
That's the whole point of destiny.
The volcano shot a plume of lava into the
air, and the ground shook hard enough
that all the dragonettes had to clutch
the rock walls to stay upright.
On the contrary.
I certainly can make my prophecy happen
however I want.
Marasier said silkily.
Considering, I'm the one who made it up
in the 1st place.
The earth began to shake without stopping
a continuous tremor that jarred
Starflight's teeth in his head, and made
him feel as though the ledge was about to
drop out from under him.
The volcano growled again, and another
fountain of lava shot over the side, and
started slithering down the craggy
slope.
Maro Seer's face was lit by the orange
glow of the volcano, cruelty etched into
every line of his snout.
You what?
Tsunami said.
The prophecy isn't real.
The words didn't make sense in
Starflight's head.
He couldn't fit them into the way the
world worked, the way his world had
always worked.
The dragonette prophecy isn't real.
That's not true, Sonny cried.
You're just saying that to be awful.
The volcano let out a roar, like 20
dragons having their tails stepped on at
once.
Oh, it's completely true.
Marosi or growled.
Queen Battle Winner and I wrote it
together after the last eruption
destroyed part of the fortress.
We knew we'd need a new home soon, and
the prophecy was our plan to get it.
How?
Starfight asked, running the prophecy
through his mind.
What does the prophecy have to do with
where the night wings live?
The idea was that we would control the
dragonettes.
Marosier said, by including a night wing
who naturally would be the leader of the
group.
You're abysmal failure in that department
was our 1st problem.
Then we'd choose a sand wing queen.
And eventually the night wings would join
the war.
With our strength in numbers tipping the
balance.
So our ally would be sure to win.
And then your ally, whoever you picked
would help you take over the rainforest.
Starflight puzzled out.
It's all about you.
But not in a way that anyone would
notice.
Darkness will rise to bring the light.
That's the night wings.
Exactly.
The only really important part of the
prophecy.
We couldn't be too obvious about it, said
Maro Seer.
Behind him, dark smoke was pouring out of
the volcano at an alarming rate.
The rest of it.
Smoke and mirrors.
No, Sonny almost shouted, making the rest
of them jump.
The prophecy is real.
We were born to end the fight to end the
war and save everyone.
Afraid not, Moros here said nastily.
You'll just as ordinary as any other
dragon.
Wow. said Clay.
No wonder I've always felt ordinary.
But you're not.
You're not ordinary, Sonny said, her
voice full of tears.
Star Light had never seen her so upset.
He took a step toward her, reaching out
with his wings, but she shoved him away.
What about the red mud wing egg?
What about my egg all alone in the
desert?
There are scientific passions to things
like the appearance of blood eggs, said
Morrow Seer.
We study them, and use them in our
prophecies, to impress our less
scientific inferiors.
As for the sand wing egg.
We planned to set that up.
But as it happened, we got a tip that
yours was there already.
A coincidence.
No, it wasn't.
It was fate, Sonny hiccuped.
On the one talent, you are the worst
tsunami said tomorrow, seer.
But on the other, Sonny, think about what
this means.
We can live our own lives.
We don't have to follow some plan that
the stars laid out for us.
We're free.
But I want to stop the war, Sonny cried.
All those dragons out there.
They believe in the prophecy.
They believe in us.
If we give up, who will save them?
No one. said Maro Seer.
Now there's no point.
The night wings are already in the
rainforest.
So we have no reason to join the war.
It'll drag on endlessly.
And more dragons will die every day
probably for generations, all of them
wondering what happened to the amazing
dragonettes who were supposed to save
them, but obviously failed.
Sonny let out a furious sob, then whirled
pushed past Starflight and fled up the
tunnel, disappearing through the hole to
the rainforest.
Marosier took a step as if to follow her
and Starflight jumped into his way.
You can't come to the rainforest with us
he said.
His voice shaking as badly as the earth
below his claws.
Clay and tsunami closed rank on either
side of him.
He's right, tsunami said.
Even if you pretended to swear allegiance
to glory, we'd know you were lying.
At this point, we wouldn't trust you
about anything.
You should go, Clay said.
Fly across the sea, as fast as you can.
Maybe you'll make it before the volcano
really explodes.
Not that we care, tsunami added.
Maro Seer's expression was incredulous.
And who's going to stop me?
The 3 of you.
Yes, Starflight said.
And me, said fate speaker's voice from
behind Starflight.
He felt her tail brush against his as she
slid up next to him.
The giant Nightwing snorted, as if that
only made things more amusing.
Is all the dragonets I want dead anyway
he said, in one convenient place.
He opened his mouth, hissing up a fiery
breath, and then the volcano exploded.
It was like nothing Starflight had ever
seen or imagined.
It was like the earth turned inside out
collapsing the top of the mountain and
shooting a vast billowing cloud of
flaming smoke into the air, which rose to
the height of a 100 dragons, and then
fell, sending all that fire and rock and
ash and death, charging down the slope
toward them faster than any dragon could
fly.
Run!
Starfly yelled, turning and shoving fate
speaker in front of him.
They tore down the tunnel with tsunami
right on his tail and clay behind her.
The heavy footsteps of Marosea are
thumped after them, but there was no time
left to confront him.
Fate speaker dove into the whole first.
Starflight found himself turning and
grabbing tsunami, shoving her in next.
And so he was facing the cave entrance
and he saw the fireball come barreling at
them, filling the tunnel wall to wall
with bright orange flames.
Moro Seer's dark figure was silhouetted
against the fire for a brief, horribly
bright moment.
And then suddenly, the huge night wing
was gone, swallowed by the volcanic
explosion.
A 2nd later, Starflights scales were
blasted with heat, as if he'd fallen into
lava, a stab of blazing agony went
through both eyes, and he closed them
with a howl of pain.
And then he felt wings wrap around him
and he realized it was clay.
Clay in his fireproof scales.
The mud wing lifted him, shielding him
with his whole body, and shot into the
tunnel.
Will the fire follow us?
Starflight wondered dazedly.
How does the animus magic work?
Will we cross over to the rainforest side
halfway through and be safe?
Or can it reach all the way?
Rain pattered down on his scales, sizzling
softly, and he felt claws pull him from
the tunnel, and lie him down on wet
moss.
Cool wet leaves pressed against his face
and he heard the murmur of 100s of dragon
voices, against a background of
rainforest night sounds, sloths
chirruping, insects and frogs singing
their night songs.
And among the talons, he was sure he felt
sunnies.
He felt the warmth of her scales that
he'd know anywhere, even with his eyes
closed.
Or blind.
And he felt her pressed close to him for
a moment and whisper.
But why did it sound like fate speaker's
voice?
Starflight?
You were so brave.
And then the warmth was gone, and he
wondered if he'd imagined it.
And then pain flared all along his body
and he opened his mouth to scream, but it
hurt too much.
Something jabbed him in the neck, and he
had a moment to think, sleeping dart.
What a good idea.
And then everything.
Everything.
The pain, the worry, sunny and fate
speaker, the truth about the prophecy, the
fear of the volcano, everything faded
away, and Starflight dropped into
darkness as black as a night wings
scales.
Epilogue.
Snow was falling thick and fast, and the
snowflakes spun across the icy ground in
the freezing wind.
A sand wing stood huddled by the walls
outside her fort, wrapped in blankets, and
trying to breathe fire into the air
around her.
Papa, please, can't we go inside?
She said to the tall white dragon beside
her.
No, said Queen Glacier.
No one can be trusted with this
information until we make a decision.
Her arctic blue eyes regarded the ice
wing guards, who were positioned just out
of hearing range, watching the skies for
danger.
Frost glittered along her wings and
horns.
The spikes at the end of her tail were as
sharp and cold as icicles.
Blaise sighed.
You mean, until you make a decision.
Your input is always welcome.
Glacier said calmly.
She knew there was no chance of the sand
wing disagreeing with the ice wing
queen.
My neck hurts.
Blaise stamped her feet and poked the
bandage on her neck.
Ow!
Do you think it's going to scar?
I'll be so mad if it scars.
You're sure about what you heard, Glacier
asked her.
The Night Wings have chosen to side with
a blister, and they're trying to force
the Dragonettes to choose her as well.
That's what it sounded like, Blaise said
but more important?
That nightwing tried to kill me.
You're going to kill him, right?
We're going to kill all of them, if we
must. said Glacier.
I have no objection to the idea of wiping
out the night wings.
But we should consider what to do about
the dragonettes of the prophecy.
They seemed nice.
Blaise said, rubbing her talons together
to warm them up.
Some of them are a little funny looking
and I still don't understand what that
rain wing was doing with them.
Besides, she was a little too pretty.
I think it's better to be just the right
amount of pretty, don't you?
Too pretty is annoying.
Indeed, said Glacier, barely listening.
We don't want them telling anyone they've
chosen blister.
It would be very demoralizing for our
dragons.
But they can't possibly choose her now
that they've met me.
Blaze cried.
Now they know I'm wonderful and would
make a great queen, they'll definitely
pick me.
Hmm.
Glacier said, non-committally.
She didn't have quite the same faith in
Blaze's persuasive abilities, or dazzling
charisma that Blaze did.
Her own alliance with Blaise was based
less on the sand wings potential
queenliness and more uncertain promises
of future new territory for the ice
wings.
Well.
Glacier said, just in case they're
leaning in another direction.
I think we should make an effort to find
these dragonettes.
I'd like to have a chat with them
myself.
Fine.
All right, Blaise said, shivering
violently.
I'll tell you everything I know about
what they looked like and what they said
but can we please do that inside?
Glacier nodded thoughtfully, and Blaze
bolted for the door.
The ice wing queen was good at putting
together clues and figuring things out.
She would find those dragonettes, and she
really would start by talking to them
just to see which way they were
inclined.
But of course, if it was the wrong way.
Well, a few dead dragon ants here and
there would hardly be noticed in a war
like this.
A serpentine figure paced in the darkness
hissing softly.
Below her mountain ledge, in a hidden
valley, hints of firelight flickered in
windows, most of them covered with black
curtains.
Blister narrowed her eyes at the
scavenger den.
Why did Maru Seer think she would care
about a rat's nest full of crawling
squeaking, pale, 2 legged creatures.
She wasn't hungry.
She didn't even feel like burning down
their pathetic little huts.
She was too angry.
A whisper of wings on the wind made her
twist around, tail poised to attack.
But it wasn't an enemy, and it wasn't
Maro's ear.
It was that spineless leader of the
talons of peace, the sea wing, and he had
someone with him.
She squinted as they landed.
Forgive my lateness, queen blister
Nautilus said with a bow.
Where is Marosir?
She demanded.
I, I don't know, he stammered.
I thought he would be here by now.
I haven't seen him since he took the
alternate dragonette from the talons of
Peace Camp.
But I knew he was supposed to be here to
meet you tonight, and I had to speak with
him.
He squared his shoulders, obviously
trying to look braver than he felt.
Well, he's not here.
Blister spat.
Who is that?
Nautilus drew the dragonette forward
keeping one wing around him.
It was another sea wing, stunted, and
green and shivering.
My son, Nautilus said quietly, touching
the dragonette's head.
Squid.
Morosir left him to die in the mountains
but by a miracle, one of our spies found
him first.
His eyes were cold and glittering in the
light of the 2 moons that were full
overhead.
I hate night wings.
Squid mumbled.
I rather hate them too.
Blister agreed.
She'd always been irritated by this
arrangement with Marosir.
These meetings he called, at his choice
of time and place, with no way for her to
contact him in between.
An alliance with the night wings, and
control of the prophecy dragonettes
should make all this annoyance
worthwhile.
But so far, she wasn't getting any of
what she'd been promised.
Worse yet, it almost seemed as if she was
losing allies.
Her small band of sand wings, hidden away
safely in the Bay of a 1000 scales, were
loyal, of course.
She controlled them with careful
precision, knowing every move they made
and every thought they had.
She tricked them all into spying on one
another, by making each one think he or
she was in an exclusive elite, who
reported secretly to her, and any hint of
insubordination, or weakness, was
instantly punished with death.
But the alliance she'd formed years ago
with the sea wings, had slipped through
her claws like ice melting.
After the destruction of the Summer
Palace, Queen Coral had fled with her
tribe to their secret underwater home, and
no one had seen her or any other sea
wings since.
Blister had gone to the wrecked summer
palace almost every day since the attack
but there were no messages.
No dragons waiting to tell her what was
happening, no apologetic scrolls from the
sea wing queen.
And if Marosir didn't show up, then what
would she do?
She had no idea where the Nightwing
Island was, no way to send him a
message.
In effect, no night wing allies to speak
of.
Maybe she did feel like setting a
scavenger den on fire after all.
Nautilus sat with his wings wrapped
around squid, brooding.
His glow in the dark scales flashed dimly
as if he were telling his son something
private, over and over again.
If Marosir doesn't show up, Blister said
I have a strong suspicion I know whose
fault it is.
The sea wings both looked up, surprised.
The dragonettes.
She hissed.
Not this weakling.
The originals.
They've been nothing but trouble since
they escaped their captors.
Nautilus winced.
We called them guardians, he said.
But you're right.
Everywhere the dragonets go, they seem to
leave chaos behind.
Well, they've caused trouble for the
wrong dragon.
Blister snarled.
She glowered down at the slumbering
scavenger den, her claws twitching with
dreams of revenge.
Wherever they are.
I will hunt them down.
I will find them, and then, prophecy or
no prophecy, I'm going to kill them all.
The sun was hot. and blistering, beating
down on the sand around the stronghold, as
the squadron of sand wings landed in the
courtyard.
The smell of the decapitated heads on the
walls was stronger than usual.
Burn inhaled deeply.
She enjoyed the decaying scent, but
mostly, she enjoyed the unnerved looks on
her soldiers' faces every time she did
that.
A dragon stepped out of the great hall
darting across the hot stones toward
her.
The black diamond patterns on his wings
always reminded Byrne of blister.
So it was difficult not to glare at her
brother every time she saw him, but he
was used to that.
I wasn't expecting you until tomorrow
Smolder said.
His forked tongue flicked in and out.
She narrowed her eyes at him and waited.
After a moment, he remembered and added
Your majesty.
I wasn't expecting you until tomorrow
your majesty.
She didn't appreciate the hint of sarcasm
in his voice, but she wouldn't point it
out in front of her soldiers.
She'd discuss it with him later, somewhere
private, where she could dig her claws
into a scales and get a truly sincere
apology.
How is our guest?
Burne asked, dismissing the soldiers with
a flick of her tail.
Still extraordinarily not pleased to be
here, he said.
You may want to move her to a more empty
chamber.
She's made a bit of a mess of what she
could reach of your collection.
Burn hissed.
Ungrateful cow.
Any word on the dragonettes?
he asked, following her into the great
hall.
They vanished again, she said.
Although there's a rumor going around the
Sky Kingdom, that they are responsible
for torching the northernmost outpost and
killing all those Skywing soldiers, as
some kind of revenge for what Queen
Scarlet did to them.
Smolder folded his wings back and looked
up at her.
Do you think that's likely?
I don't know anything about them, she
said.
In the arena, they didn't seem fierce
enough to kill anything.
But then they attacked Scarlet, so
they're clearly more dangerous than they
look.
She stopped at the long table loaded with
the food that ran down the center of the
hall.
I do know.
I don't like them, she muttered, and I
wish I'd gotten my claws on all of their
eggs before they hatched.
She snatched up a dead hawk and ripped
off its head with one bite, imagining
doing the same to a certain sea wing, or
that insidious rain wing.
It's not going well with Ruby.
Smolder asked.
The supposed new queen of the sky wings
is a bore and a nuisance.
Burns snarled.
She wants to restore order in the sky
kingdom, and establish the stability of
her own throne before engaging in any
more battles at my side.
She's even more difficult than her
annoying mother, and she follows orders
very poorly, if at all.
We haven't had a satisfying battle in
weeks.
I'm considering getting rid of her.
Sounds frustrating.
Smolder slid a platter of dates toward
himself and popped 2 in his mouth.
It is.
I really need to kill something.
It's been too long since I last ripped
out a dragon's throat.
Her brother sidled a few steps away
perhaps thinking he was being
surreptitious, but failing.
Well, he said, there's always your
prisoner.
No, no, Bern corrected him.
Queen Scarlet is our guest for now.
I may change my mind once I decide how
useful she can be.
She glanced out at the blazing sun
reflecting off the courtyard stones.
No.
I have another victim in mind.
Five of them, in fact.
Of course, he said, ducking his head.
You just have to find them first.
Oh, I will, she said.
Everyone will finally shut up about the
wonderful dragonettes of destiny when I
have their heads mounted on spikes on my
walls.
She bared her teeth at her brother, smoke
rising from her nostrils.
Mark my words.
Soon we'll put an end to this prophecy
nonsense once and for all.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 4, The
Dark Secret, by 2AT Sutherland.
A Nightwing Guide to the Dragons of Pira
read by Tui T. Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Sebastian Zettin.
Executive producer Paul R.
Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text copyright 2013 by Tweet T
Sutherland.
Production copyright 2016 by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.
Hi, this is Tooey Sutherland.
A Nightwing Guide to the Dragons of
Pyrea.
Sand wings.
Description.
Pale gold or white scales, the color of
desert sand, Poisonous barbed tail, Forked
black tongues.
Abilities can survive a long time without
water.
Poison enemies with the tips of their
tails like scorpions.
Bury themselves for camouflage in the
desert sand.
Breathe fire.
Queen.
Since the death of Queen Oasis, the tribe
is split between 3 rivals for the
throne.
Sisters burn, blister, and blaze.
Alliances.
Byrne fights alongside Skywings and
Mudwings.
Blister is allied with the sea wings, and
Blaze has the support of most sand wings
as well as an alliance with the ice
wings.
Mudwings.
Description, thick armored brown scales
sometimes with amber and gold
underscales.
Large flat heads with nostrils on top of
the snout.
Abilities, can breathe fire if warm
enough.
Hold their breath for up to an hour, blend
into large mud puddles, usually very
strong.
Queen, Queen Moorhen.
Alliances, currently allied with burn and
the sky wings in the Great War.
Sky Wings.
Description, red gold or orange scales
enormous wings.
Abilities, powerful fighters and flyers
can breathe fire.
Queen, Queen Scarlet.
Alliances, currently allied with burn and
the mud wings in the Great War.
C Wings.
Description, blue or green or aquamarine
scales, webs between their claws, gills
on their necks, glow in the dark stripes
on their tails, snouts, underbellies.
Abilities, can breathe underwater, see in
the dark, create huge waves with one
splash of their powerful tails.
Excellent swimmers.
Queen, Queen Coral.
Alliances, currently allied with blister
in the Great War.
Ice Wings.
Description.
Silvery scales like the moon, or pale
blue like ice.
Ridged claws to grip the ice, forked blue
tongues, tails narrow to a whip thin
end.
Abilities can withstand subzero
temperatures and bright light.
Exhale a deadly, freezing breath.
Queen, Queen Glacier.
Alliances.
Currently allied with Blaze and most of
the sandwings in the Great War.
Rain wings.
Description, scales constantly shift
colors, usually bright like birds of
paradise, prehensile tales.
Abilities, can camouflage their scales to
blend into their surroundings.
Use their prehensile tails for climbing
no known natural weapons.
Queen, Queen dazzling.
Alliances, not involved in the Great
War.
Night Wings.
Description, purplish black scales and
scattered silver scales on the underside
of their wings, like a night sky full of
stars.
Forked black tongues.
Abilities, can breathe fire, disappear
into dark shadows, read minds, foretell
the future.
Queen, a closely guarded secret.
Alliances, too mysterious and powerful to
be part of the war.